WELCOME TO SOMEBODY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEARING APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH AT ABOUT.
ONE THIRTY FIVE CALLING FOR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE THE
COMMITTEE IT SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE APRS ABSENT MEMBERS.
UP FIRST OF ALL WELCOME TO OUR
LAST LOCAL GOVERNMENT HEARING ON
FISCAL ASSEMBLY BILLS.
JUST KEEP A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS TO GO OVER BEFORE WE START.
I HAVE TWENTY EIGHT ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. FIVE ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE MULLIN.
ITEM ELEVEN AB NINE NINE FOUR
MATHIS.
AB TWELVE TO THE ITEM TWELVE AB
TEN EIGHTY NINE STONE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWELVE
TWENTY GARCIA.
AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN CHEN.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED.
WE WILL ALSO HAVE ONE ITEM THAT
WOULD BE HEARD FOR TESTIMONY
ONLY TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
BILLS AND SIGN IN ORDER -- A
COUPLE THINGS ALSO WE WILL HAVE.
YOU CAN HAVE TWO MAIN WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT TO IN OPPOSITION.
AND REPRESENTS BREVITY IS
APPRECIATED TODAY -- WE WILL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BONTA.
AND WE ARE GOING TO BE AS A SUB
COMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET OUR
QUORUM.
OKAY.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MANAGER WITH THE
CHAIRS PERMISSION WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO START WITH A BE
ELEVEN NINETY ONE MY SECOND BILL.
THAT WOULD BE FINE THANK YOU.
THAT WILL BE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
WE'LL START WITH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUE
AND A COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE CITY OF OF OAKLAND AND
OPEN A IS HAVE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER ON A PLAN. FOR A
PRIVATELY FINANCED BALLPARK THAT
WILL ENSURE THE EIGHTIES STAY IN
OAKLAND WE'RE PROUD THAT THEY'VE
BEEN OPEN FOR FIFTY YEARS WE
WANT THEM TO STAY FOR FIFTY
YEARS AND MORE.
AND AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS A
TEN IT INTENDED TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE IN OAKLAND TO
INCLUDE A BASEBALL PARK FOR THE
OAKLAND ATHLETICS AS WELL AS
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING.
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
RETAIL.
MANY.
OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT THIS
PROJECT IS REQUIRED TO MEET
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS.
AND THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE HOWARD TERMINAL SITE
CONSIST OF A PATCHWORK OF
HISTORIC UPLANDS AND FILLED
FORMER THAILAND'S AS WELL AS
SUBMERGED LANDS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT.
BY THE PORT OF OAKLAND THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. FOR THE
CDC ELEVEN NINETY ONE PROVIDES
AUTHORIZATION TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO DETERMINE THE
TITLE AND BOUNDARY UNCERTAINTIES
AS IT RELATES TO THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE.
AND TO APPROVE A TRUST EXCHANGE
THE BILL DOES NOT REMOVE THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION AUTHORITY
OR BE CDCS AUTHORITY THEY RETAIN
ALL THEIR FULL AUTHORITY.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO WORK
COOPERATIVELY WITH THIS MULTI
PARTY GROUP THAT INCLUDES AT THE
PORT AND THE CITY THE CAB THE
COMMISSION AND THE CDC.
AND THIS IS JUST A REALLY
IMPORTANT PROJECT FOR FOR
OAKLAND FOR THE EAST BAY FOR MY
DISTRICT.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT BASEBALL
IT'S ABOUT JOBS TWO THOUSAND
GOOD CONSTRUCTION JOBS THREE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL JOBS AFTER
THAT -- A HUGE ECONOMIC STIMULUS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A NUMBER OF
OTHER REALLY IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
BENEFITS.
AND IT'S REALLY VITAL TO KEEP
OUR OAKLAND A IS ROOTED IN
OAKLAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE A PEEK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
TODAY.
AND WITH ME IN SUPPORT I HAVE
DAVE CAMPBELL THE PRESIDENT OF
THE OAKLAND ETS MOLLY MAY BURN
THE CITY OF OAKLAND PROJECT
MANAGER AND SAYS OUR DS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING TRADES
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
I YES DAVE CAVALIER WITH THE
OAKLAND ACE -- I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY LIKE TO ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP FOR US TO BUILD A
PRIVATELY FINANCED BALLPARK IN
OAKLAND. TO RETAIN THE LAST
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAM IN THE
EAST BAY WE HAVE FIFTY ONE YEARS
OF HISTORY IN THIS COMMUNITY WE
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
HAVE A VIBRANT EXCITING PROJECT
AT THE WATERFRONT.
ON THREE THOUSAND JOBS THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
IMPACT A VARIETY OF BENEFITS
THAT WILL HELP.
WITH THINGS LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AIR QUALITY ON AND SO
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROJECT IT'S ONE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING.
TIME ENERGY RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE IT HAPPENS TO ENSURE WE'RE
HERE FOR MANY GENERATIONS TO
COME.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND WE APPRECIATE
IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AS
READY AS ONLY HALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
OF HONOR TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL A MANY TIMES WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU DIFFERENT
PROPOSES A LOOK AT UPENDING
LOCAL CONTROL.
THIS BILL IS OPPOSITE TO THAT IS
VERY CAREFULLY WRITTEN IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO THE LOCAL
APPROVAL PROCESS IT'S A IT'S A
BUSINESS LABOR COMMUNITY TYPE
AGREEMENT WHERE THERE'S GOING TO
BE A LOT OF COMMUNITY BENEFITS --
SPECIALLY ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SIDE OFTENTIMES YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PROJECTS WHERE THEY
COULD DISPLAY CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THIS PROJECT SITE
DOES NOT CHOOSE VERY CAREFULLY
SELECTED BUT IT DOES NEED THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL TAKEN
ALLOWED TO BE.
MOVED FORWARD FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
CHAIRPERSON AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS MOLLY MAE BROWN I AM
HERE REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
OAKLAND MAYOR SHOP APOLOGIZES
THAT SHE COULD NOT BE HERE IN
PERSON BUT HAS ASKED ME TO
EXPRESS HER STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
A BI -- ELEVEN NINETY ONE THIS
BILL WILL FACILITATE AS STATED
BY MY COLLEAGUES THE
REDEVELOPMENT OF HOWARD TERMINAL
WITH A WORLD CLASS FACILITY. TO
RETAIN THE LAST MAJOR LEAGUE
SPORTS FRANCHISE IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND.
IN ADDITION -- THIS MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC AND COMMUNITY BENEFITS
TO THE CITY AND PEOPLE OF
OAKLAND.
INCLUDING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THREE THOUSAND NEW UNITS OF
HOUSING INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
NEW JOBS AND AND EQUALLY
IMPORTANTLY MAKING OUR WATER
FRONT A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
OUR WATER FRONT ACCESSIBLE FOR
PUBLIC USE AND ENJOYMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE SMALL ROOM
TODAY EVERYBODY IS IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFICULT BECAUSE AND IT'S
REALLY NOISY.
I APOLOGIZE.
DILLON GIVENS -- LIFELONG
OAKLAND ATHLETICS FAN -- SUPPORT
OF THE AUTHORS -- BILL TO KEEP
THE ATHLETICS IN OAKLAND.
THANK YOU TO THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY FOR ALL OF THEIR EFFORTS.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE ROB
STOKER REPRESENTING THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AS WELL AS A
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YEAH THERE ARE NO THE BILL I
THINK.
OKAY.
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHEN WE NEED TO SWITCH
[inaudible]
TO GREAT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MIKE CHECK WITH PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION IF
YOU BRING THAT LITTLE BIT CLOSER --
CANNOT NOISE SEEING WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE SILENT -- MIKE
TICKET WHIPS OF MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILLS AFTERNOON --
REPRESENTING A BROAD COALITION
INCLUDING THE SANDALS HERE FROM
THE AISLE W. -- RIVER AND A
NUMBER OF OF ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE VIABILITY OF THE PORT OF
OAKLAND.
ISSUES RANGING FROM CONGESTION
ON THE WATER TO CONGESTION WITH
TRUCKS COMING IN AND OUT OF OUR
FACILITIES -- AND BASIC
INCOMPATIBILITY OF LAND USE
ISSUES WHICH WE KNOW THIS
COMMUNITY I'M SORRY THIS
COMMITTEE IS IS INTERESTED IN.
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE
SACRIFICING OUR ABILITY TO USE.
OUR DEDICATED THAILAND STRESS
RESOURCES BETTER DEDICATED TO
WATERFRONT USES -- AND
SURRENDERED TO USES WHICH ARE
PURELY MUNICIPAL OR LOCAL --
REGIONAL IN NATURE BUT DON'T
NEED TO BE WATER DEPENDENT.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE
SETTING UP A PROCESS FOR THE ETS
AND THEIR STADIUM AND THEIR
HOUSING AND THEIR COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT -- TO BE
ABLE.
TO LOOK AT A PROPERTY IN A WAY
WHICH IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH --
THE CURRENCY POOR PLAN OR WITH
THE RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE IN
THAILAND'S TRUSTS AND
ADMINISTERED BY STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
WE ACTUALLY REFLECT TO REALLY
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR PUTTING IN
THE CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT
HE PUT IN AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO -- TO CLARIFY
THAT THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OF
THE BILL WITH RESPECT TO BE CDC.
BUT WITH RESPECTTO THE PROJECT
IS MOVING FORWARD THE INTENT
THAT YOU HEARD TODAY FROM THE A
IS AN FROM THE CITY IS THAT THEY
DO INTEND TO HAVE HOUSING ON THE
SIDE.
THAT ISN'T CURRENTLY LAWFUL AT
AND CONSISTENT WITH THE TIME
ONCE TRUST RESTRICTIONS SO
THAT'S A PROCESS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE.
LOOKING AT AS THIS MOVES FORWARD
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
RESTRICTIONS WORSE REMAIN ON
SITE AND IF THEY ARE REMOVED.
THAT WHEN THEY'RE REMOVED THEIR
DONE IN A WAY WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH WITH OUR VISION.
FOR MAKING SURE THE WATER FROM
HIS PRIMARY USE FOR THE SITE AND
AND MAKING THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
A SEAPORT THAT'S WORKING -- AND
ITS ITS HIGHEST OPTIMAL LEVEL.
GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU AND ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF MY NAME IS A LEASE AND ALL.
AND I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE WAREHOUSE UNIONS.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL WHICH REPRESENTS
SEVENTEEN LOCALS FROM EUREKA.
DOWN TO FRESNO -- WE ARE OPPOSED
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE BECAUSE THE
BILL WILL ELIMINATE CURRENT
PUBLIC TRUST PROTECTIONS.
AT HOWARD TERMINAL FOUR DAYS
BALLPARK PLAN -- THE PUBLIC
TRUST PROTECTIONS FOR RESERVE
WATERWAYS FOR NATURAL HABITAT
PROTECTION AND MARITIME
ACTIVITIES.
THIS HAS ALLOWED THE PORT OF
OAKLAND TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL IN THE WEST COAST.
OPEN SUPPORT IS A ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY.
AND SEAPORT ACTIVITY AT THE PORT
SUPPORTS MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IN DIRECT WAGES AND
SALARY FOR INDUSTRIAL DRIVES.
THAT SUPPORT THE LIVELIHOODS OF
MANY BAY AREA RESIDENTS.
THIS IS EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
JOBS REGION WIDE IN 20% OF THOSE
840-001-7000 JOBS ARE IN THE
CITY OF OAKLAND.
THE LEGISLATION FAILS TO ADDRESS
POLICIES. TO MAINTAIN CURRENT
MARITIME INDUSTRY JOBS IN THE
PORT AREA.
IT DOES NOT ADDRESS.
A BUFFER AREA BETWEEN THE
WORKING POOR IN THE PROPOSED
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING.
THE BILL ALSO WAS LACKING.
REALISTIC SOLUTIONS. TO FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION CONGESTION.
OUR MARITIME WORKFORCE
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
SKILLED IN HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
BLUE COLLAR LABOR IN NORTH
AMERICA.
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IN A SPORT
COMMISSION SEEM TO HAVE A NEW
VISION OF THE PORT.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE US.
THIS IS TROUBLING AND CONCERNING
BECAUSE IT REDUCES THE PORT AREA
WHICH WAS REDUCES MARITIME WORK
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR THE MARITIME
COMMUNITY.
THE LEGISLATION SHOULD NOT A
RESOURCE SHOULD NOT ENDORSE A
REMOVAL.
OF THE THAILAND STRESSED FROM
THE WATERFRONT PROPERTY WITHIN
THE PORT OF OAKLAND OR ALLOW FOR
THE CREATION OF A HOUSING.
SLASH OFFICE SLASH STADIUM SLASH
COMPLEX.
WHICH IS COMPLETELY INCONSISTENT
WITH THE PUBLIC TRUST ON A
WORKING WATERFRONT.
WE RESPECTIVELY -- WE
RESPECTIVELY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO TAKE OUR CONCERNS INTO DEEP
CONSIDERATION.
AND TO PROTECT OUR MARITIME
RELATED JOBS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THEIR
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JOSHUA SHAH FOR SCHNITZER STEEL
INDUSTRIES OPPOSED TO THE
INCOMPATIBLE USES PROPOSED AT
THE SITE.
ARE THERE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MORE INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
I. O. W. IN OPPOSITION HOW WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY WORKERS
OUTSIDE.
THE CAPITAL THEY CAN MAKE IT IN
TO TESTIFY ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE IS
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR THERE ARE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOBS.
JOBS THAT CAN BE REPLACED WE CAN
HAVE.
THERE'S WORKERS FIND JOBS ARE
ANYWHERE OUTSIDE WE ASK FOR
NOBLE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
MERRIMAN GOVERNOR TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ALL THE
OPPOSITION -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT SEEING KNOWING AND THE
NEED A MOTION.
I WOULD HAVE A QUORUM AT THAT SO
SORRY -- SO WE'LL WAIT TO WE
HAVE A QUORUM -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
AS THE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
AGAIN THIS IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BILL THAT MOVES FORWARD A
PROJECT THAT ADDRESSES MANY OF
THAT.
MOST BURNING CONCERNS AND ISSUES
IN IN OAKLAND HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- JOB CREATION AND OUR
INTENT IS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AN HAS ALWAYS BEEN. TO AT CO
EXIST IN A WAY THAT CONTINUES TO
ALLOW FOR A SUCCESSFUL PORT
OPERATION AS WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP AND BRIGHT OF OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUCCESSES IN
OAKLAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL MISTER BONTA AND DOING
SO IS THAT I HAVE FULL
CONFIDENCE IN YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO NEGOTIATE -- WITH YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS -- AND TO WITH THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION.
AND SO -- WITH THAT -- I WILL
REALLY BE -- SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY AND WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM WE CAN GO THROUGH THAT
OKAY.
A MEDICARE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU STAFF.
OKAY NOW YOU CAN DO -- IF HE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE THE MISTAKE ON
IF YOU COULD JUST HOLD JUST SO
WE GET THE NEXT CREW OUT
[inaudible]
SORRY
.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE REDISTRICTING.
IS OF CRUCIAL IMPORTANCE TO
LOCAL DEMOCRACY HOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
ELECTION.
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN CAN HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A
COMMUNITY WILL BE FAIRLY
REPRESENTED AT THEIR MOST
INTIMATE AND CLOSEST LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT UNLIKE STATE LEVEL
REDISTRICTING.
THERE ARE VERY FEW REQUIREMENTS
GOVERNING LOCAL.
REDISTRICTING TO ENSURE THE
PROCESS IS FAIR AND TRANSPARENT
AND THAT THE PUBLIC AND
ESPECIALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES.
ARE ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS
CURRENTLY LOCAL DISTRICT MAPS
CAN BE DRAFTED THEN INTRODUCED
AND ADOPTED AT THE SAME.
MEETING WITHOUT FIRST BEING
PUBLISHED AND SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS NO PUBLIC
OUTRAGE REQUIREMENT INCLUDING TO
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE AWARE
OF THE PROCESS AB EIGHT FORTY
NINE WILL BRING TRANSPARENCY AND
CREATE CLEAR STANDARDS.
THAT WOULD BE SIMILAR TO THOSE
OF STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL
REDISTRICTING REQUIREMENTS THIS
BILL WAS AMENDED COMING OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CONCERNS.
AS THIS BILL MOVES AHEAD I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
WE ACHIEVE A STRONG BILL THAT
GIVES DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES A VOICE AND
ESTABLISHES A FAIR.
LOCAL REDISTRICTING PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
MEMBERS WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE R. NICHOLAS HEIGHT
ONE POLICY AND LEGAL DIRECTORY.
DIRECTOR OF COMMON CAUSE
CALIFORNIA AND JONATHAN STEIN
HEAD OF VOTING RIGHTS AND SENSES
PROGRAMS AT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- MEMBERS
NICKEL SIDE ON WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE.
FAIR REDISTRICTING IS CRUCIAL AT
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT ENSURE
REPRESENTATIVE AND INCLUSIVE
DEMOCRACY.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO A GOOD
JOB OF ENCOURAGING THE RESIDENTS
PARTICIPATING REDUCING PROCESS
AND DRAWING MAPS OF LOGICAL
BOUNDARIES TO REFLECT THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER MANY OTHER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO NOT.
UNFORTUNATELY IN MANY INSTANCES
USING THE REDUCING PROCESS ABUSE
IN A WAY THAT UNDERMINES
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY BY CRACKING
COMMUNITIES BE IT RURAL
COMMUNITIES WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OR MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
THE WAY THE DILUTES THE POWER
OTHER VOTE MAKES A MUCH LESS
LIKELY SELECTIVE FISHEL'S WILL
BE RESPONSIVE TO THEIR CONCERNS.
THIS IS IN SIGNIFICANT PART
BECAUSE UNLIKE WAS STATE
REDUCING THEIR ALMOST NO
MANDATORY STANDARDS FOR LOCAL
REDISTRICTING TO PREVENT ABUSE.
FOR EXAMPLE UNLIKE FOR STATE RE
DISTINCT THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
FOR LOCAL REDUCING THE
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE HOLE.
IN FACT OTHER THAN EQUAL
POPULATION THERE NO MANDATORY
STANDARDS AT ALL FOR LOCAL
REDUCING JUST DISCRETIONARY
CONSIDERATIONS A CAN AND OFTEN
ARE IGNORED.
AND UNLIKE THE STATE'S EXTENSIVE
HEARING PROCESS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST HOLD JUST ONE
PUBLIC HEARING FOR DEDUCTING
MAPS.
OF NO PUBLIC OUR REACH
REQUIREMENTS.
AS A RESULT IN FORCING MANY
UNDER REPRESENT COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY FAILED TO
PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL REDUCING
PROCESS IT MAY NOT EVEN BE AWARE
THIS IS OCCURRING.
THE SPLITTING OF NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO THE STARK UNDER
REPRESENTATION OF RACIAL
MINORITIES IN CALIFORNIA LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
JUST LAST YEAR KERN COUNTY LOS
LAWSUIT FOR DRAWING LINES AT THE
LIVES OF THE VOTING POWER OF
LATINOS AND LAST CYCLE MANY
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE LACKEY SO YOUR MOUTH F..
REPEATEDLY OBJECTED TO MINORITY
COMMUNITIES BEING SPLIT THROUGH
LOCAL REDUCING UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
AB EIGHT FOUR NINE FOR MAPS ACT
IS INTENDED TO BE A SAFETY NET
TO STOP THE WORST OF THESE
REDUCING ABUSES.
DOES SO BY ESTABLISHING
MANDATORY RANK REDUCING CRITERIA
THAT ARE CLOSELY MODELED OFF THE
STATE CRITERIA SO KEEPING
NEIGHBORHOODS AND COMMUNITIES
WILL BE PRIORITIZED IN THE
PROCESS.
THE BILL ALSO BANDS FOR THE
FIRST TIME PARTISAN
GERRYMANDERING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AB EIGHT FOUR NINE ALSO REQUIRES
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION PUTTING MINIMUM
FOR HEARINGS REQUIREMENT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENGAGE IN
BASIC COMMUNITY OUR REGION.
SO DIVERSE CAME CONSTITUENCIES
INCLUDING NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
ONCE OR WHERE THE PROCESS CAN
ADVOCATE FOR LINES THE BEST FOR
LIKE THE COMMUNITIES.
TOGETHER THESE CHANGES WE THINK
WILL CONTRIBUTE TO MORE
REPRESENTATIVE INCLUSIVE AN
ACCOUNT OF A LOCAL MARK SEE FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE URGE AND I
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE YOU
MOVE ON WITH HOPE RESPECTFULLY
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO I JUST WANT
TO HAVE -- OR SECRETARY TAKE THE
ROLES WE CAN MOVE ON TODAY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE LACKEY.
LACKEY HERE.
BLOOM BURNER HORVATH.
BURNER HER OF HER WRATH HERE
RAMOS.
RAMOS HERE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
YOU -- MY NAME IS JONATHAN STEIN
I'M WITH ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS ONE OF SEVERAL CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
EIGHT FOUR NINE I'M HERE TO
SHARE A STORY WITH YOU OF WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE -- WHEN THE STORY
OF A CITY THAT TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING RIGHT IN A DISTURBING
PROCESS BUT STILL EXEMPLIFIED
WHY THIS BILL IS NECESSARY?
SO IN A CITY SHIP FROM OUT LARGE
DISTRICT ELECTIONS IT HAS TO
HOLD FOR HEARINGS THE CITY OF
FREMONT GOT A NOTICE LETTER
UNDER THE C. B. R. A. BEGAN A
SHIFT TO DISTRICTS.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT AFTER TWO
HEARINGS HAD BEEN COMPLETED AND
DRAFT MAPS THAT ARE THEN
PUBLISHED.
THE DRAFT MAPS SPLIT THE CITY'S
AFGHAN COMMUNITY INTO TWO OR
THREE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
DEPENDING ON THE MAP.
YOU MAY KNOW THAT FREMONT IS
HOME TO THE WORLD'S LARGEST
AFGHAN POPULATION OUTSIDE OF
AFGHANISTAN.
AND YET BECAUSE THE AFGHAN
COMMUNITY HAS NO VOICE IN THE
CITY'S POLITICS NO AFGHANS HAVE
BEEN CONSULTED IN THE PROCESS
AND THE DRAFT MAPS HAD ENDED UP --
GERRYMANDERING THEM INTO
MULTIPLE DISTRICTS.
WE IMMEDIATELY DROPPED OUR OTHER
PRODUCTS WE BORROWED IN THE
ASKING COMMUNITY WE BEGIN
EDUCATING THE COMMUNITY ABOUT
DISTRICTS ABOUT.
HOW THEY CAN GET INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS AND REPAIR THEM TO STEP
FORWARD AND GIVE TESTIMONY?
IN THE FIRST TWO DISTRICTING
HEARINGS THERE IS ZERO AFGHANS
PRESENT IN THE LAST TWO AFGHANS
OVER HALF OF THE SPEAKERS NONE
OF THEM HAVE EVER SPOKEN TO
THEIR CITY COUNCIL BEFORE.
THEY SPOKE PASSIONATELY
SOMETIMES THE TRANSLATOR BUT HOW
IMPORTANT FREMONT WANTS THE
AFGHAN COMMUNITY AND HOW
IMPORTANT THE AFGHAN COMMUNITY
WAS TO FREMONT.
THEY SPOKE ABOUT FINDING A NEW
HOME AFTER WITHIN ONE TORN BY
WAR AND THEY FELT THEY SPOKE
ABOUT A FEELING LISTEN TO IN
THEIR NEW HOME.
THE LONG STORY SHORT IS THE MAPS
WERE REDRAWN AND THE AFGHAN
CULTURAL AND COMMERCIAL HUB WAS
KEPT TOGETHER INTO ONE DISTRICT
IT WAS A VICTORY FOR
REPRESENTATION IN A FAIR
DEMOCRACY.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
NO ONE OTHER THAN US REACHED OUT
TO THE AFGHAN COMMUNITIES AND
TOLD THEM THAT THIS PROCESS WAS
EVEN HAPPENING.
IF WE HAD A DECIDED TO DO THAT
THAT VICTORY WOULDN'T OF
HAPPENED.
THESE ARE WORKING FOLKS THEY
CAN'T TAKE KMART TIME OFTEN THE
DAY IF THOSE MEETINGS HAD IT
BEEN A NIGHT.
THIS VICTORY WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
THERE WERE NO TRANSLATORS ON
HAND -- OTHER THAN COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE WILLING TO HELP
THEIR FELLOW -- NEIGHBORS IF
THAT WASN'T TRUE THIS VICTORY
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED AND IT TOOK
US TIME TO ORGANIZE AND TO
EDUCATE AND TO MOBILIZE IF
THERE'D BEEN JUST ONE HEARING AS
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND
REDISTRICTING.
THAT VICTORY WOULDN'T OF
HAPPENED.
IN FREMONT LITERALLY EVERYTHING
WENT RIGHT NOW -- BUT IF ONE
THING HADN'T THAT COMMUNITY
WOULD HAVE BEEN SLICED AND DICED
IN SILENCE FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE DAY OF THE OF THAT MISTER
MAPPING IN PLACE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
CREATE LOCAL REDISTRICTING
PROCESS SEES WHERE THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN WHAT COMMUNITIES HAVE A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO MAKE
THEMSELVES HEARD AND DRAWING A
TRAP MAPS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT -- A NUMBER
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATION
FEEL AS THOUGH THAT THERE COMPLY
THERE'S A COMPLIANCE BURDEN
INVOLVED WITH THIS BILL AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH MANY WITH THOSE TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
HOWEVER THE BURDENS TO VOTERS.
LIVING UNDER DEMOCRATIC SYSTEMS
THEY DON'T FULLY REPRESENT THEM
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THEIR
NEEDS THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE THE
COMMUNITIES THE MEANT TO SERVE
THAT ITSELF IS A FORMER BURDEN
AS WELL.
UP WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON A BE A
FOUR NINE THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
I'M SORRY.
I'M CATALINA FLORES ON THE LOCAL
PRESIDENT OF REALTORS ABOUT THE
NEW BLACK I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE STATE LITTLE ACT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
WE'RE VERY HAPPY ABOUT HAVING
SOMETHING FINALLY.
PERHAPS AT THE NO POPULATION
WILL HAVE EQUAL REPRESENTATION
IN THE GOVERNMENT AT ALL LEVELS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THINGS AND
WRITTEN IN OUR LANGUAGE WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE.
INVOLVED IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
THIS IS WHAT AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
PROMISES I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU
WILL VOTE FOR THIS AND THIS IS A
MOMENT OF HISTORY WE WILL HAVE
YOUR NAME STONE WAS VOTING FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND MOVE FOR
JUST YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION --
BUT TILING YOUR POSITION PLEASE
YOUR ROSE.
OVER VOTERS A CALIFORNIA DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IS CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT AND I'VE BEEN
DEPUTIZED BY MI FAMILIA VOTED TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
I EVAN MINTON VOICES FOR
PROGRESS WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
MY ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT
.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN END THE
SOUTH OF SACRAMENTO SENIOR
CITIZENS ALLIANCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI UNDER HER ERA RESIDENTS
STOCKTON IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO TANYA PELLEGRINI WITH THE
MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NO WAY BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I CITY WEBER SACRAMENTAL HIS
SUPPORT ALSO LIKED -- CRITERIA
TO INCLUDE MULTI MEMBER
DISTRICTS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT GUT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
DâN HUTCHINGS WITHIN THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES -- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- YOU
KNOW I THINK FROM FROM A
HOLISTIC STANDPOINT -- WE WE
STILL CONTEND THAT -- YOU KNOW
OVER THE PAST DECADE THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AS WORKS IN
COLLABORATION -- WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE ON
SEVERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT
RELATED MEASURES REDISTRICTING
MEASURES PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
ISSUES AND AND THE LIKE.
WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD WHEN WE
SAW YOU KNOW THE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MEMBERS EVER DROPPED
IN INTO THE MEASURE WITHOUT ANY
WARNING OR ANY.
WORK TOWARDS COLLABORATION ON
THE FRONT AND RATHER THAN HAVING
TO BE REACTIVE AND AND AND
OPPOSE AND SO UNFORTUNATELY
STILL DO OPPOSE THE BILL -- YOU
KNOW WITH THE THE THE FREMONT
EXAMPLE I THINK OUR MEMBERS DO
TAKE SOME EXCEPTION TO TO THE
THE EXAMPLE I OUTLINED BY THE
SPONSORS -- THIS IS ALSO THE
SAME YOU KNOW WHEN WE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIFTY WITH THESE WITH
THESE FOLKS AS CO SPONSORS --
THERE WILL BE THE SAME GENTLEMAN
WHO TESTIFIED AROUND THE FREMONT
ISSUE WAS ALSO THE SAME
GENTLEMAN WHO -- SPOKE TO ALL OF
MY MEMBERS AND THANKING THEM FOR
COLLABORATION AND AND ACTUALLY
SAYING THAT WE NEED MORE TIME
FOR OUTREACH WITH REGARDS TO THE
PROVISIONS OF AB THREE FIFTY
WHICH THE LEAGUE WASN'T STRONG
SUPPORTER OF HOWEVER.
SOME OF THE OTHER FOLKS -- ON
THE COALITION OR NOT THEY WANTED
A TIGHTER TIME LINE -- SUFFICE
IT TO SAY -- CITIES HAVE BEEN
GOOD ACTORS IN THE SPACE -- THE
MEASURE -- EVEN AS AMENDED
REQUIRES A TO SIX PUBLIC
HEARINGS -- DIFFERENT LOCATIONS --
AFTER SIX PM AND ON WEEKENDS --
LIVE TRANSLATION SERVICES FOR A
FOR A FOR ALL APPLICABLE
LANGUAGES FOR EACH YOU KNOW
ASKED TERM BY THE CENSUS.
AUDIO VISUAL RECORDINGS WHY WE
HAVE TO CREATE A WHOLE HOST OF
NEW WEB WEB PAGES WITHIN OUR
WITH OUR WEBSITE -- NEW REPORTS
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
REQUIRED -- MAPS MAPS AND
MEETING POSTINGS THAT EXCEED THE
BROWN ACTING AS WE KNOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS FOLKS HERE WHO
HAVE SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
KNOW JUST HOW STRANGE IN THE
BROWN ACT IS -- HOW WE HAVE CITY
OFFICIALS AND CITY STAFF REALLY
TRY IN IN STRUGGLE TO COMPLY
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN
ACT -- NOW THIS ADDITIONAL
POSTING OF SEVEN DAYS -- TO
DIFFERENT FOR THESE NASTY POSTED
UP FIVE DAYS TO AN ADVANCE FOR
FOR PUBLIC HEARINGS -- BUT YOU
KNOW IT NOT TO MENTION THE CAT
TO THE FACT THAT WHICH I DO KNOW
THAT SOMEONE OUT OF THE PURVIEW
OF THIS COMMITTEE -- BUT THE
ABSOLUTE ABSORBENT COSTS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE HAD THERE AT
THAT IS GOING TO BE BURDEN WAIT
WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
OF UNFUNDED OR SUSPENDED
MANDATES WE'VE SEEN IT SINCE --
TWO THOUSAND FOUR ELECTIONS
ELECTION COST HAD NOT BEEN
REIMBURSED TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL -- YOU KNOW.
I I THINK FROM A FROM A HOLISTIC
STANDPOINT -- AND I SAID THIS IN
THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AS WELL
I THINK THIS BILL MAKES A BROAD
ASSUMPTION THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ACTIVELY WORKING
AGAINST TO DISENFRANCHISE.
THE VOTERS SAID THAT THEY
REPRESENT AND WE RE WE SHOULD WE
TAKE STRONG EXCEPTION TO THIS
BECAUSE IF YOU YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT THE EXAMPLES FROM THE
SPONSORS WERE REALLY DUMBFOUNDED
AS TO WHY WE COULDN'T WORK
CLOBBER LEE ON THIS ARE ASK IS
THAT YOU SAY NO TO THIS.
BILL TODAY WE WE WE DO NOT MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS VEHICLE WE
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO HAVE TO
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS
INTRODUCED A VEHICLE THAT WE CAN
ALL GET BEHIND -- WE REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DEALING GIVENS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
THIS TIME -- THIS FOR THE LAST
DECADE -- THE LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
ENCOURAGING -- PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO MOVE TO BUY DISTRICT
ELECTIONS.
AND NOW WITH THIS BILL WE'RE
GOING TO PUT A HUGE UNFUNDED
MANDATES AND WE'RE WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO MAKE -- MAKE THIS CHANGE
THEY ALSO THOSE WHO ARE BEEN
CONSIDERING MAKING THE CHANGE ON
THEIR OWN VERSUS BEING FORCED TO
DO SO -- BY LAWSUITS ARE LIKELY
GOING TO CHOOSE TO NOT MOVE TO
BUY DISTRICT ELECTIONS KNOWING
THAT IF THEY MAKE THE SWITCH.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO INCUR
ALL OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT EVEN A NUMBER OF OUR
SPECIAL DISTRICTS JUST BY VIRTUE
OF THE TYPE OF AGENCY THEY ARE
AREN'T EVEN ELIGIBLE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT EVEN IF THE STATE
WERE.
TO REIMBURSE THE PUBLIC AGENCIES
THROUGH THE BAD DATE.
SAYS A LOT OF SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ON EVEN ELIGIBLE. FOR JUST FOR
THIS COMMITTEE THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT SERVE THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IF THAT NOW UNDERSTAND THAT MOST
OF THEM AT THIS POINT ART BY
DISTRICT ELECTIONS IN THIS WOULD
APPLY TO THEM.
BUT THERE THE THAT THOSE NUMBERS
ARE RAPIDLY CHANGING IF WE TOOK.
AND JUST SAID THAT THAT THEY HAD
TO DO FOR MEETINGS EACH NOT EVEN
THE SIX ARE REQUIRED BY THE BY
THIS BILL SPECIAL DISTRICT WILL
BE HOLDING FOURTEEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MEETINGS ON
REDISTRICTING IN YOUR JUST IN
YOUR DISTRICTS THAT'S JUST A
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE SCHOOL.
DISTRICTS THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THE CITIES THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE
THE COUNTIES.
DURING THIS PROCESS WE'RE ALSO
GONNA BE TRYING TO REACH OUT AND
CONTRACT -- FOR MAPPING
CONSULTANTS TO SHOW UP TO THESE
MEETINGS.
THERE SIMPLY AREN'T ENOUGH
MAPPING CONSULTANTS IN EXISTENCE
RIGHT NOW TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROCESS.
ALSO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE OUR LEGAL
COUNSEL AT THESE MEETINGS.
THAT'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
HOURS -- PIECE FOR MOST OF THESE
BUT A LOT OF TIME CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS SHARE THIS
COUNCIL SWITCH MEETINGS ARE THEY
GONNA GO.
TO THEIR THESE MEETINGS AGAIN BE
HAPPENING THE SAME TIME NIGHTS
WEEKENDS DIFFERENT LOCATIONS.
THE THE THE IT IS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
A PUBLIC AGENCIES TO COMPLY WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL.
LET ALONE IT IS IT'S IT'S GOING
TO COST THEM A TON AND THEY'RE
NOT GONNA GETTING THAT MONEY
BACK SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
POST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEAN HEARST HERE TAMMY HAVE THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA WITHIN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SWEEPING MANDATE THAT'S
CONTAINED IN THE BILL AND THE
RESULTING COSTS THAT WILL.
BE IMPOSED ON COUNTIES.
WE ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
SUSPENDED MANDATES AND WE'RE
DOING A LOT IN ELECTIONS RIGHT
NOW IS A CONSIDERABLE BURDEN
THAT.
WE THINK IS UNMANAGEABLE AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NAME AND
POSITION AND I WOULD BE GOOD
JEFF KNEW OVER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
JEANS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION -- WHEN
THEY COULD BE PRESENT THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE SORRY LAWS
I WAS ALSO ASKED? FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS ACCESS ALSO
OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO OTHER
WITNESSES OPPOSITION A QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
NO QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE I
NEED A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH AT
THIS.
BILL IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL
INCREASES ENGAGEMENT
TRANSPARENCY IT ALSO GIVES A
VOICE TO VULNERABLE AND
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE IT NOW. TO BE CLEAR
NO ONE NO ONE IS ACCUSING ANYONE
OF INTENTIONALLY DISENFRANCHISE
ANYONE.
WE ARE SEEING THE PROCESS NOW --
FOR REDISTRICTING IS IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO GET OUR VOICES IN
THE ROOM TO PROVIDE FAIR
REPRESENTATIONS OR TRYING TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS.
AND AND A FAIR PROCESS WILL LEAD
TO FAIR MAPS -- SO I THINK THIS
IS A BILL THAT REALLY -- WELL UP
WITH COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THAT
ARE BEING LEFT OUT RIGHT NOW AND
WILL PROVIDE MORE FAIRNESS IN
MORE GOOD GOVERNMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- I'M VERY SYMPATHETIC
TO THE COST CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED TODAY TRUST ME BEEN
THERE DONE THAT COST IS A BIG
ISSUE.
BUT I'M ALSO FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE INTENT BEHIND SPILLED
INCREASE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IN
THE REGION JUST AGREEING PROCESS.
AND IMPROVE REPRESENTATION FOR A
LOCAL GOVERNING BODIES -- I FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT THAT WORKING WITH
MR BONTA -- HE'LL HELP YOU GET
OVER SOME OF THE HURDLES THAT WE
HAVE.
AND YOU HAVE AND I HOPE THAT THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUES AND I
FEEL THAT YOU WILL -- FOLLOW UP
WITH THAT AS WELL SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT TODAY AND
DIXIE WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY NO LACKEY
NO BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
THE BILL THE WELL WE'RE STILL IN
ONE VOTE IN STONE WALL FIND OUT.
THE MANAGER THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU STAFF [inaudible]
MR BONTA.
I WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR AB ONE ONE NINE ONE
THAT WAS HEARD A MINUTE AGO ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
THIRTEEN NUMBER.
THIRTEEN I KNOW I'M SORRY.
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THEY WERE JUST READ WE JUST DO
IN THE VOTE ON YOUR BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER OF THAT
RAMOS RAMESSIDE THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS I
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING.
THAT'S HOW.
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE WHAT
DO WE DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
EVERY MOTION A SECOND.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY I'M AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER VAST RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL AYE.
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE MISTER GREAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS AS ARE ANY
PARTICULAR ORDER THE YOU'D LIKE
TO TAKE THOSE MAY TAKE IT UP
FORTY FOUR FIRST PLEASE BE GREAT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL BE.
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE MAY.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT BY UC
BERKELEY'S TURNER CENTER FOUND
THAT DEVELOPMENT FEES CAN BE AT
THE CAN BE DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE.
ARE HIGHLY VARIABLE ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT PROJECTS
ARE OFTEN SUBJECT TO ADDITIONAL
EXTRACT EXACTIONS NOT CODIFIED
IN ANY FEE SCHEDULE.
ALL OF THESE FACTORS COMBINED TO
MAKE DEVELOPMENT RISKIER MORE
COSTLY AND ALTERNATELY SERVE TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING THE
GETS BUILT IN OUR STATE.
THE BILL ALSO WILL REQUIRE A
LOCAL AGENCY TO POST ON ITS
WEBSITE.
A LIST OF ALL FEES APPLICABLES
TO A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECT
THIS SIMPLE CHANGE TO EXISTING
LAW WILL ADD MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
AND I HAVE TO WITNESSES THE
WITNESSES TODAY THAT I WILL ASK
TO SELF INTRODUCE RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DANGER BECAUSE IT ARM I
AM THE SCIENTISTS AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION CBA IS PLEASED TO CO.
SPONSOR AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
BY THE HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON A BILL THAT REQUIRES
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO POST ON
THE INTERNET THE TYPE AND AMOUNT.
OF DEVELOPMENT FEES IMPOSED ON A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MANY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DO NOT PUBLISH THE
SCHEDULES OR PROVIDE ESTIMATES
OF THOSE FEES AND THE AFFECTED
THESE FEES.
ON HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS HARD
TO OVERSTATE.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR SIX
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY BRINGING
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PROCESS FOR THIS REASON CB I A
SUPPORTS FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS BRING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
WHERE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
PRODUCTION PRESERVATION OF LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
POLICE TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS FELLOW -- AND AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE DEATH OF A
CONTINUING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
AND BILLS LIKE THE THIS ONE AND
THAT ONE WILL TALK ABOUT NEXT --
HELP ENSURE THAT THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE PUT FORWARD TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS ARE NARROWLY TAILORED
AND SPECIFIC TO TO DEAL WITH THE
THE THE ACTUAL PROBLEMS THAT OUR
DRIVER TODAY.
THANK YOU ARE THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAILY COVERAGE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS ALSO HAPPY TO BE A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
DRIVE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
LOUIS BRONTE WITH CALIFORNIA BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHRIS MOUNT BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT -- MATT REGION FROM
BAY AREA COUNCIL OR THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY EMPLOYER MEMBERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL IN WAS SO COMPELLING
HOME IN SUPPORT.
HOWEVER MANY WITH LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ALTHOUGH ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KEEP THE ROUTE WITH ENTERPRISE
CAN YOU PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MAY JUST SEPARATE SO I AM TO SEE
COMMISSIONER HERE MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI DAVID ON THE OF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING UP TO SEE COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
TONY BLAIR WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SUFFICIENT YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY.
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THIS IS
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE SEE NO OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WE ARE MOST.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE.
AND CHAIR RECOMMENDS TO PASS.
US SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER BACK RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
IMAGE.
MEASURES UP FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO WE'LL GO TO NEXT
BILL THAT WOULD BE A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY WAITING ON WITNESSES
THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY I'LL START.
THE COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
ONCE AGAIN MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND NOTE
THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. TOO MUCH OF THE
HOUSING DATA COLLECTED AT THE
STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL
IS NOT ASSESSABLE STANDARDIZED
WERE ORGANIZED IN A MANNER THAT
LEVERAGES OUR EXTENSIVE
COMMUNITY OF HOUSING.
RESEARCHERS AND ADVOCATES TO
ADDRESS THIS THE SHORTFALL A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HAS.
THERE ARE TWO VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND BETTER DATA.
ON THE TRANSPARENCY SIDE THE
BILL REQUIRES CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO PUBLISH A VARIETY OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE
DATA.
INCLUDING FEES APPLICABLES A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS IT
ALSO REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
REPORT ON INFORMATION THAT WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE PROGRESS
THEY ARE MAKING ON APPROVING
HOUSING INCLUDING.
THE NUMBER OF DISCRETIONARY
PERMITS BUILDING PERMITS AND
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY THEY
HAVE ISSUED ON THE DATA SIDE A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE PARCEL DATE DATABASE
THAT WILL PROVIDE AN OPEN AND
FLEXIBLE FRAMEWORK FOR
ORGANIZING THE STATE'S HOUSING
DATA.
FINALLY THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE A
CD TO DEVELOP A TEN YEAR DATA
STRATEGY.
IN THE STATE HOUSING PLAN TO
ENSURE THAT ALL FUTURE DATA
REQUIREMENTS ARE COORDINATED AND
THAT JURISDICTION'S ARE
SUPPORTED IN THEIR ROLES. TO
EXPLAIN THE IMPACT OF THESE
POLICY CHANGES I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY EMPTY --
IN DC COMMISSIONER NICK TO
SUFFER WHAT'S AND ANDREW BECAUSE
THAT ARE WITH CBI [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'VE -- GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN MY NAME'S
INJURED BECAUSE IT ARE IN THE
SCIENCES LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR CPA CPA IS PLEASE TO SPONSOR
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE A BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE VITAL
INFORMATION ABOUT FEES SPECIAL
TAXES AND PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IT'S HARD TO
OVERSTATE HOW MUCH FEES TAXES
AND ASSESSMENT AFFECT THE COST
OF A NEW HOME.
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER A
RECENT STUDY BY UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOUND VOTE FOR
FEES COST UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER HOUSING UNIT.
AND THAT THE AND THE DETERMINING
THE ACTUAL FEES FREQUENTLY LACKS
TRANSPARENCY CLEARLY NOT KNOWING
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR PRICE TAG
CREATES TROUBLES UNCERTAINTY FOR
THE HOME BUILDER AND ALSO THE
FUTURE HOME OLDER.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HELPS
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OF
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REPORT THE FEES
AND TAXES THAT THEY ASSESS AND
NOTHING MORE.
BY POSTING THIS INFORMATION
PUBLICLY ACADEMICS CAN STUDY THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN FEES TAXES
AND HOMEBUILDING.
CITIES CAN COMPARE THEIR FEES
AND HOMEBUILDING TO THEIR PEERS
ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS AND
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION CAN BE HAD BASED
UPON CLEAR DATA.
AS CALIFORNIA'S TROUBLES WITH A
HOUSING CRISIS SO TRANSPARENCY
IS SORELY NEEDED AND IN ORDER TO
REMOVE THE UNCERTAINTY AND TO
HELP -- ENCOURAGE HOMEBUILDING
FOR THESE REASONS CDA SUPPORTS
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NICK JUST STUFF WHICH I AM A
COMMISSIONER ON THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION HIT
TODAY'S AN INDIVIDUAL
COLLABORATING WITH THE OFFICE
THIS OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
THIS MEASURE IS ABOUT MAKING
SURE WE HAVE THE INFORMATION WE
NEED TO IMPLEMENT CURRENT LAWS
POLICIES AND REGULATIONS TO
DELIVER THE HOUSING PRESERVE
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROTECTING STABILIZE HOUSING FOR
EXISTING RESIDENTS.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS THE
VEHICLE TO FILL GAPS IN EXISTING
DATA INCLUDING FEE DATA AND
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE DATA.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON IS
WORKING CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FOCUS ON DATA
THAT IS READILY AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND DIRECTLY
PERTINENT TO UPHOLDING RULES.
THAT LEGISLATURE'S PASSED AND
INFORMING AFFECTED HOUSING
POLICY.
AS AN MTC COMMISSION A AND T. A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS A
VITAL AND FLEXIBLE TOOL AS WELL.
AS WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ENCOURAGE AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE
DATA SIMPLY ISN'T THAT TO
PROPERLY UNDERSTAND THE BARRIERS
AND TO THE DESIGN TARGETED
INCENTIVES.
THIS MEASURE CREATES A RELIABLE
POP AND PO'S WITH A TRYING TO
TAILOR LOCAL HOUSING SOLUTIONS
TO GET THE DATA THEY NEED. FOR
EXAMPLE MONTEREY COUNTY MIGHT
NEED DATA FOCUSED ON PHAM WAKA
HOUSING WELL ANTI CO CCAC MIGHT
BE SEEKING DETAILS ON THE NUMBER
OF RENT CONTROL UNIT CITY'S
JURISDICTION.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE WE NEED
TO GET BEYOND ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACHES TO ADDRESS HOUSING
NEEDS FRONT OF US STATE.
I ASK YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE AS A
FLEXIBLE TOOL TO PROPERLY
IMPLEMENT AND ADOPT A STATES
ROBUST HOUSING POLICY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS OF OUR FOR FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT.
THE BACK AMERICANS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGENTS SUPPORT.
WHO IS FRIDAY WITH CALIFORNIAN
BE IN SUPPORT I JUST ADD TO THE
THE TESTIMONY THAT WE JUST HEARD
THAT IS A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE
FOR FOLKS?
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN LOCAL
POLITICS A HOUSING CAN BE A VERY
CHALLENGING TOPIC UNDERSTAND AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND JUST BRING
THE INFORMATION OF THE SERVICE
IS GOING TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO ENGAGE WE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT?
YEAH THE GARBAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT OF DATA.
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
MATT REGAN BAY AREA COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KEEP THE ROW WITH ENTERPRISE CAN
BE PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MEDIUM HAVE A HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME IN
SUPPORT MICHAEL I'D.
TONY BUT WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT SO SHE CAN HEAR
SUPPORT.
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS AND SILICON
VALLEY RISING IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVE ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION --
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
NO MOTION.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EVER.
A MISTER GRAYSON THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING OUR AMENDMENTS THEY
WERE PRETTY THOROUGH I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU TEND TO KEEP
WORKING ON SECTION TWO OF THE
BILL IN TERMS TO REFINE THE
LANGUAGE MOVING FORWARD -- I'M
IN SUPPORT OF MORE INFORMATION
ON HOUSING DECISIONS THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT WHAT SOME BOUNDARIES.
INCREASING MANDATES ON CITIES
AND COUNTIES NEEDS TO BE
BALANCED WITH THE COST TO DO SO
AND MAKING SURE THE INFORMATION
SUBMITTED TO H. C. D. IS DONE SO
IN A WAY THAT MAKES.
ALL THIS INFORMATION GATHERING
MEANINGFUL A SUPPLY ALL SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TO DATE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BATH RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HI.
HE IS THE ONE VOTE AWAY FOR THAT
ONE TO COME BACK FOR YOU OKAY
THINK ABOUT IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS WELCOME.
NICE AND COZY IN HERE.
IF YOU WANT TO JUST WAY SECOND
JUST SO SHE CLOSES THE DOOR.
AND IF THE WITNESSES COULD TALK
CLOSE INTO THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY WELCOME GO AHEAD THANK YOU
THANK YOU SURE THANK YOU MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY -- I THINK EVERYONE
AGREES IN THE STATE WE NEED TO
BUILD MORE HOMES BUILT MORE
HOMES FOR CAN YOU WERE SAYING
THE CHALLENGES OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS IN TERMS OF THE COST OF
LIVING -- THE INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES -- IT'S DIFFICULT
NOW IF YOU'RE A TEACHER DOT.
NURSE OR A COP TO LOOK TO
ACTUALLY AFFORD A MIDDLE CLASS
LIFESTYLE CERTAINLY MY DISTRICT
AND I KNOW MANY OF US.
ARE EXPERIENCING THAT -- THE
GOVERNOR TALKED ABOUT THE NEED
TO BUILD MORE HOMES I THINK WE
NEED OF THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
MORE HOMES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND I IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST -- NUMBER OF
PEOPLE VERSUS LOS NUMBER OF
HOMES IN THE COUNTRY THINK OR
FORTY EIGHT IN THE NATION IN
TERMS OF THAT STATISTIC -- SO
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE DO IT
HOW DO YOU PAY FOR IT -- I HAVE
A BILL HERE THAT WOULD ENSURE
THE TIMELY APPROVAL OF COMPLIANT
HOUSING PROJECTS THROUGH A
STREAMLINE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS. FOR MIXED INCOME OR
MISSING MIDDLE DEVELOPMENTS --
AND BASICALLY WHAT AB --
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE DO WILL
EXPAND EXISTING ENVIRONMENTAL
STREAMLINING LAW TO ENCOURAGE A
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION -- I AM.
ACCEPTING A PROPOSED AMENDMENT
BY THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION APA TO ALIGN THE
DEFINITION OF MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING TO AN EXISTING
DEFINITION AND THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE.
AND I'M WORKING ON AN ADDITIONAL --
AMENDMENT PROPOSED BY A PAY TO
CLARIFY HOW THE INTERPLAY WITH
LOCAL ORDINANCES WILL WORK --
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL --
IT'S IT'S AN IMPORTANT -- ONE I
THINK WE'LL GET A LOT OF GOOD
SUPPORT ON IT I'M HERE TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
MOVE INTO THE NEXT PROCESS.
I WILL ASK FOR AYE THOUGH AND I
WILL ASK.
MY MY FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES IN
A ADVOCATES HERE TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND TALK ABOUT WHY
THEY'RE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADAM
CHAIR A COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME'S MATT REGAN I'M HERE FROM
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL.
WE ARE IN BUSINESS SPONSORED
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION LIKE THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY OF THE BAY AREA'S
LARGEST EMPLOYERS ARE MEMBERS --
AND THEY TELL US EVERY DAY THAT
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE OF CONCERN
FOR THEM IS THE HOUSING
CHALLENGE IN OUR REGION -- IT'S
NO SECRET TO ANY OF US THAT
THERE'S A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
BAY AREA WHICH IS NOT EXPANDED
TO AND ACROSS THE THE WHOLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS ARE TELLING US IS A
EVERY DAY THAT THEY CANNOT HIRE
PEOPLE THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
THEY CAN'T GROW THEIR BUSINESSES
THEY CAN EXPAND AND IT'S
PRIMARILY IN THE MIDDLE INCOME
JOBS ACTOR THEY'RE HAVING THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM AND THAT'S
PRIMARILY BECAUSE PEOPLE IN THAT
INCOME SECTOR CAN'T AFFORD. TO
LIVE IN OUR REGION.
THERE'S A HUGE DOUGHNUT HOLE IN
OUR HOUSING SUPPLY PIPELINE --
THERE'S A SMALL -- AT NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT CAN BE SUBSIDIZED
THERE'S A SMALL NUMBER OF UNITS
THAT CAN BE BUILT BY MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS AND THOSE ARE COMING
IN AT SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR AND UP --
BASIC CONSTRUCTION COSTS SO THE
AVERAGE HOMEOWNER A HOMEOWNER
SAVE WITH TWO TWO TEACHER
SALARIES CAN'T AFFORD MARKET
RATE HOUSING AND THEY DON'T
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING
AND NOT DOUGHNUT HOLE GETS
BIGGER EVERY DAY.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS MAKE THAT
DONUT HOLE A LITTLE BIT SMALLER
AND WE ARE CHEN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU?
THANK YOU DURING OUR CURRENT AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL LANG WITH
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME NINE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ONE
OF THE KEY POINTS FOR US IS THAT
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE FINITE VERY
PRECIOUS SUBS AT SEVENTY DOLLARS
FOR FORMAL HOUSING. TO EXTENT WE
CAN ALLOW THE MARKET TO
STREAMLINE MODERATE MIXED INCOME
DEVELOPMENTS THAT'S ACTUALLY
MORE EFFECTIVE WAY TO BE ABLE TO
TO PRODUCE THIS HOUSING BECAUSE
WE DO HAVE THE WITH THOSE MORE
MORE HOUSEHOLDS WHO DON'T HAVE.
YOU DON'T QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING BUT ALSO CAN'T REALLY
COMPETE FOR MARKET RATE UNITS
THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AND ALLOW US
TO TO SAVE THOSE THOSE OTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS MORE
DEEPLY AND COME TARGETED --
DEVELOPMENTS.
WE RESPECT THE ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HOLLY FOR MANY ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY EAST BAY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVID ON BEHALF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING AFTER SEE COALITION AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY -- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITEE.
ALL RIGHTY I ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
OUR MOTION AND THE SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
JUST WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE -- I'LL BE SUPPORTING A
BILL TODAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS --
I UNDERSTAND THE NEAR YOU'LL BE
NEARING THE SCOPE -- TO THE BAY
AREA IN FUTURE AMENDMENTS.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE NEARING THE
SCOPE OF THE VILLAGES.
AREA.
OKAY THAT'S FINE OKAY YEAH.
FIND A GREAT.
SONG TAPE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SECRETARY
DICK RELATIONS DO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER VAST RAMOS
RAMOS SILOS REAVIS ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL [inaudible]
I MISSION IS ONE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT THE US.
WAS COOPER HERE OKAY MISTER
MAYES IS HERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB [inaudible]
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR HI [inaudible]
WELL.
THAT TO MANAGER.
IT WAS A NEAR A TIME YOU GET TO
GO.
THE MAN CHAIR AND THEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR A VERY SIMPLY
ARE LEGISLATION THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE YOU WOULD ADD SIX SEATS
TO THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS FIVE MEMBER BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
BEGINNING WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTIONS.
EACH NEW SEAT WOULD REPRESENT A
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT THAT
IS SERVED BY ID.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW A SEPARATE
PUBLIC UTILITY DISTRICT TO BE
FORMED THAT WOULD PROVIDE
ELECTRICAL SERVICES THE PEOPLE
OF RIVERSIDE.
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES WITH A
DULY ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY SERVE.
LIKE OTHER GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
ID'S BOARD OF DIRECTORS ARE
ELECTED INTO OFFICE BY VOTERS.
IN THIS INSTANCE ELIGIBLE VOTERS
ARE ONLY THOSE LIVING WITH AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
STATED DIFFERENTLY IDEAS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY VOTERS ARE
DENIED AT THE ABILITY TO PICK
THEIR REPRESENTATIVE TO THEIR
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY EVEN
THOUGH THEY RECEIVE THE SAME
SERVICE.
FROM ID AS IMPERIAL COUNTY DOES.
THIS BODY RIGHTFULLY.
GIVES ITS UNEQUIVOCAL SUPPORT
WHEN PROTECTING VOTING RIGHTS.
AND WE MUST CONTINUE TO DO SO
FOR THE NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DISENFRANCHISED VOTERS WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY ID BUT HAVE NO SAY.
WHO SITS ON THE BOARD?
THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR THOSE WHO
REPRESENT YOU IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
EACH OF US WHO HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF SERVING OUR CONSTITUENTS
KNOWS THIS AND IT IS OUR DUTY TO
PULL THAT RIGHT WITH EVERY FIBER
IN OUR BODY.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY TWO WITNESSES --
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF INDIO
LUPE RAMIS IS THAT A MYTH.
A MYTH PLEASE YOU AND MOVE THE
MICROPHONE CLOSE YES.
BECAUSE IT'S A LOT OF GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR OF THE OUT OF
COOLEY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LOU BUT ALMOST I'M ME.
I AM THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
INDIA AND SIXTEEN YEAR MEMBER ON
THE INDIA CITY COUNCIL.
AND PAST CHAIR OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
ENERGY CONSUMER ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THE ECAC.
MY CITY OF EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND
EIHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND POPULATION ISN'T WITHIN
AYE ID ENERGY SERVICE AREA.
BUT HAS NO SAY IN WHO REPRESENT
THEM ON AYE ID'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
WE SIMPLY DO NOT GET A VOTE ON
WHO SITS ON THE AYE ID BOARD.
I I D. CLAIMS MY CITY IS
REPRESENTED ON THE ECAC BOARD.
THIS SIMPLY IS NOT THE CASE.
ANYONE SITTING ON THE ECAC.
MUST HAVE AYE AYE DE BOARD
APPROVAL.
MEANING THAT I I D. MUST FIRST
APPROVE THE APPOINTMENT.
AND THEN CAN REMOVE ANY
OPPOSITION FROM ECAC WITHOUT
CAUSE.
THIS RECENTLY HAPPENED TO MY
NEIGHBORING CITIES
REPRESENTATIVE MAYOR PRO TEM
STEVE SANCIOUS.
MY COLLEAGUE MAYOR PRO TEAM
SANCIOUS SIMPLY RAISE THE
QUESTION AS TO WHY THE COACHELLA
VALLEY CITIES DID NOT HAVE EQUAL
REPRESENTATION ON THE AYE AYE DE
BOARD.
AND FOR THAT REASON WAS PROMPTLY
REJECTED AT THE TIME OF
REAPPOINTMENT WITHOUT BECAUSE
THEIR EXPLANATION.
AND FOR THIS REASON I AND MY
COLLEAGUE MAYOR PRO TEM MILLER
OF THE CITY OF INDIA HAVE
PROTESTED.
BY NOT PARTICIPATE IN THE IN THE
ECAC MEETINGS.
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL AND
FORMER MARINE STEVE'S COMMITMENT
TO THE PEOPLE HE REPRESENTS IS
UNQUESTIONABLE.
WHICH IS WHY IS IT IS SO
INAPPROPRIATE TO REMOVE HIM FROM
THE ECAC.
SIMPLY FOR VOTE VOICING
DISSENTING VIEWS.
I DE ID IS APATHETIC AT BEST AND
DOWNRIGHT VENGEFUL AT WORST WHEN
IT COMES TO HANDLING DISPUTES
WITH LOCAL OFFICIALS.
AS MRS AND RATE PAYERS.
THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE OPINION
IS HEARD IS THROUGH THE RIGHT TO
VOTE WHICH IS WHY MY CITY AND
THE CITIES OF INDIAN WELLS.
RANCHO MARAJ PALM DESERT AND
LOOKING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I APPRECIATE TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MEGAN BE
MANIFESTING THOUGH.
I'M A COULD TELL A RESIDENT A
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY IN A LONG
TIME ADVOCATE FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH A COMMUNITY WELL BEING IN
THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
I WAS ALSO RECENTLY ELECTED TO
THE COULD TELL US CITY COUNCIL.
I'M I ALSO REPRESENT THE
COMMUNITIES OF COULD TELL UP
LIVE LIKING THAT AN INDIO IN
THIS GAG REGIONAL COUNCIL.
I'M HERE TODAY AND
REPRESENTATION OF THOUSANDS OF
DISENFRANCHISED EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY RESIDENTS IN IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
WHICH WILL FOR THE FIRST TIME
PROVIDE US WITH THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND WITH REPRESENTATION.
IN THE IMPERIAL.
IRRIGATION DISTRICT ELECTIONS TO
GIVE YOU A PICTURE OF COACHELLA
AND THE UNINCORPORATED EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY WE ARE 97%
LATINO 85% SPANISH SPEAKING AT
HOME.
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME AROUND
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND OR LOWER
AND WE FACE HIGH RENTS POVERTY
AND POLLUTION BURDENS.
WE ARE FARM HOME CARE
CONSTRUCTION HOTEL AND
RESTAURANT WORK FORCE FOR THE
REST OF THE VALLEY.
COULD TELL IS ABOUT 70%
UNDEVELOPED IN RURAL AND THE
UNINCORPORATED EASTERN COACHELLA
VALLEY IS LARGELY AN AND
UNDEVELOPED AND PREDOMINATELY
RURAL.
AND OFTEN THE COMMUNITIES ARE ON
PERMITTED BY BUILDING AND AND
SAFETY CODES AND STANDARDS.
WE ARE A REGION OR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE DAILY
ISSUE WE'RE ALSO A REGION WHERE
POLITICAL REPRESENTATION HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY DEFICIENT.
THE ISSUE OF AYE ID
REPRESENTATION IS ONE THAT WE
HAVE DISCUSSED FOR YEARS IN THE
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
WITH PARALLEL WITH THEIR
STRUGGLES TO IMPLEMENT ASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
ESPECIALLY THE UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES.
WHERE THE ELECTRICITY IS OFTEN
IS ON PERMITTED ILLEGAL AND
UNSAFE HAVING BEEN DESIGNED SORT
OF OUTSIDE THE REALM OF NORMAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPHECIES?
IN THOSE STRUGGLES RATHER THAN
HAVING ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
TO TURN TO WERE LEFT TO DEPEND
ON AYE ID STAFF AND ONLY
IMPERIAL VALLEY ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHOSE INTEREST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS LARGELY ABOUT.
THEIR INVESTMENT AND WHAT MAKES
SENSE FOR THE BUSINESS MODEL.
IN FACT IT IS WITH A CERTAIN
DEGREE OF RISK THAT I COME TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
BECAUSE WE IN COULD TELL ARE
ACTIVELY SEEKING THE ENERGY
STATION OF A NEW DEVELOPMENT IN
THE CITY AND WITHOUT AYE ID'S
VOLUNTARY.
ENERGY PROVISION WE LOSE THAT
DEVELOPMENT AND SO WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT'S A RISK -- IN THE THE
POTENTIAL RATE RETALIATION AND
WITHDRAWAL IS REAL TO US.
BUT I COME HERE AND STAND FOR
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT AND IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
I'M JOINED BY MY COUNTERPARTS
WHICH ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY SUCH AS PUEBLO
NEEDLE CDC.
LEADERS CAMPESINOS ALI ANSWER
COACHELLA VALLEY THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR RURAL STUDIES AND
MANY OTHERS WHO HAVE SUPPORTED
WRITTEN SUPPORT -- TO HAVE
SUBMITTED WRITTEN SUPPORT FOR A
BI.
EIGHT FIVE FOUR YOU DESERVE
REPRESENTATION IN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE.
WE DESERVE ACCOUNTABLE ELECTED
LEADERS AND I URGE YOU TO MOVE
FORWARD AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR FOR
THE WELL BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANTHONY GONZALEZ I
REPRESENT THE CITY'S A PALM
DESERT MAKITA AND INDIAN WELLS.
NOW WE'RE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
ONE OF THANKED AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE SUPPORT.
WE ASKED FOR AND I WROTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
BUT BEGIN.
MADAM CHAIR MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON YOU CAN START
WHENEVER YOU'D LIKE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME THESE
FEW MINUTES.
CHAIR WOMAN I GEAR CURRY AND
MEMBERS OF THE SYSTEM COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS NORMA SIERRA GLENDALE.
I AM VICE PRESIDENT OF THE I AD
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
I TESTIFIED BEFORE YOU.
TODAY.
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B..
EIGHT FIVE FOUR THIS BILL LIKELY
VIOLATES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION'S PROHIBITION
AGAINST SPECIAL LEGISLATION.
AND THE EQUAL PROTECTION AND DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS OF AYE ID'S
CURRENT CONSTITUENTS IN RATE
PAYERS.
IT CIRCUMVENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DECISION MAKING AUTHORITY AND
SETS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR
ALL SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
THE BILL ANALYSIS SAYS THAT
THERE IS A LOCAL PROCESS
AUTHORIZED BY LAW.
AND BY THE LEGISLATURE BY WHICH
SERVICE RELATED ISSUES AND
GOVERNANCE SHOULD BE ADDRESSED.
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE FOUR MAY ALSO
VIOLATE THE FEDERAL VOTING
RIGHTS ACT BECAUSE UNDER THE
TERMS OF THE BILL.
VOTERS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY ARE
AUTOMATICALLY GIVEN A MAJORITY.
SKEWS ME ON THE ELEVEN MEMBER
BOARD.
MOREOVER IT LIKELY VIOLATES THE
ONE PERSON ONE VOTE REQUIREMENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS.
BY CREATING DISTRICTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY THAT INCLUDE
POPULATIONS TEN TIMES LARGER
THAN THOSE IN IMPERIAL COUNTY.
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY RESIDENTS ARE
PRIMARILY LATINOS.
AND OF LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS
WHILE THE RESIDENCE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY ARE MUCH LESS SO.
FINALLY THIS BILL THREATENS LONG
STANDING WATER AND ENERGY
SERVICE AREA RIGHTS.
I A DIS POWERS AND PURPOSES ARE
PERMITTED BY STATE LAW AND
DEFINED BY LONG TERM AGREEMENTS.
THE NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR
COMPROMISED AGREEMENT REACHED
BETWEEN AYE ID THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE.
THEN THIS NINETY NINE YEAR
AGREEMENT WAS INTEGRAL IN
RESOLVING LEGAL DISPUTES RELATED
TO WATER AND ENERGY RIGHTS.
IT HAS PROVIDED CV W. D. ACCESS
TO RELIABLE WATER SUPPLIES.
AND IT HAS HELPED SECURE ID'S
RIGHTS TO SERVE RESIDENTS OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
PER THE AGREEMENT ID PACEY V. W.
D. 8% OF ITS ANNUAL ELECTRICAL
SERVICE REVENUES. TO DATE DOES
PAYMENTS TOTAL APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FIVE MILLION.
AND WE PROJECT THEY WILL REACH
UP TO SIXTY FIVE MILLION IN THE
NEXT FOURTEEN YEARS WHEN THE
AGREEMENT REACHES ITS FULL TERM.
THE COMPLETE RESTRUCTURE OF ID'S
GOVERNANCE UNDER AB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR NOW IN JACK'S THE STATE
LEGISLATURE INTO THIS PROCESS
AND THREATENS THE VIABILITY OF
THE COMPROMISE.
WHILE THE BILL'S AUTHOR HAS SAID
THAT COACHELLA VALLEY RESIDENTS
HAVE NO VOICE ON MATTERS RELATED
TO ID SERVICES.
THEY MOST CERTAINLY DO.
ID ENTERED INTO THE COMPROMISE
AGREEMENT WITH C. V. W. D. AND
ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS ARE
ELECTED.
BY RESIDENTS OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY. FOR THE RECORD.
YOU MUST KNOW THAT ALL OF AYE
ID'S CUSTOMERS RECEIVE THE SAME
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE SERVICES.
WHEN COMPARED TO NEIGHBORING
UTILITIES ID'S CUSTOMERS PAY AN
AVERAGE OF 50% LESS THAN THEIR
MONTHLY POWER BILLS?
AB EIGHT FIVE FOUR AM JUSTLY
SINGLES OUT THE ID FOR REASONS
DRIVEN BY LOCAL POLITICS.
AND SETS A VERY DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT AND FOR THESE REASONS
I BEG YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SECOND THE
MOTION BY THE WAY.
I MEAN OPPOSITION THANK YOU SIR
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
YOU ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
YES MA'AM GOOD OUT GOOD
AFTERNOON MY COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN --
COMMITTEE THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAKING MY NAME IS
FRANK OSWALD I'M GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE ID.
I'VE ALREADY WRITTEN LETTERS TO
MISTER MAYES AND WHAT I THINK OF
SOME BILLS WERE MADE TO YOUR
COMMITTEE TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL INFIRMITIES OF
THIS BILL.
YOU NEED TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER.
ALL THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
RAISED BY THIS PARTICULAR BILL
IT'S S. PIECE OF SPECIAL
LEGISLATION THAT PURPORTS TO
REGULATE INTO AN AREA THAT'S
FULLY REGULATED BY.
THE GOVERNMENT REORGANIZATION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND IT RAISES
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES OF EQUAL
PROTECTION [inaudible]
BECAUSE IN MY VIEW IT IS A BILL
THAT PROVIDES A SOLUTION LOOKING
FOR A PROBLEM.
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH THE
SERVICE PROVIDED BY THE AYE ID.
THE RATES ARE THE MOST
COMPETITIVE IN THE STATE.
IT CHARGED VIRTUALLY HALF OF
WHAT OUR IMMEDIATE COMPETITOR
DOESN'T IN APRIL EXCUSE ME IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
THE BILL ALSO WOULD IRONICALLY
ENOUGH.
CREATE THE ABILITY OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY VOTERS TO CONTROL AN
INITIATE ACTIONS ON ASSESSMENTS.
AND ASSESSMENTS ARE PRIMARILY
AND ALMOST ALWAYS
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED. FOR
IMPOSED ON THOSE WHO OWN LAND
WITHIN THE DISTRICT THE DISTRICT
THE ID'S.
LAND IS LOCATED IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY NOT RIVERSIDE COUNTY YET
THIS WOULD GIVE POWER TO
RESIDENTS OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO
WITH LEAST INITIATE OR IMPOSE
POTENTIAL ASSESSMENTS.
SO IF THERE'S A TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE.
THE IRONY HERE IS THAT IT REALLY
POTENTIALLY IMPOSES TAXATION
WITHOUT REPRESENTATION ON
RESIDENTS OF THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
THE MOST TELLING ARGUMENT THOUGH
THAT THAT THIS BILL.
REALLY PRESENTS AS A PROBLEM IS
THE INVASION OF THE WATER RIGHTS
THAT ARE HELD BY THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
THE WATER RIGHTS OUR WATER
RIGHTS WERE DEVELOPED AT THE
TURN OF THE LAST CENTURY THE
NOTICES OF APPROPRIATION WHERE
THE COLORADO RIVER WAS BEING
USED TO IRRIGATE FARMLAND IN THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY.
AS WELL AS CITIES AND SOME
INDUSTRIAL USES.
THAT WATER RIGHT HAS BEEN
CONSECRATED IN A SERIES OF
DECISIONS AND LAWS AND
ENACTMENTS BY CONGRESS.
ALL OF WHICH ARE EMBODIED IN THE
REAL UNDER THE RUBRIC OF THE LAW
OF THE RIVER.
AT THE PRESENT TIME THE
IMPLICATION DISTRICT HOLD A
WATER RIGHT IN TELLING THAT TO
THREE POINT ONE MILLION ACRE
FEET OF WATER PER YEAR.
IT IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
CONTRACTOR WHO CAN TAKE WATER
OUT OF THE COLORADO RIVER.
ON THE RIVER.
IT EXCEEDS ANYBODY ANY OTHER
SINGLE USER OF THE RIVER AND THE
SOLE SOURCE OF WATER FOR THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY IS THE COLORADO
RIVER.
IF YOU DELEGATE CONTROL OF THE
AYE ID BOARD TO RESIDENTS WHO
LIVE IN RIVER SIDE YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THEN AND RIVERSIDE.
WHO HAVE NO HISTORICALLY
INTEREST IN FARMING OR THE
ACTIVITIES OF IMPERIAL COUNTY?
CONTROLLING WHAT THE ID DOES
WITH RESPECT WAS WATER RIGHTS
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE HI ID
OR NOR ITS PEOPLE CAN LIVE WITH.
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE NO NO IN FACT
IT COULD EVEN BE A TAKING.
BECAUSE IT LOOKS AS THOUGH THIS
LEGISLATION BY FIAT WOULD TAKE
THAT WATER RIGHT AWAY AND
CONFERRED ON A BODY OF PEOPLE
WHO MAY BE WELL INTENTIONED.
AND MAY HAVE THE RIGHTS OF THEIR
OWN.
RESIDENTS AND VOTERS IN THEIR
HEARTS BUT IT TAKES AWAY
SUBSTANTIAL PROPERTY RIGHT THAT
HAS EXISTED FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS AND IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THE THE OTHER ISSUES ARE.
THAT ARE RAISED HERE ARE VOTING
RIGHTS ISSUES WOULD HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY LETTER AND SUBMITTED
TO YOU.
IT VIOLATES POTENTIALLY THE ONE
PERSON ONE VOTE RULE BECAUSE
YOU'RE GOING TO ADD A TREMENDOUS
THE HUGE POPULATION BASE TO THE
REPRESENTATION OF THE ID BOARD.
AND EFFECTIVELY DISENFRANCHISED
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY.
AND REMEMBER THIS.
THE BILL COUNTY IS 85290% LATINO.
IT IS ONE OF THE POOREST
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF NOT THE
NATION 2225%.
HISTORIC ENDEMIC AND PERSISTENT
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE PEOPLE OF IMPERIAL VALLEY
AND IMPERIAL COUNTY HAVE
VIRTUALLY NOTHING IN COMMON.
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
CAME.
TO AND LESS IN COMMON.
A LITTLE MORE BUT NOT QUITE AS
MUCH WITH THE OTHER PEOPLE IN
INDIA.
HISTORICALLY THERE HAS BEEN AN
ADVERSE POSITION BETWEEN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
WHICH IS.
HAS THE WATER RIGHTS SERVICE TO
THE AREA SUPPLIED.
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
SINCE NINETEEN THIRTY TWO THERE
BEEN A SERIES OF ADVERSE ACTIONS
BETWEEN COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT AND THE PILLAR CATION
DISTRICT WHICH CULMINATED IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR COMPROMISE
AGREEMENT WHICH COULD CHILL
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
SEATED AND GAVE UP.
ITS RIGHTS TO DISTRIBUTE ENERGY
IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY AREA.
IN RETURN THERE WAS PEACE IN THE
BOULDER GET BOULDER CANYON
PROJECT FOR THE TIME BEING.
AND THE ID INSTEAD OF ANNEXING
C. V. W. D. AS IT WAS AUTHORIZED
TO DO AGREED NOT TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
SINCE THEN -- BEEN AT LEAST TWO
LAWSUITS BETWEEN CAL COULD CHILL
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND THE ID
CONCERNING.
THE NET PROCEEDS IN TERMS OF THE
HELLO THE 8% ROYALTY IT IS TO BE
PAID BY THE IDEA IN CONNECTION
WITH ITS POWER.
GENERATION.
THIS AS CHRISTY OR EXCUSE ME
DIRECTOR GLINDA SHELTON WAS
PLAIN TO YOU IT'S BECAUSE EIGHT
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
TRANSFERS HAVING TO BE MADE BY
THE ID. TO COACHELLA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT.
NOW THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN COULD
CHILLED OUT OF WATER DISTRICT
WOULD NOW UNDER THIS BILL.
HAVE THE CONTROL OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
HOW CAN YOU?
FLY IN THE FACE OF HUNDRED YEARS
OF OPPOSITION AND DIFFERENCES OF
INTEREST.
YEAH BUT IF NOTHING ELSE IT
VIOLATES THE RIGHT NOT TO
ASSOCIATE WHICH IS ALSO
CONSECRATED.
AND OUR FEDERAL CONSTITUTION SO.
I'D LEAVE IT AT THAT I JUST
THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
AND CONSTITUTIONAL INFIRMITIES
AT THIS BILL.
HAS TO ADDRESS AND CANNOT
ADDRESS AND I WILL CALL UPON YOU.
TO DO YOUR DUTY IN THIS A
SITUATION OF THE THINK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES THAT YOU WILL
DECIDE WHETHER NOT TO PASS A SET
OF COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T GIVE IS THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS.
CORRECT THE TRUSSES BAXTER ON
BEHALF OF THE IMPERIAL COUNTY
LAUGH GOAL HELLO CLEAR
INFORMATION COMMISSION IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
CHAU MCREYNOLDS ATTENDS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
OF IMPERIAL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
A MARK ON HALF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER THIRTY
IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO CHERYL VIEGAS WALKER --
IMPERIAL COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SALE.
HI NICK WELLS FROM THE CITY OF
HOPE BILL.
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION TO YOU
EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE FOUR THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ANTHONY
MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN FEEDING
CALIFORNIA C. DISSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR PAP
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
POST.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA SPENDING CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICK ROACH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES RESPECTFULLY FLEA
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE ALRIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
WAS THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SUGGEST OR DID YOU TAKE
AWAY I GUESS THAT MIGHT BE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WHAT IS ANY.
ANY ISSUES THAT ANYBODY HAS ON
THIS THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS. TO ADDRESS THEM
[inaudible]
YES. SEVEN MEMBER TO REVERSE.
THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE CONCERNS --
BROUGHT UP REGARDING
REPRESENTATION -- IN THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY RESIDENTS
ABILITY -- TO HAVE
REPRESENTATION ON THE SERVICES
THAT THEY RECEIVE BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT USUALLY THESE
TYPES OF QUESTIONS GO THROUGH A
LOCAL PROCESS FIRST AND I
BELIEVE THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
NOT HAPPENED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
SO THAT'S MY CONCERN AND I FEEL
LIKE UNTIL THOSE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE TAKEN PLACE.
I FEEL THIS BILL IS A LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE AND I CANNOT SUPPORT
IT WHAT.
THE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
RECONSIDER -- Là NOT SUPPORTING
IT TODAY AND I WILL -- I'LL TELL
YOU WHY -- I WOULD HAVE HOPED
THAT WE WOULD HAVE HAD MORE
CONVERSATIONS IN REGARDS. TO
THIS -- TO THIS BILL AND IN FACT --
OF THOUGH IT SEEMS AS THOUGH FOR
SOME THAT THINK THAT ID IS ONE
OF MY FOES IT IS NOT.
A THEY DO PROVIDE FANTASTIC
SERVICE -- AS AS THEY BOTH THE
HAD TALKED ABOUT.
AND I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE
CONTINUED THIS -- THIS
CONVERSATION I ALSO COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I SPENT EIGHT
YEARS ON A CITY COUNCIL AND I
SPENT FOUR YEARS A CHIEF OF
STAFF TO A MEMBER THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
AND I UNDERSTAND LAUGH CO IN
FACT I WOULD HOPE THAT THIS
THERE'D BE A MECHANISM IN PLACE
OF FOR THE LAUGH BECAUSE A TO A
TO ADDRESS THIS.
IN FACT THEY HAVE -- THEY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND I THINK WE'VE
HANDED OUT COPIES.
IN -- TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN A IN
A REVIEW THAT WAS DOWN BY THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LAUGH GO ON A
DATE IF EVERY TWENTY SECOND.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IF I CAN JUST
READ THIS MADAM CHAIR.
SINCE THE MAJORITY OF IDEAS
SERVICE POPULATION FOR
ELECTRICITY IS WITHIN THE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE STAFF RECOMMENDS THE
DISTRICTS SPHERE OF INFLUENCE BE
ESTABLISHED TO INCLUDED SERVICE
AREA.
AS DEPICTED IN THE ATTACHED
EXHIBIT.
IN ADDITION STAFF RECOMMENDS ID
FORMALLY SUBMITTED ANNEXATION
APPLICATION TO INCLUDE THE AREA
ESTABLISHED AS ITS FEAR OF
INFLUENCE ALLOWING FOR
COTERMINOUS FEAR.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THIS IMPORTANT
PART THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
REGISTERED VOTERS WITHIN THE
COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE TO
PARTICIPATE IN IDEAS ELECTIONS.
CURRENTLY CUSTOMERS WITHIN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ARE NOT
REPRESENTED BY ID'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS EACH BOARD MEMBERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DIVISION NONE OF
WHICH INCLUDES REGISTERED VOTERS
WITHIN THE COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE.
SO I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I GOT
MYSELF INTO FINANCES THIS BILL
IF I CAN BE -- CAN BE REAL --
BUT IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR TO ME
THAT THIS THE VOTING RIGHTS --
ISSUE THAT WE WANTED BILL TO
PROVIDE THIS I IDN'T REALIZE
THAT THIS WAS AN ISSUE THEY
DIDN'T JUST COME UP IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN IN FACT IT HAS
BEEN -- IT IT'S BEEN PROBABLY
THIRTY YEAR PROCESS -- AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT WHEN IT
WAS FORMED OVER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS AGO --
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS AGO A NO
ONE PROVIDED POWER AT THE TIME
AND SO IT MADE SENSE FOR A LOCAL
WATER AGENCY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE POWER.
BUT WHAT ENDS UP WHAT ENDED UP
HAPPENING OVER TIME IS YOU ENDED
UP WITH NINETY TWO THOUSAND
VOTERS THAT LIVE WITHIN THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY PORTION.
THAT ARE DISENFRANCHISED THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LASKO SAYS WE
WE THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE DONE
BUT THEY HAVE NO POWER OVER
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
NOW YOU HEARD FROM IMPERIAL
COUNTY THAT THEY WERE OPPOSED
BUT OF COURSE THEY THEY WOULD BE
OPPOSED BECAUSE THEY HAVE
POLITICAL POWER TODAY IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
MY GOAL WITH THIS LEGISLATION AS
I'VE LEARNED IT IS NOT SIMPLE IN
FACT I WOULD TELL YOU IF I WAS
SITTING BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I DON'T THINK THE LANGUAGE -- I
WOULD NOT IF I WAS THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LANGUAGE BEFORE ME I
WOULD NOT SIGN THIS INTO INTO
LAW IT NEEDS SOME WORK.
IT NEEDS WORK -- AND MY HOPE
WOULD BE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE IMPALER
DISPUTATION DISTRICT TO BE ABLE
TO SOLVE THIS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY I RECEIVED A
LETTER FROM THEM AFTER A MEETING
THAT I HAD HELD.
IN AT ONE OF THEIR OFFICE TO TRY
TO FIGURE THIS OUT I GOT A
LETTER FROM THEM I'VE NEVER SAYS
NEVER RECEIVED A LETTER LIKE
THIS EVER BEFORE FROM A PUBLIC
AGENCY THIS IS NOT A PRIVATE
AGENCY NOT A NOT A AN INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY THIS IS A PRIVATE.
OUR STATE PUBLIC UTILITY.
THEY SAID TO ME IT DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE VOTING RIGHTS CURRENT
OR PROSPECTIVE FOR LEGIBLE RATE
PAYERS WHO RESIDE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
THEY DON'T WANT THE FOLKS IN THE
COULD TELL VOWED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE RIGHTS.
IN ADDITION THEY SAID.
ID CAN SEE NO VALUE IN FURTHER
PRIVATE MEETINGS.
OR FOR THAT MATTER FUTURE TALKS
WITH YOU.
SO THE DIFFICULTY IS HERE WE
HAVE A PROBLEM.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
BY THE WAY I WANT TO MAKE THIS
POINT THE WATER RIGHTS ISSUE IS
VERY REAL.
AND I HAVE WRITTEN OP ED AND
GIVE BOTH PRIVATE AND PUBLIC.
AFFIRMATION OF THAT I WILL DO
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY TO SECURE.
THE WATER RIGHTS FOR IMPERIAL
COUNTY THOSE ARE SECURE WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW WELL
WHAT BY THE WHISKIES FOR
DRINKING AND WATERS FOR FIGHTING
OVER.
AND I WILL FIGHT WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THEIR THEIR
WATER RIGHTS WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE NINETY TWO
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO TO
VOTE -- AND FOR THAT REASON THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
HAVE A WE NEED TO CONTINUE.
CONTINUE TO HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES.
THANK YOU I'M FOR THIS COMES IN
THANK YOU -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REAVIS FOR BRINGING UP THOSE.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND AND
HERE IN A IMPERIAL COUNTY LEFT
GOING.
NOW AT THE READING OF THAT
LETTER AND GOING BACK INTO SOME
HISTORY SAYING THAT RIVERSIDE
COUNTY LAUGH WAS ALSO.
I'M ENGAGED IN YOUR EXPERIENCE
AS A CITY ELECTED AND WORKING
FOR A CHIEF OF STAFF ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SITTING AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR
AND CHAIRMAN OF THE LEFT GOING
SAN MEDINA COUNTY.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH WITH.
WITH OTHER COUNTIES TO BRING
TOGETHER SO AND SOLVE ISSUES
THAT ARE THERE.
I DO TO THINK THAT THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE -- PREMATURE TO
BE AT THIS LEVEL WHEN THINGS CAN
BE WORKED OUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
POSSIBLY BY ENGAGING -- BOTH
LAUGHED BECAUSE IMPERIAL COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO COME
TOGETHER AND WORK OUT THOSE
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE ON SPEARS
OF INFLUENCES ALL THE THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND TO COME HERE AND ASK THAT
CERTAIN BOARD MEMBERS BE
PREDESTINED TO REPRESENT CERTAIN
AREAS ISN'T.
IN THE WILL OF OF THIS AREA
SHOULD BE DONE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE GOING
BACK WORKING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WITH IMPERIAL COUNTY LEFT GO.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY LAUGH GOING TRY
TO COME TOGETHER TO SOME TYPE OF
MECHANISM AND RESOLVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
I TO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
LITTLE -- PREMATURE TO BE HERE
AT THIS STAGE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS YES.
YEAH IF I COULD JUST ADD -- A
COUPLE COMMENTS TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SAID YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THE BILL I AM
MYSELF COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- AND UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW -- THAT
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
CERTAINLY IS A LONG PROCESS AND
THIS IS ONLY YOU KNOW ONE OF
THOSE STEPS -- AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT -- THIS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT VEHICLE TO CONTINUE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND I YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT WILL
HAVE -- IF IF IF IT DOES PASS
WILL HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THOSE LAWS WENT ON THE
FLOOR AND I'D.
BE HAPPY TO SEE IF ANY -- CHRIS
WAS MADE -- BUT CERTAINLY I
WOULD HOPE THAT -- THESE THESE
BECAUSE THIS LETTER IS REALLY
CONCERNED -- AND CERTAINLY IS IS
IS IS REALLY -- A COMPELLING
LETTER TO ENCOURAGE ME TO
SUPPORT LEGISLATION SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS AND REALLY
PROJECT THANK YOU.
BLOOM -- THANK YOU -- I'M GONNA
BE SUPPORTING THIS -- BILL TODAY
ALSO I'M FRANKLY -- UP PRETTY
WELL OUTRAGE -- THAT A LETTER
WOULD BE SENT FROM A PUBLIC
AGENCY THAT BASICALLY -- SAYS.
STILL LATER -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
NO NEED TO HAVE ANY DISCUSSIONS
HERE IN FACT.
NOT ONLY IS THERE NO NEED --
WE'RE NOT GONNA TALK TO YOU -- I
I THINK YOU'VE LAID OUT SOME
VERY IMPORTANT.
REASONS WHY THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT.
BUT FOR ME IF NO OTHER REASON WE
SHOULD BE VOTING FOR THIS TODAY
TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT THAT KIND
OF BEHAVIOR FROM A PUBLIC AGENCY
IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS [inaudible]
WELL -- I HAVE COMMENTS.
I'VE HEARD FROM BOTH OF MY
COLLEAGUES REPRESENTING THE
DISTRICT'S AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
THEY HAVE OPPOSING VIEWS ON THIS
BILL BUT THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
HAS COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AND I ID.
THE OPPOSING STAKEHOLDERS.
MR GARCIA DOES BELIEVE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO BE HAD.
FOR THAT REASON WHILE I DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM I AM WILLING TO ALLOW THIS
MOVE BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND RECOMMENDED I VOTE BY MY
COLLEAGUE SO THE CONVERSATION
MAY CONTINUE.
BEFORE I ASK FOR THE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO THE BOARD
OF THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT THAT I'M APPALLED.
YOUR REFUSAL IN YOUR LETTER TO
MISTER MAYES TO HOLD FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH A MEMBER OF
THIS OF THIS BODY WHO IS TRYING
TO REPRESENT HIS CONSTITUENTS.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE THE PATH THAT
HE IS PICKED HAS CHOSEN TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS.
BUT FOR AN OFFICIAL
CORRESPONDENCE FROM A PUBLIC
AGENCY TO A MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO COMMUNICATE AN
UNWILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT.
HOW IT'S CONSTITUENTS INTERESTS
MIGHT BEST PROTECTED IS
INSULTING TO HIS OFFICE ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS INSTITUTION?
AND QUITE FRANKLY IT'S INSULTING
TO ME.
SO I'LL ASKYOU AND PLEASE BE
VERY CAREFUL BECAUSE THE WRONG
ANSWER WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON MY PERSPECTIVE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE ON YOUR AGENCY GOING
FORWARD.
WILL THE BOARD AND STAFF OF THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT
PROMISE THIS COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
AND OR REPRESENTATIVE OF HIS
CONSTITUENTS.
ON HOW TO PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
INPUT INTO AYE ID'S PUBLIC POWER
AGREEMENT HOW PUBLIC POWER
AGREEMENT.
AND SERVICE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
WE DO IT.
I CANNOT SPEAK FOR THE BOARD I'M
ONLY ONE OF FIVE I WOULD BE MORE
THAN DELIGHTED TO BRING IT TO
THE BOARD AND GIVE YOU AN ANSWER
IMMEDIATELY AFTER WE'VE
DISCUSSED IT. FOR MAY MADAM
CHAIRMAN I WILL SAY THIS OF THE
BOARD AS WE PUBLICLY ANNOUNCES
RETAIN THE SERVICES OF A LAW
FIRM IN EXPERTS TO LOOK AT THE
WHOLE SITUATION WITH RESPECT. TO
THE DIFFERENT AREAS BEING SERVED.
WITH AT WITH THOSE PLAIN VIEW OF
THE PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED VIEW ON
EXAMINING PATHS GOING FORWARD SO
I PERSONALLY DON'T SEE ANY
REASON WHY WE CAN ENGAGE IN A
COLLOQUY WITH.
MR MAYS AND TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE SOLICITING
OPINIONS AND VIEWS FROM PEOPLE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AS WELL ALSO
ALTHOUGH.
OUR DIRECTOR HERE IS NATURALLY
CONSERVATIVE ABOUT I CAN SAY YES
WE'RE MORE THAN WILLING TO
ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL PROCESS
BUT IT HAS TO BE MEANINGFUL.
AND I THINK THE BOARD'S CONCERN
MORE THAN ANYTHING WAS AT THAT
POINT WHERE THE OFFER WAS MADE
BY MISTER ASSEMBLY WHEN MAYES
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT IT
WASN'T GOING TO BE A MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATION.
THE BOARD IS NOT IGNORING THIS.
IT'S INSTRUCTED ITS OWN
ATTORNEYS AND TO AND EXPERTS IN
WITHIN THE NEXT SIXTY TO NINETY
DAYS IS GOING TO BE EXPLORING
DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES.
AS OTHER PATH IN GOING FORWARD
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS HERE.
A LOT OF MOVING PARTS AND THAT
MAKES IT A DIFFICULT --
SITUATION TO SEE A RESOLUTION
IMMEDIATELY ACHIEVABLE AND OF
COURSE PART OF THAT IS TO GET
YOU KATE ASSEMBLYMAN MAY SO THEY
CAN APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITIES.
AND THAT MAY IN FACT MODERATE
SOME OF HIS VIEWS AS YOU
RECOGNIZE THE NEED.
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE HANDLED
COMPLIMENTED AND DOUBLE KILLED
AND WORK TOGETHER TO GET IN THE
AN ENTRY LEVEL SOLUTION.
SO THANK YOU AND IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK WITH
MISTER MAYES AS WELL AS OTHER --
IN THIS PROCESS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU TO MY GREAT
HOPE THAT THIS COMMITMENT BY
THESE PEOPLE HERE WILL GET THIS.
TO A EVEN A BETTER BILL IN THE
FUTURE AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME
YOU'VE SPENT.
APPRECIATE MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S TIME THAT HE HAS SPENT
ON THIS AS WELL I'M SORRY HE'S
NOT HERE TODAY.
BUT I THINK THAT YOU CAN COME TO
SOME KIND OF RESOLUTION.
PRO OR CON WHATEVER BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE YOU GUYS SIT AT THE
TABLE.
AND TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IF I CAN
CLOSE MANAGER.
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
ON THIS -- IS WELL -- AGAIN IT'S
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT I
REALIZED I WAS GOING TO BE IS --
AS BIG OF AN ISSUE AS IT HAS
BECOME AND WE'VE ALL SPENT --
QUITE A BIT A BIT OF TIME ON
THIS -- I DO THINK IT IS
EXCEPTIONALLY IMPORTANT VOTING
RIGHTS.
ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN HOLD THE GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE AN THAT THERE'S
TRANSPARENCY IN SO THAT REALLY
IS FOR ME GOAL NUMBER.
ONE THE SECOND GOAL FOR ME IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE WATER RIGHTS
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY STAY WITH
IMPERIAL COUNTY WITHOUT A SHIRT
MAKE SURE TO HOW. TO TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS OTHER
QUESTION THAT HAS COME UP THAT I
WASN'T SURE THAT I UNDERSTOOD
BEFORE BUT I NOW KNOW IT'S VERY
REAL.
AND THAT IS THAT THERE'S THIS
FIFTEEN YEAR TIME FRAME I'M IN
WHICH THERE IS DISAGREEMENT
BETWEEN IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT AND TELL ABOUT A WATER
DISTRICT.
AND THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT
WHO'S GONNA PROVIDE POWER IN
THAT THAT TERRITORY -- IN
PERPETUITY THAT QUESTION HAS TO
BE ANSWERED I'VE AND THIS IS
ANOTHER ISSUE SAID I WANT TO GET
INTO THIS BUT I DO THINK THAT IS
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO HAVE
A CONVERATION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE HAVE GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND MAKING SURE THE
GOVERNMENT CAN BE ACCOUNTABLE TO
ITS PEOPLE SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SECRETARY TAKE THE
ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER OF THAT.
RAMOS.
RAMOS KNOWS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SNOW ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HI VOEPEL
[inaudible]
I THE MEASURE IS OUT
FIVE TWO TWO GOVERNOR
.
OKAY SO EVER COOPER.
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
ONE FORTY ONE BEGIN.
THE MUSIC HERE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
OVER A SPAN OF FOURTEEN YEARS
THE GOLDEN STATE KILLER WAS
SUSPECTED OF COMMITTING MULTIPLE
MURDERS.
RAPES KIDNAPPINGS ROBBERIES AND
BURGLARIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE GOAL IS THE KILLER'S CRIMES
ARE SO VIOLENT AND WIDE SPREAD
OVER THE YEARS THAT HE WAS ALSO
KNOWN IN VARIOUS PARTS OF THE
STATE IS THE EASTER RAPIST.
BUY SELL YOUR RED SECTOR IN THE
ORIGINAL NIGHT STALKER.
LAST YEAR JUST OF DEANGELO WAS
ARRESTED AS THE GSK SUSPECT.
THE TRIAL GSK IS GOING TO TAKE
PLACE ON AN EXCUSE ME.
IS GOING TO PLACE AN EXPECTED
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON THE COUNTY
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR TRYING THIS
CASE.
AB ONE FORTY ONE WILL ESTABLISH
THE MECHANISM WAS DESCRIPTOR
KNEES AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AFFECTED COUNTIES BE ABLE TO
SEEK REIMBURSEMENT FOR
EXTRAORDINARY COST.
WITH YOUR WITNESSES FROM SEVERAL
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DIFFERENCE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY MORGAN GEYER
IT'S SECOND OKAY PUBLIC DEFENDER
STEVE STEVEN GARRETT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- IT IT'S MY GREAT
HONOR TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS AB
ONE FORTY ONE I'D LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER FOR
BRINGING THE BILL MY NAME IS
MORGAN GEYER.
I AM A SUPERVISING DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE --
I HELP OVERSEE OUR CONVICTION
INTEGRITY AND POST CONVICTION
UNIT.
AND IT IS AN HONOR TO BE SITTING
ON THE SAME SIDE OF THE TABLE AS
MY STEAM CALLING MISTER GARRETT
THE PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR SEGMENT.
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS CASE OF
THE CASE AGAINST MR D'ANGELO
CAN'T BE OVERSTATED -- WE ARE
EXPECTED AS PROSECUTORS AND
PUBLIC DEFENDERS TO HANDLE A LOT
OF CASES WE ARE EXPECTED TO
HANDLE A LOT OF BIG CASES.
BUT NOTHING COULD HAVE PREPARED
US OR BEEN ANTICIPATED WITH
REGARD TO THE VOLUME OF THIS
CASE -- JUST TO GIVE AN IDEA OF
SOME OF THE LOGISTICS INVOLVED.
THIS CASE SPANS WITH AN
INVESTIGATION THAT SPANS OVER
FORTY YEARS.
ON THERE ARE THIRTEEN PEOPLE WHO
WERE MURDERED THERE WERE.
NEARLY FIFTY PEOPLE WHO WERE
RAPED.
THERE WERE OVER A HUNDRED
BURGLARIES.
THE THE VOLUME OF INFORMATION
AND EVIDENCE IN THIS CASE IS
STAGGERING.
NO ONE COULD HAVE PREDICTED THIS
AND NOT ONE SINGLE COUNTY SHOULD
HAVE TO SHOULDER THE BURDEN --
THE THE BURDEN THAT COMES FROM.
THIS KIND OF UNANTICIPATED
EXPENSES.
WOULD JEOPARDIZE THE OPERATIONS
OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN PLACE AN
ENORMOUS BURDEN ON THE DA'S
OFFICE ON THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE.
THAT WOULD RESULT IN DELAY.
AND DELAY RESULTS IN.
JUSTICE THAT IS DENIED FOR THE
ACCUSED DELAYS PREJUDICIAL TO
THE ACCUSED.
AND IT DENIES.
JUSTICE TO THE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS WHO HAVE WAITED A VERY
LONG TIME TO SEE THE STAY CALM.
THE PRE TRIAL.
ASPECTS OF THE CASE WILL RESULT
IN EXTRAORDINARY COSTS AND
BURDENS THE TRIAL WILL BE.
LOGISTICAL FEAT TO PUT TOGETHER
WITH.
OVER ELEVEN COUNTIES INVOLVED
COMPRISING OVER ONE THIRD OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS QUITE SIMPLY
HASN'T BEEN DONE BEFORE.
THE COSTS OF A LARGE CASE ARE
ALWAYS ANTICIPATED IN THE
ORDINARY COURSE OF BUSINESS AND
THE COSTS THAT WILL BE
ASSOCIATED WITH PUTTING ON THIS
TRIAL IN SACRAMENTO WILL BE
EXTRAORDINARY.
AND AB ONE FORTY ONE PROVIDES A
MEASURE TO RELIEVE THAT BURDEN
ON THE COUNTIES TO PROVIDE THE
DA'S OFFICE ON THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFSET THOSE
EXTRAORDINARY COSTS THAT QUITE
SIMPLY COULDN'T HAVE BEEN
ANTICIPATED BEFORE [inaudible]
THE PROCESS SHOULDN'T BE DELAYED
BECAUSE THERE AREN'T SUFFICIENT
FUNDS AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
ONE COUNTY SIMPLY CANNOT BEAR ON
ITS OWN.
SO WITH THAT I WILL.
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OR TURN OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GARRETT.
BUT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WILL CHAIR OF
MARBLE MEMBERS I'M STEVE KERR
ITEM THE SECOND COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU.
AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL WHICH THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO HAS PUT FORWARD -- A
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER ARE IN AGREEMENT BUT
AND WE ARE IN AGREEMENT ON THE
SIZE AND THE MAGNITUDE OF OF
WHAT WE ARE FACING HERE -- AND
AND I WANT TO BE I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR IT BUT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POTENTIAL CRIME SCENES.
I MEAN THAT ALONE IS STAGGERING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUTHUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF WITNESSES FORTY TO
FORTY FIVE YEARS OF
INVESTIGATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ELEVEN COUNTIES WHICH
MAKES UP A JUST AMONG THE THE
COUNTIES THAT COULD BE INVOLVED --
POTENTIALLY I THINK -- ALMOST A
THIRD OF THE STATE -- IT IT THE
ALLEGED THE ALLEGATIONS TOUCH
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
THEY TOUCH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA LARGE PORTIONS
THERE.
AND THEY TOUCH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SACRAMENTO DOWN TO TULARE.
SO WHICH SHOULD BE HUGE EXPANSE
HUGE GEOGRAPHIC AREA A HUGE -- A
TIME PERIOD AND A HUGE NUMBER OF
OF POTENTIAL WITNESSES.
ESTIMATES EARLY ON AND I AM I OR
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IT YET THE EARLY
ESTIMATES ARE THAT THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WE MAY BE GIVEN.
COULD NUMBER -- OVER A MILLION
PAGES WHICH IF YOU SAT DOWN JUST
WITH YOUR PHONE AND THE
CALCULATOR FUNCTION YOU'LL FIND
THAT FOR ANY ONE OF US TO TRY
AND READ THAT.
WOULD BE MANY YEARS OF OUR LIVES.
AND SO WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE NORMAL KIND OF CASE.
WHERE WE CAN HANDLE THAT --
WITHIN OUR BUDGET CONSTRAINTS.
WERE LOOKING AND AMIN AS DEFENSE
LAWYERS WERE FACING A TEAM OF
POTENTIALLY OVER THIRTY
PROSECUTORS OR THIRTY PEOPLE
FROM THE PROSECUTION.
WE'RE NOT BILL FOR THAT.
I ASK THAT YOU GIVE FAIR
CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORT THE
BILL THAT -- SEKHEMRE COUNTY HAS --
PUT FORTH IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ON THE EDGE OF THE THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
CHRISLEY AND COMPANY CITIES
ASSOCIATION -- JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
I GUESS THAT'S IT.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY QUICKNESS OF SORRY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SECOND.
CARE MOST A SECOND JUST REAL
QUICKLY.
HOW CLOSE IS AS THIS
INVESTIGATION?
COAST COMPLETED.
STEVE KERR'S HER DRESSING UP TO
ME -- MY EVER WILL ENSURE ONLINE
I I'LL GIVE YOU I THINK I CAN
GIVE YOU A FAIR ANSWER SO.
I BELIEVE THAT THE NUMBER TWO IN
THE SACRAMENTO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WAS ONCE ASKED
THE QUESTION.
AT THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ABOUT THAT IT AND THE ANSWER WAS
SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS CASE
FOR ALMOST FORTY YEARS -- THE
DEFENSE NEED SOME TIME TO CATCH
UP -- AND YOUR WILL OUR
INVESTIGATION WILL BE
INDEPENDENT OF WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT US AND WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
DONE AT THIS POINT.
AND I'VE GOT PEOPLE WORKING FULL
TIME ON THIS SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU WOULD BE DO YOU HAVE ANY.
ACTION OF HOW LONG IS THAT WE
TALK AND MANY MANY MORE YEARS
BEFORE THAT YOU'RE PREPARED TO
GO TO TRIAL.
WELL I EIGHT IT'S DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT THAT -- I I ALL I CAN
SAY IS THAT WE WILL DO WE WANT
TO DEAL WITH THIS CASE --
PROFESSIONALLY AND EXPEDITIOUSLY
BUT WITHOUT THE RESOURCES THAT'S
NOT LIKELY THE WHO WITH
RESOURCES LET'S SEE GET
RESOURCES.
AS OR ANY KIND OF FINITE ANSWER
YOU CAN GIVE TO THIS CASE.
WHAT WITHOUT HAVING OPTED
REDISCOVERY WHICH WE HAVE NOT
YET BEEN ABLE TO DO?
I CAN'T ANSWER THAT BUT IT ILL.
THESE CASES ARE NOT SHORT THEIR
DIFFICULT CASES THEY'RE HARD
CASES PEOPLE WHO WORK
UNDERSTATEMENT ON THE YEAH
PEOPLE GET SICK WORKING ON THESE
CASES SO -- THESE ARE -- REAL --
STRUGGLE SO WE HAVE I'M NOT
TRYING TO AVOID YOUR QUESTION
I'M JUST I'M NOT TRYING TO GIVE
AN ANSWER WHICH IS -- FAULTS
PRECISION -- ENOUGH.
AND JUST TO DECLARE FOR THE
INVESTIGATION DOESN'T STOP.
AT THE FILING OF CHARGES THE THE
THE INVESTIGATION FOR PURPOSES
OF PROSECUTING THE CHARGES THAT
ARE ENUMERATED IN.
HIS IN THE CURRENT CHARGING
DOCUMENT ARE OBVIOUSLY
SUFFICIENT FOR PROCEEDING TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AT THIS
POINT.
BUT JUST GIVEN THE SHEER VOLUME
AMOUNT OF TIME OVER WHICH THESE
CRIMES OCCURRED THEY'RE ALWAYS
BE REMAINING INVESTIGATION TO BE
DONE BUT FOR PURPOSES OF OF OF
GETTING THE CASE MOVING -- THE
THE THE FILING THE CHARGES HAS
SIGNIFIED THAT IT IS COMPLETE TO
THOSE POINTS BUT JUST THE IDEA
THAT THE INVESTIGATION NEVER
REALLY STOPS JUST BASED ON THE
SHEER AMOUNT OF TIME IN VOLUME
OF OF CRIMES THAT WERE COMMITTED.
CAN OF THANK YOU.
READY CALL FOR THE QUESTION.
I GUESS YOU TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO CLOSER PLEASE THANK YOU -- IS
ESTIMATED AT THE TRIAL EXCEED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
AB ONE FORTY ONE WELL
ESTABLISHED MECHANISM IN WHICH
THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND IS
RETURNS OFFICE AS THE AFFECTED
COUNTIES WILL BE ABLE TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT FOR EXTRAORDINARY
COSTS.
IN THIS BEEN FOURTEEN YEARS --
THIRTEEN MURDERS THIRTEEN
KIDNAPPINGS FIFTY RATES ONE
HUNDRED ROBBERIES I GREW UP IN
RICHARD ALLOWS TWELVE YEARS OLD.
AND THE COUPLE THAT WAS KILL THE
AIRFORCE THURMOND WAS ABOUT A
MILE AND A HALF FROM MY HOUSE WE
DOCTOR WILL THAT NIGHT.
IT WAS HOT IN SUMMER AND NOBODY
WENT OUT FEAR GRIPPED THE SECOND
REGION.
UNBELIEVABLE -- AT HIS DELIVERY
I THINK BEING.
VERY CAUTIOUS BUT A HIGH PROFILE
MURDER CASES SOMETIMES IT MIGHT
BE TWO THREE YEARS BEFORE IT
GOES TO TRIAL.
THAT'S A REAL LOOKING AT JUST
THE THE AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE.
IT'S ASTRONOMICAL THIS IS REALLY
THE BIGGEST CASE IN THIS TO THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
AND PROBABLY THE COUNTRY WHO
HAVE SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS JUST
ONE SUSPECT.
SO -- THESE COUNTIES -- GONNA BE.
IN THE RED SIGNIFICANTLY JUST
BECAUSE THIS CASE.
AND THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO --
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE THE STATE TRYING TO SYSTEM
THESE ARE A PRESS IN THE TIMES
UNCHARTED WATERS -- SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
AND I SHOULD ANNOUNCED AT THE
THE CHAIRED HAS -- OFFERED THIS
A SUPPORT.
SHE HAS RETURNED.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
IN MY OWN Q. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY HIGH
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER VAST RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
I THERE'S A SEVEN ZERO
GRADUATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO I WAS IN HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO AHEAD [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
HISTORY THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GO [inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH GO USERS.
WE JUST.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE
HERE WERE WAITING FOR WITNESSES
TO SHOW UP AND SPONSORS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
RECONVENE HERE.
AND WELCOME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SIX SEVEN ONE OR
DO YOU WANT TO DO THE OTHER.
ONE YEAH I YEAH SIX SEVEN ONE
FIND.
GREAT.
GOOD.
I'M GOOD IF YOU'RE GOOD OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB SIX SEVENTY
ONE TO ENCOURAGE PROPERTY OWNERS
TO BUILD AN AFFORDABLE OFFER A
VIEWS FOR RENT.
OF COURSE IS A IMPORTANT PART OF
SOLVING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS -- THAT MANY LOCALITIES
ARE TURNING TO AB USE HAS A
REALLY COST EFFECTIVE WAY -- TO
ADDRESS A HOUSING COULD LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- AB SIX
SEVENTY ONE REQUIRES A LOCALITY
TO INCLUDE A PLAN THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT TO INCENTIVIZE AND
PROMOTE THE CREATION OF A VIEWS
WHICH CAN BE OFFERED A FOR
AFFORDABLE AS AFFORDABLE UNITS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO DEVELOP
A LIST OF EXISTING STATE GRANT
AND FINANCIAL INCENTIVES AND
POSTED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
WEBSITE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
LOCALITIES.
AB SIX SEVENTY ONE CREATES A
WORKABLE RESOURCE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
AFFORDABLE EIGHTY IS.
WITH ME TODAY IS NOBODY I'M HERE
ALL BY MYSELF.
AND WE LOVE BREVITY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELCOME.
TO ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
THERE THERE ARE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOU CAN JUST TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
FIND SOMEWHERE. TO WIN THIS
ISN'T OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THE JUST ANOTHER WERE
YOU TRYING TO ENCOURAGE EIGHTY
USE ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS A
WAY THAT WE SHOULD NOW START TO
TO HELP SHIFT FINANCIAL DOLLARS.
ON THIS IS A GREAT PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP POTENTIAL WE
CAN PARTNER WITH OUR PRIVATE
HOMEOWNERS TO DO A AB USE THAT
HAVE A SMALL AMOUNT OF SUBSIDY.
FOR PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR WHAT
WE COULD BUILD A NEW UNIT -- FOR
IF WE'RE TO BUILD AN APARTMENT
BUILDING WE COULD HAVE A NEW
AFFORDABLE UNIT THAT COULD BE --
CUT I HAVE A COVENANT WITH THE
PROP WITH THE HOMEOWNER AND IT'S
A WIN WIN FOR EVERYBODY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO
WE HAVE A MOTION -- I JUST ONE
THING SO WE HAVE A LITTLE TURMAN
Là ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT ALL
EIGHTY USE ALL THE TIME.
OR THAT'S WHAT IT FEELS LIKE
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD PLANNING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPTIONS LIKE
EIGHTY USES A PART PART OF OUR
HOUSING CONVERSATION I'LL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY --
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER BACK.
BURNER HER ABOUT THAT I RAMOS.
THOMAS AYE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
I MEASURES OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
ITEM I MISS FRIEDMAN THAT WOULD
BE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ELSE ARE THIS
WON'T BE QUITE AS BRIEF -- THANK
YOU ENSURE MEMBERS I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON THE
BOTTOM OF PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS
AND I'LL BE TAKING IT IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE SHOULD THE BILL
PASSED TODAY.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ASSIST THE
COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATE PROCESS
AND PROVIDES CLARITY TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RESIDENTS AND
DEVELOPERS ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
AN UPDATE A COMMUNITY PLAN IT
SHOULD SERVE OUR MIDDLE DOCUMENT
BE CHALLENGED IN COURT.
WHILE MOST JURISDICTIONS UPDATE
THE LAND USE ELEMENT OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN AS PART OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN UPDATE THOSE WITH
MULTIPLE COMMUNITY PLAN AREAS
UPDATE THESE DOCUMENTS
INDIVIDUALLY.
FROM QUERY COMMUNITY PLANS TO
REVIEW BE REVIEWED INDIVIDUALLY
SO WE SEEM AN CITIES LIKE LOS
ANGELES THEY DO COMMUNITY PLAN
KIND OF NEIGHBORHOOD BY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND SOME OF THESE JURISDICTIONS
WITH MULTIPLE COMMUNITY PLANS
THE PLANTS HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED
IN RECENT YEARS TO REFLECT
CHANGING LOCAL PRIORITIES AS
WELL AS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
HOUSING.
ABILITY AIR QUALITY INCREASING
TRANSIT RIDERSHIP VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED EXCEPT HER. FOR EXAMPLE
IN LA THERE AND LAND USE ELEMENT
IS COMPRISED OF THIRTY FIVE
COMMUNITY PLANTS THAT CONTAIN
GUIDING GOALS AND PRINCIPLES FOR
HOW EACH PLANT AREA SHOULD GROW
SOME OF THESE PLANS ARE
CURRENTLY OVER TWENTY YEARS OLD.
AND THEY BECOME A SIGNIFICANT
OBSTACLE OBSTACLE TO BUILDING
NEW HOUSING ONE SIGNIFICAN
UPDATE UPS UPDATING THESE PLANS
IS THE UNCERTAINTY THAT RESULTS
IF THE E. I. ARE.
PREPARED FOR THE COMMUNITY PLAN
UPDATE IS CHALLENGED IN COURT.
DURING THE LITIGATION PROCESS
IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
ORIGINAL COMMUNITY PLAN OR THE
UPDATE WILL BE IN EFFECT CAUSING
DEVELOPER SOME PLANNERS GREAT
UNCERTAINTY AND POTENTIALLY
DELAYING ALL DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY PLAN AREA.
AND AFFECTING THE ABILITY TO
OBTAIN NEEDED HOUSING INTENDED
BY THE COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATE.
UNDER AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT WERE
APPROVED -- DEEMED A PRIOR
DEEMED COMPLETE A COMPLETE PRIOR
TO RECORD ISSUED RICHER RESCIND
AVOID UPDATED COMMUNITY PLANS
CANNOT BE INVALIDATED BY THE
COURT.
AB FIFTEEN IS NARROWLY TAILORED
AND MAINTAINS ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SEEK WERE TO
DISCLOSE ALL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS ASSOCIATED WITH AN
UPDATE UPDATED COMMUNITY PLAN.
AND DOES NOT PROHIBIT A PLANTS
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FROM BEING
CHALLENGED.
FINALLY AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN WOULD
ONLY APPLY TO COMMUNITY PLANS OF
ALREADY MET A HIGH SAID OF
SPECIFIC CRITERIA.
AIMED AT ADVANCING LOCAL AND
STATE PRIORITY INCLUDING HOUSING
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITH ME
TODAY IS NICHOLAS MAYOR SOCIAL
WITH THE CITY OF LA TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME'S NICK
MARISSA CHIN I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI OF
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTEEN I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE WITH YOU TODAY.
AS THE SOMEONE EVER SAID IN LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY PLANS ARE THE
PARCEL BY PARCEL BLUEPRINT FOR
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT IN OUR CITY.
DESIGNATING LAND FOR A VARIETY
OF USES AND INTENSITIES.
THE MAYOR HAS COMMITTED TO
HAVING ALL THIRTY FIVE OUR
COMMUNITY PLANS UP TO DATE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND WE ARE
COMMITTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
YOUR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO FIND THESE EFFORTS.
WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR COMMUNITY
PLAN STAFFING FROM ABOUT A DOZEN
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO TO OVER
SEVENTY STAFF NOW SO WE ARE
PUTTING TREMENDOUS RESOURCES
INTO THIS EFFORT.
AS PART OF THE UPDATE PROCESS
WE'RE WORKING TO ALIGN THE LAND
USE POLICIES IN OUR COMMUNITY
PLANS WITH STATE AND LOCAL GOALS.
THAT SUPPORT BOTH INCREASED
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
WE ARE CURRENTLY ACTIVELY
UPDATING SIXTEEN COMMUNITY PLANS
I HAVING COMPLETED OUR SIX
ALREADY.
AND THE CITY HAS EXPERIENCED
UNCERTAINTY IN THE PAST WITH
RESPECT TO IMPLEMENTATION OF
ADOPTED LAND USE PLANS WHEN THEY
ARE SUBJECT TO A SECRET
CHALLENGE.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE CLARITY
ON HOW TO YOUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CAN PROCEED WITH
IMPLEMENTATION DURING THAT
PERIOD.
CITIES AND COUNTIES CAN DO GREAT
PLANNING TO INCREASE CAPACITY
FOR HOUSING IN THEIR LAND USE
PLANS.
BUT IF WE ARE PREVENTED FROM
IMPLEMENTING THE PLANS DUE TO
LEGAL UNCERTAINTIES WE CAN
EXPERIENCE YEARS OF DELAY BEFORE
THE ADDITIONAL HOUSING CAPACITY
IS REALIZED.
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
REMOVES THAT AMBIGUITY HELPING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PROPERTY
OWNERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW THESE
PLANS MAY BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
EVENT OF A CHALLENGE.
THE BILL WILL ENCOURAGE
JURISDICTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
TO MAXIMIZE THEIR EFFORTS TO
ADOPT LOCAL LAND USE PLANS THAT
INCREASE HOUSING CAPACITY.
AND OPPORTUNITIES HOUSING
CAPACITY IN HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES IN A COMMUNITY
LIKE CONTACTS FOR THESE REASONS.
GARCETTI SUPPORTS AND SPONSORS
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN AND WE THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TO ACT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MENTOR MEMBERS MORE TALK ON
BEHALF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE OTHER WITNESSES.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WE NEED A MOTION. SEVEN THE
MOTION AND A SECOND.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
MANY OF OUR CITIES -- THANK YOU
FOR THIS VERY TAYLOR BILL TO
ENSURE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS ARE
NOT NECESSARILY DELAYED WHEN THE
COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATE.
GETS HELD UP IN THE COURTS.
DUE TO THE TIMING WILL SEND THIS
BILL ON OUT ON THE DO PASSED
MOTION WITH THE COMMITMENT TO
TAKE THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
NOW TO RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITH THAT I'LL BE VOTING I FOR
IT THANK YOU.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HARPER AT
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I MET.
MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU -- I'M
GOING TO TURN THIS OVER TO THE
VICE CHAIR I HAVE TO GO TO A
BILL.
IN OUR NEXT ONE UP WILL BE THE
ONE THREE WHAT TELL. SEVENTEEN
SEP [inaudible]
AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN CREATES A PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE DENSITY AND CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS NEAR
TRANSIT CORRIDORS.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT HIGHER DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS IN WITHIN A
HALF MILE OF MAJOR TRANSIT STOPS
AT A QUARTER MILE A BUS SERVICE
ON LAND THAT IS KNOWN FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
CITIES COULD DECIDE USES PROGRAM
SO IT'S AN OPT IN PROGRAM AND
THEY THEMSELVES AND THAT'S IN
THE THE AREAS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS FINANCIAL SUPPORT. TO
DETERMINE IF A PROJECT IS
ELIGIBLE THE PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT MUST BE INSIDE THE
CITY DESIGNATED PROGRAM AREA AND
AT LEAST TWO THIRDS OF THE TOTAL
SQUARE FOOTAGE MUST BE MULTI
FAMILY.
THESE DEVELOPMENTS MUST ALSO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
BASED ON THE SET ASIDE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PROGRAM.
INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPMENTS WOULD
RECEIVE FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN THE
FORM OF A BOND FROM CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AUTHORITY IN
EXCHANGE FOR PROVIDING HIGH
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT WITH INCOME
RESTRICTED UNITS FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS.
THE AMOUNT OF THE BOND IS
DETERMINED BY THE DURATION OF
THE TAX ABATEMENT.
WE'RE WORKING WITH CAL HFA AND
CONSULTING WITH BOND COUNSEL
REGARDING ON HOW TO ENFORCE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BOND
COVENANTS AND OTHER ISSUES WITH
BONDING.
AGAINST TAX INCREMENT.
THE BILL WAS SUPPORTED BY STATE
TREASURER IF YOU OWN A MOP WHO
SITS ON CAL HFA CALIFORNIA
YOU'LL BE THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
WITH ME TODAY IS MIKE KING CELL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR UP WITH
UP FOR GROWTH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM MADAM CHAIR AND
IT.
IS.
A VICE CHAIR LACKEY AYE AYE
THAT'S RIGHT NOW I'LL AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN AS BANKING
CELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF UP
FOR GROWTH ACTION IN OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE PROJECT -- AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN REPRESENTS A
CRITICAL TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION HOME SHORTAGE THAT
HAS BEEN THAT IS TWO DECADES IN
THE MAKING.
I AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
PROVIDES -- LOCALITIES CITIES
AND COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WITH AN OPTION TO PROVIDE.
TO BRIDGE THE FEASIBILITY GAP TO
ENABLE THE TYPE OF SMART GROWTH
ACCESSIBLE GROWTH I TRANSIT
ORIENTED HOUSING OPTIONS THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE YEARNING -- FOR
BUT IN TOO OFTEN CASES DON'T
HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE THE THE BILL CREATES A
PROGRAM THAT CREATES IN NUMEROUS
PUBLIC BENEFITS FROM INCREASING
HOUSING SUPPLY -- TO MEET
TODAY'S HOUSING NEED AND DEMAND
I IT IN SO DOING ADDRESSING
AFFORDABILITY CREATING -- IT
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS TAKING MORE CARS OFF
THE ROAD BECAUSE THESE HOMES
LOCATED NEAR TRANSIT -- ARE
OCCUPIED OFTEN MY FOLKS WHO
DON'T USE THEIR CAR BUT INSTEAD
TAKE THE TRAIN I INCREASING
ECONOMIC OUTPUT INCREASING
ECONOMIC OUTPUT IN GROWTH ACROSS
THE STATE -- AS WELL AS CREATING
POSITIVE FISCAL BENEFITS IN
TERMS OF INCOME TAX REVENUE I IN
SALES TAX REVENUE ACROSS THE
STATE SO FOR THOSE REASONS UP
FOR GROWTH ACTION IN OUR
COALITION MEMBERS SUPPORT --
PASSAGE AND URGENT AYE VOTE --
IT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS -- LUIS MANTE WITH
CALIFORNIA BE AT THAT THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION HOME SHORTAGE
IS EQUAL TO THE ENTIRE SHORTAGE
OF THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES
COMBINED.
WE SEE THIS OPTIONAL TOOL IS AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO HELP CALIFORNIA
RESOLVE THAT SHORTAGE AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STEVE ALL COMBAT THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TÁI DAVID ON BEHALF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
MATT REGION WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
GUESS WOULD GET YOUR TURN TO
CLOSE THEM THIS WOULD JUST GIVE
OUR COMMUNITY IS ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX SHOULD THEY CHOOSE
TO USE IT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE ALL HANDS ON DECK WE
NEED TO MAKE A MAJOR INVESTMENT
HOUSING AND THIS WOULD WE WORKED --
FOR TO ACTUALLY A COUPLE YEARS
NOW ON THIS BILL -- HOPEFULLY WE
CAN YOU KNOW WE FEEL THAT WITH
THE POLICY IS RIGHT NOW TO BRING
IT FORWARD.
I THANK YOU WE NEED A MOTION.
KERRY OF FIRST AND SECOND IN
THIS ENJOYS A AND DO PASSED FROM
THE REAL CHAIR.
OF THE QUESTION.
AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D BURNER **** BATH RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
OF HELL NO THE BILL IS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THESE TWO BOATS BUT OR MADE A
CALL OKAY [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR. EIGHT AND ELEVEN
ITEM THREE MISTER CHIU.
KANSEN CHU.
WE KNOW THE ANSWER MAY BE.
HELLO WITNESSES MAYBE ALL HEREBY
WAY TO SETTLE GUEST AGO STAR ALL
RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SEND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO THE REAL CHAIR --
GOOD AFTERNOON -- I LIKE.
SENDING THE AB FIVE ZERO EIGHT
FIRST. FIVE ZERO EIGHT ON TO
DELIVER SAVE WATER TO SMALL
COMMUNITIES WHO RELY ON DOMESTIC
WELLS AND SMALL WATER SYSTEMS.
THE BILL AB DID THIS BILL BUILT
ON CALIFORNIA.
ONGOING EFFORT TO PROVIDE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT DURING
PUBLIC ALL RICH AND
CONSIDERATION OF CONSOLIDATION
OR EXTENSION OF SERVICES.
THE WATER BORE INFORMED
RESIDENTS IF THE OWNER OF TO
DOMESTIC WELL OR DWELLING IS
WITHHOLDING CONSENT. TO THE
STATE FUNDED CONSOLIDATION OR
EXPANSION OF SERVICES.
COMING HERE A MEMBER REMOVED A
SECTION OF TO BUILD THAT
PROHIBIT RECEIVING WATER SYSTEM.
FROM ILLEGALLY CHARGING THE
STATE FEE OF FEED I MEANT FOR
THE NEW DEVELOPMENT WHAT PROJECT
ARE MEANT TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TO THE EXISTING
COMMITTEE.
A LAST WEEK -- I MY OFFICE IS IN
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS HE IS
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCY.
WERE WORKING ON NARAL INTO
SECTION.
AND TO ENSURE THERE WOULD BE NO
AND INTEND THE CONSEQUENCES.
OF AND SO WE HAVE -- CAME UP
WITH THIS AGREEMENT.
AND AND A MEMBER BUT DUE TO THE
TIME CRUNCH WELL -- WE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT TAKE BILLS
AS COMEDIA MEMON TODAY.
BUT I WOULD TAKING THOSE TO
AGREED UPON IN NAM AND AS ALSO
THERE'S A MA'AM AND YOU FLY BILL
MAKE IT OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY.
I'M FINE THIS WILL MAKE SURE
THOSE FEES TO NOT TAKE AWAY.
THE STATE RESOURCES THAT COULD
GO DIRECTLY INTO PROVIDING CLEAN
DRINKING WATER OR RACE THE
CALLED COST OF PROJECT TOO HIGH
FOR THE STATETO PRESERVE. TO
PURSUE.
AB FIVE ZERO A IS SPONSORED BY
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL. FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE.
POLICY LINK CLEAN WATER ACTION
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
DAUGHTERS.
WAS ME TODAY ARE -- MICHAEL
CLEAR BORN FUND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL. FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND AYE RICKY DS --
RULE UP IN -- CALL OF CON CONTRA
CREEK.
CALIFORNIA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE CAN HOOK MY NAME IS MY
CLAIBORNE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
I'D LIKE TO START BY.
THANKING THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUING TO CHAMPION EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN THE STATE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AND
REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY FOR
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON DRAFT.
AMENDMENTS REGARDING CAPACITY
CHARGE PROVISION WHICH HAS BEEN
REMOVED IN THE AMENDMENTS AS WAS
JUST EXPLAINED -- THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT DATE HAVE
APPEARED TO HAVE ARRIVED AT A
RESOLUTION THAT IS ACCEPTABLE TO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS BUT AS WAS
EXPLAINED -- TOO LATE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING -- TURNING TO
THE NEED FOR THE BILL THERE IS A
DRINKING WATER CRAZY CRISIS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MORE
THAN ONE MILLION PEOPLE LACK
ACCESS TO DREDGE SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN THEIR HOMES.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THIS
CRISIS INVOLVES THOSE RELIANT ON
DOMESTIC WELLS -- WHICH PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER TO NEARLY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN RECENT
YEARS SPURRED BY THE PASSAGE OF
SB EIGHTY EIGHT AND AB TWENTY
FIVE OH ONE LAST YEAR.
WHICH GRANTED THAT STATE WATER
BOARD AUTHORITY TO MANDATE --
DRINKING WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION AS WELL AS
EXTENSION OF DRINKING WATER
SERVICE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SEVERAL WAYS
IN WHICH AB FIVE AWAIT WILL MAKE
THE MANDATORY CONSOLIDATION AND
EXTENSION OF SERVICE PROCESS
MORE EFFICIENT AND TRANSPARENT.
AN EXAMPLE FOR THE NEED OF THE
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS PROVIDED BY
THE BILL IS PROVIDED BY
TOMBSTONE TERRITORY WHICH IS A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AND
FRESNO COUNTY.
WITH THIRTY NINE HOME SERVED BY
DOMESTIC WELLS -- WHICH CAM AND
CONTAMINATED WITH TWENTY THREE
T. C. P. N. NITRATES LIKE CAMINO
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT LACK
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
TOMBSTONE IS LESS THAN A MILE.
FROM THE CITY OF SINGER WHICH
PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING WATER
THROUGH A PUBLIC SYSTEM.
HOWEVER THE WAY THAT THE
RELEVANT STATUTE AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN THE STATE WATER BOARD
MUST OBTAIN WRITTEN CONSENT FROM
OWNERS OF HOUSEHOLDS SERVED BY
DOMESTIC WELLS.
BEFORE IT COMPLETES A
FEASIBILITY ANALYSIS -- THIS
BILL WOULD MOVE THAT PROCESS
CHANGE THAT PROCESS SO WRITTEN
CONSENT IS CONSIDERED WHEN THE
FIT IF HE'S ABILITY -- AND ALICE
THIS IS COMPLETED.
AND THE IDEA BEHIND THAT CHANGES
THAT IT'S OFTEN DIFFICULT WHEN
WE'RE WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES
TO GET CONSENT -- WHILE THE
DETAILS OF THE PROJECT ARE
UNKNOWN PRIOR TO A FEASIBILITY
ANALYSIS.
SO.
THE BILL WOULD MOVE THAT PROCESS
SORT OF AND ANALYZING CONSENT
DOWN TO LATER IN THE PROCESS AND
HOPEFULLY BUILD MORE SUPPORT FOR
THE PROJECT IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING THE
BILL WOULD DO IS IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE STATE BOARD TO
NOTIFY BOTH HOMEOWNERS AND
CURRENT.
OCCUPANTS OF DWELLINGS WITHIN A
COMMUNITY SURVIVE FAILING
DOMESTIC WELLS -- OF THE WATER
QUALITY PROBLEMS OF THE
POTENTIAL HEALTH IMPACTS AND
THAT THERE'S A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION HERE AN EXTENSION OF
DRINKING WATER SERVICE.
AND HOLD THE BILL WOULD MAKE THE
PROCESS FOR EXTENSION OF
DRINKING WATER CITY SERVICE MORE
EFFICIENT AND MORE TRANSPARENT
AND CONTINUE THE RECENT PROGRESS
THAT HAS BEEN MADE IN IMPROVING
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THAT
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SO MY NAME IS INTRICATE THE
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT I
WAS ALSO ASKED OF WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
THANK YOU.
YOU CAN IS AN OFFICER MY NAME IS
INTRICATE THANK YOU A CHAIR VICE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
BEING HERE FOR LISTENING TO US
FOR WHAT IS REALLY A BASIC NEED
OF THIS.
OF HUMAN BEINGS IN THIS WORLD
THIS WORLD IS FACT MADE UP OF
70% WATER OUR BODIES MADE ABOUT
65% WATER AS INFANTS WE MAKE UP
TO SIXTY FIVE OR 75% WATER.
AND IT'S REALLY POINT THAT WE'RE
HERE ON THE DAY OF THE DEATH
AFTER SAYS SIR THOMAS WHO WAS
REALLY KNOWN FOR HIS -- FOR HIS --
HIGH HIS PASSING THAT HE DID BUT
HE SURVIVED BY WATER CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
AND ALTHOUGH I LIVE IN GILROY
CALIFORNIA NOW I DIDN'T WAKE UP
TODAY THINKING THAT THAT I WOULD
BE HERE BUT MY MOM TEXTED ME
THIS MORNING THAT SHE WOULD BE
HERE THAT IN ITSELF IS A IS A IS
A BIG ACCOMPLISHMENT FOR FOR HER.
AND THERE WAS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT THAT I COULD THINK OF
THAT I COULD DO IN MY HOME OR AT
MY WORK THAT WAS MORE IMPORTANT
AND WATER SO I GOT MY **** UP IN
MY CAR AND CAME OVER AND DROVE
OVER. TO SPEAK TO YOU GUYS THAT
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME BE
HERE.
OUR COMMUNITY THAT I GREW UP IN
REALLY HOT AND IN THE SUMMERTIME
MADE UP OF WATER MADE UP OF
INDIAN PEOPLE.
ITALIAN PEOPLE AND AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALL ARE STAPLES NEED
WATER NEED THAT WATER TO COOK
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT WE
COULD USE TO MAKE IT CC.
EXCEPT THAT.
I SUPPORT AB.
AB FIVE AWAIT AND ANYTHING THAT
PROVIDES CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO
PEOPLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER -- IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON YES I'M AGREED TO
AT THE A PRIORITY [inaudible]
NUMBER.
SIX WHEN THE STATUS NUMBER SEVEN
YEP.
BEEN BUT THAT BEING UP WELL YEAH.
THE PROPOSED THE MINISTER
COMMUTER THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SALLY I'VE COME
HERE TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL AB
FIVE AWAY IS WHAT SHE SAID -- MY
NAME IS MADELINE HARRIS I'M HERE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND I ALSO
SUPPORT AB -- FIVE ZERO EIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A AN URGENT
DRINKING WATER CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK IT'S
GREAT THAT THIS PROPOSAL -- IT
MAKES THE PROCESS OF CONNECTING
FOLKS TO RELIABLE DRINKING WATER
SERVICES FASTER THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS ME NUMBER IS
JULIA MENDOZA EFFECTIVENESS
CLICK ON THOUGH THEY FRESNO
BINGO THE LEPIC IN A COMPANY
THAT IT GOT BLOCKED?
APPLE YEAH OPINION ISTHIS
FOOTBALL YOU AYE SEPARATE VOICE
THE PORTLAND IS AS YOU GUYS GET
THE AND THEN WAS JUST GOING TO
THAT IS GOING COR FOR US.
HI MY NAME IS JULIA I ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M ASKING FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON US -- ON BEHALF
OF UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU.
BUT AS YET FOR CERTAIN KIßM
THANKS FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
PRINT AND ALSO SEE A CACOPHONY
IN SUPPORT.
SHE ONLY FOR LEGAL WITH POLICY
LINK IN SUPPORT.
W. AS IT CAN BE WATER SOUTHERN
ALSO BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
I KNOW OUR WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
SORRY A BIT OF A BOTTLENECK BACK
THERE JIM WHEN BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THE QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
NO QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION [inaudible]
SENATE.
OUR MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS OVER AND TAKING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
I KNOW YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THERE IS
AGREEMENT ON THE FEELING WHICH I
HOPE THE COLLABORATION CONTINUES
WITH THE AMENDMENT PROPOSED IN
THE ANALYSIS OVER THE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
US SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM HIGH BURNER **** BATH
RAMOS.
RAMOS SEIDER THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
HI.
IT'S OUT.
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU SO MOVE ONTO
YOUR ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR SB SIX HUNDRED IS THERE
YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE -- TO SET UP THE COME MEET
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
THAT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THIS.
ON THIS ISSUE.
AS A MATTER THE AMENDED THIS
BILL WILL CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE IN
THE CAR. ONE STORY -- JUST JUST
CURRENT LAW BY PREVENTING CITIES
FROM DOING SWELL I CALLED A
SELECTIVE AND EXCITATION. TO
AVOID.
AND X. SEEN A DOES VAT DIS
ADVANTAGED SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS ISSUES
IDENTIFY BY THE COMMITTEE.
IN TWENTY TWELVE CALIFORNIA
BECAME THE FIRST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY COUNTRY. TO RECOGNIZE TO
HUMAN RIGHTS TO WATER HOWEVER.
ABOUT ONE MILLION CALL OF
WILLIAM STILL LACK **** TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND MANY DON'T
HAVE RELIABLE WASTE WATER
SERVICES.
SO CURRENTLY THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO INCLUDE
IN THEIR PLANNING DOCUMENTS.
OF THE AN ASSESSMENT OF THE AREA
WHERE THERE'S A LACK OF THE SAYS
ABILITY TO DRINKING SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
SERVICES.
HOWEVER.
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY DAY ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO DEVELOP A PLAN
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO THOSE
AREAS.
SO IN ORDER TO ADDRESS A GOOD
DOES GAP IN DRINKING WATER AND
WATER AND WASTEWATER SERVICES IN
OF THIS THIS ADVANTAGE.
EARN INCORPORATED COMING
COMMUNITIES AB -- SIX HUNDRED
WHAT BILL -- THE EXISTING PLAN.
THE FOCUS ON THE NEED AND
EFFICIENCY OF THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND FIND WAYS TO IMPLEMENT.
THOSE PLANS LOCALLY.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WAS TO
STAKEHOLDERS UNDER APPROPRIATE
APPROACHES AND HERE WAS ME A
TODAY TO TESTIFY TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT.
THIS VB SETON FONG LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND
MARIA DELORES D. S. FROM UNSCOM
CONTRA CREEK.
AND INCORPORATED THE COMMUNITY
IN FRESNO COUNTY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANKS SO MUCH TO BE SEEN WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY A HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS CALIFORNIANS TODAY ARE
LIVING IN THE HUNDREDS OF
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND THEY STILL OF LIVE WITHOUT
ONE OF THE BASIC SERVICES THAT
SO MANY OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED.
SAFE DRINKING WATER ADEQUATE
WASTEWATER SERVICE AND OTHER
BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
MANY COMMUNITIES LIVE WITHIN A
STONE'S THROW OF NEARBY CITIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS LIVING AS
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM KERN
COUNTY CALLS.
ME THAT KINI THAT YEAH NEITHER
FROM HERE NOR FROM THERE.
JUST OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF
RESPONSIBILITY OF ANYONE. FOR
DECADES COMMUNITIES PERSISTED IN
THE SHADOWS NOT ONLY WITH
INADEQUATE SERVICES BUT ENTIRELY
OUTSIDE THE CONSCIOUSNESS OF
ALMOST ALL CALIFORNIANS IN A
LITERALLY INVISIBLE ON LOCAL AND
STATE MAPS.
WE HAVE BEGUN TO ADDRESS THIS
BLIND SPOT BUT NOT NEARLY
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB TWO FORTY FOUR WHICH
REQUIRED CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
IDENTIFY ALL DISADVANTAGED
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IN ITS
PLANNING AREA AND ARE REQUIRED
LEFT GOES TO CONSIDER
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES.
A MUNICIPAL SERVICE REVIEWS
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE UPDATES --
AN ANNEXATION APPROVALS IT IS
NOW TIME TO ADDRESS THE
DEFICIENCIES IDENTIFIED IN THOSE
NINE ANALYSES AND WERE CORRUPT
COOPERATIVELY TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
FUND OF FUNDAMENTAL BUILDING
BLOCKS.
OF A SAFE AND THRIVING
NEIGHBORHOOD. ONE PROVISION OF
SB TWO FORTY FOUR IN PARTICULAR
REQUIRED CITIES APPLYING FOR AN
ANNEXATION OF TEN OR MORE ACRES
TO SIMULTANEOUSLY APPLY TO ANNEX
A NEIGHBORHOOD NEIGHBORING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY.
IF THE COMMUNITY ITSELF WANTED
TO BE A NEXT WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT CITIES CAN PIECEMEAL
ANNEXATIONS FOR EXAMPLE DO KIND
OF SMALL ANNEXATIONS TO ADD UP
TO MORE THAN TEN ACRES -- IN
ORDER TO GET AROUND THIS
REQUIREMENT -- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE TODAY AS
PART OF A BROADER EFFORTS TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO SUPPORT
DEVELOPMENT OF A HEALTH AND SIT
HEALTHY AND SAFE CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MARIA THE LORD IS THE
S. I. N. THANK YOU FOR IT YOUR
ATTENTION -- I CAME FROM NOT
COME TO A CREEK RUNNING
CORPORATE RAIDER COMMUNITY SIXTY
MILES AWAY SUPPORTERS AND ALL.
I CAN TO REPRESENT MY IS MORE
TIME GOING TO A CREEK AND
NORTHERN INCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES WHO FACE SIMILAR PRO
NEWS RELATED TO ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER.
AND LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THAT REASON I SUPPORT AB SIX
CONJURED.
BY A SOMBER DEMANDS.
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OTHER OTHER -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible] FOR PEOPLE.
HELLO INTRICATE THE AS
CONSTITUENT FROM GILROY I
SUPPORT AB FIVE OH EIGHT AND THE
WAY SAME WAY SUPPORT AB SIX
HUNDRED NOW FOR THE SAME REASONS
AND TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I SEVENTY NUMBER LIKE A
WOMAN?
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BLANKA GOMEZ YOUR FOR YOUR
PROPOSED THIRTY CAN UNDER.
THIRTY I SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL A
LANGUAGE THE PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL.
COULD OPEN ON THE BED AND THEN
WE'LL BE ABLE LOCAL ISN'T IT
YEAH.
I THINK THAT THE DIFFERENT GOT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THIS
PHONE SEVENTY CENTS A PART OF SO
WHAT ARE STILL ASKING ME THAT
AND THEN PUT FOR US -- I THINK
THAT THE LOCAL DIFFERENT THE
DIFFERENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES SHOULD TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
AN INCORPORATED COMMUNITIES.
AND I'M ON I THINK WE MIGHT AS
THE MOST THE MOST UNITS UNLESS
THERE'S BEEN MANY THAT HAVE
BASIC SERVICES AND I THINK THAT
WE DESERVE THOSE BASIC SERVICES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I FIFTH.
WHEN IS THAT IS THAT I MEAN?
WE NOBODY'S COOLEY MENDOZA.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON ONCE AGAIN MY
NAME IS WILLIAM AND ALSO.
EVEN GO THE LET THE TECHNICAL
MONEY THAT A KENTUCKY COULD BUT
THEN THE SECOND OUT IF IT IS NOT.
A COME FROM THE SMALL COMMUNITY
OF DENTAL CREEK IN THE COUNTY
FRESNO.
THE END OF THIS UP ALL YOUR
LIBERAL VOICE THAT THEY SEE IN
BOTH IN LOVE ONE ALSO THRILLED
WITH A COMPANY THAT IS MILLION
CARDBOARD EITHER.
KNISHES HE THAT IS.
THE HOURLY YEAH THIS IS YOU GUYS
THAT ARE NOT.
THIS IS THE THAT IS THERE -- IS
THAT'S THE ONLY BLOOM BATTLES HE
I'M ASKING FOR SUPPORT ON A. B.
SIX HUNDRED BECAUSE I COME FROM
A SMALL COMMUNITY THAT HAS NEEDS
FOR CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND
DRAINAGE AND THINGS LIKE A FIRE
STATION.
THEY NAY MOST COMPONENTS THREE
VEHICLES HAVE YOU DONE THIS AND
KNOWING THING MY POTENTIAL HELLO
HELLO TO THEIR CAMP.
THAT ASK YOU FOR SOMETHING FEW.
WE HAVE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE TO LIVE IN OUR TOWN AND
MANY OF THEM ARE FARMWORKERS
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ATTENTION -- AND ONCE AGAIN MY
NAME IS MADELINE HARRIS I
SUPPORT AB SIX HUNDRED BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ACCOUNTABLE
TO EQUITABLE INVESTMENT IN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AND I
THINK THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ACHIEVE THAT FROM WOMAN.
THANK YOU. NINE THE NUMBERS THEY
LIVING UP BY YATALA PROPOSAL SO
YOU SEE IN THOSE.
YOU WANT COMPANION AVE
[inaudible]
MASSIVE PERCEPTIONS.
HI MY NAME IS SALLY I'M ALSO
HERE TO SUPPORT -- AB SIX
HUNDRED I'M ALSO WITH -- THE
GROUP FROM GOING TO A CREEK --
THANK YOU.
DEBBIE WAS WITH ME WATER CENTER
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SHE ONLY
PLAYED A LINE HERE REPRESENTING
POLICY LINK WHERE CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I KNOW OUR WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
LETTERMAN BECAUSE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL I WAS RAISED IN A NON
CORPORATE COMMITTEE CALL TOWN
CALIFORNIA IN FRESNO COUNTY AND
TO JUST TO SAY THAT I AM A
PERSON WHO WAS RAISED IN A
CORPORATE COMMUNITY.
HAVING TO CONSTANTLY BEING
SHOWERED WITH CLOCKS IN MY WATER
I'M FORTUNATE ENOUGH THAT MY
FAMILY HAS MOVED.
BUT THIS IS DEFINITELY A BILL
THAT WAS A POOR UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES WILL BE POURED THANK
YOU.
I ARE THERE ANY -- THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION.
I'M DON'T KNOW WHAT'S AHEAD WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION WE WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY CONCERNED WITH THE
BILL AS IT CAME INTO COMMITTEE
BUT I WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK I HAVE I HAVE THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF AND THE SPONSORS AND
THE AUTHOR.
IS TRYING TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS IMPRINT
AND CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MANY OTHERS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAMELA MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSIONS.
AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE WE DID
HAVE SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WITH THE
BILL GOING INTO COMMITTEE I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO YOUR STAFF AND THE SPONSOR --
FOR FIRST FULL TAKING UP THIS
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
WE CERTAINLY AGREE AND SUPPORT
OF THE EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE SAFE AND
ADEQUATE DRINKING WATER.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU --
ON FINDING THE THE RIGHT
POLICIES TO MAKE THAT WORK THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI ANTHONY TOWN HELL CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND HAS MY PROCESS WAS JUST --
SHARED THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING.
OPEN TO THE DIALOGUE IN THE
DISCUSSION.
AND OTHER FOR THE CONTINUING
THAT IN REVISITING OUR POSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEVE CREWS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SOME REALLY -- WE HAD
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF OPPOSITION --
BUT SUBSEQUENTLY -- SAT DOWN
WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE AND
SPONSORED WORKED OUT OF SOME
ISSUES AND BASED UPON THAT
COMMITMENT ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE SEEN. TO REMOVE THERE
IS A LINKAGE TO NEW DEVELOPMENT --
TO THE PROVISION OF SERVICE TO
AN RELATED AREAS -- WITHOUT
NECESSARILY FUNDING THAT IS WELL
THAT WOULD OVERSEE SHIP COSTA.
ON NEW HOME BUYERS AND SO WITH
THAT COMMITMENT WE ARE CAN
REMOVE OPPOSITION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE IN THE NEAR MOTION.
THE MOTION A AND THE SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR WORKING WITH ME IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THIS BILL.
I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
PROBLEMS.
SB SIX HUNDRED IS TRYING TO
SOLVE.
ENSURING THAT EVERY RESIDENT
CALIFORNIA SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER IS CRITICAL.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NUMBER OF
TOOLS THAT ALREADY EXISTS TO
HELP REDUCE THIS PROBLEM.
WE SHOULD TAKE A MORE IN DEPTH
LOOK AT THOSE TOOLS TO SEE HOW
THEY CAN BE IMPROVED.
ADDITIONAL MANDATES ON LOCAL
AGENCY BUDGETS THAT ARE ALREADY
STRETCHED THIN AND ADDING
BARRIERS TO GROWTH DURING
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS ARE
IMPORTANT FACTORS THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER.
I ASK THAT YOU WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS DISCOVER WHERE THE
DEFICIENCIES CURRENTLY ARE AND
HOW TO FILL THOSE GAPS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
SOLUTIONS -- AND THE FOR THE
CONVERSE JUST CONVERSATION THIS
WILL BRING THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
REALIZE THIS IS AN ISSUE AND WE
GOT TO DO IT ALL RIGHT.
THE FIRST TIME RIGHT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING THIS FOR
NOW BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY.
SECRETARY.
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
THE BILL.
THE BILL SO.
SIX ZERO THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
ALL THOSE THE TESTIFIED ON THAT
ONE THAT'S FOR WITH.
A DICK RUBIO -- LET'S SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
AS A BRO NEVER MIND HOLD ON YEAH
OKAY.
IT SAYS THE BRO SORRY.
OKAY I NEXT UP WILL BE -- ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE THIS IS A
TESTIMONY ONLY. ZERO MAKE SURE
YOUR FIRST.
BEFORE YOU START [inaudible]
THIS RECIPE.
THE PACKETS THE BIGGEST THE I
JUST STARTED TODAY WILL BE
HEARING TWELVE SEVENTY THREE FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY.
THAT MEANS NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN
BUT WE WILL BE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
THE AUTHOR -- WILL HAVE TWO MAIN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TWO MAIN
ENOUGH OPPOSITION AND THE NAME
OF ORG NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION FROM OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
AFTER TESTIMONY IS FINISHED WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY DISCUSSION
FROM THE MEMBERS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER ROWE
FOR BEING HERE TODAY I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE LOCAL
CONTROVERSY.
SURROUNDING THE HIGHWAYS IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND HOPE THE LOCAL
SOLUTIONS BETWEEN THE EFFECTIVE
DATE IS GOING TO BE AGREED UPON
IN THE FUTURE.
AND I RECEIVED NUMEROUS SUPPORT
LETTERS REGARDING THIS AS WELL.
SO GO AHEAD AND START THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
TRANSPORTATION QUARTER AGENCIES
TCA WAS FORMED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX AS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY BY THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE IN SEVERAL CITIES
FOLLOWING PLANNING THAT BEGAN.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
IDENTIFYING THE NEED FOR NEW
HIGHWAYS.
IN THE MID EIGHTIES TWO BILLS
WERE PASSED OFF THREE
AUTHORIZING THE JPA TO COLLECT
TOLLS AND OPPOSE DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DIFFERING AND THE ACTUAL OR
ESTIMATED COST OF CONSTRUCTING
ROADS THE AUTHORIZATION TO
COLLECT TOLLS WAS RELYING SOLELY
UPON A FINDING THAT THERE WAS NO
OTHER ADEQUATE FUNDING AVAILABLE
FROM ANY FEDERAL STATE.
OR OTHER SOURCE THE JPA COULD
TOLL ROADS THAN TO PAY OFF THE
DEBT AND ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PRICE TAG.
THE LEGISLATION ENVISIONS THE
ROADS UPON REPAYMENT WILL BECOME
PUBLIC TO BE USED AS FREE LOADS
LIKE INTERSTATE.
FIVE THE ORIGINAL CONCEPT HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY WHEN OPENED
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES THE
SYSTEM COSTS WAS EXPECTED TO BE
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR BILLION.
AND FINAL ACTUAL INITIAL COST OF
THE ROADS WERE MISSED BY SOME
THREE POINT TWO BILLION OR ABOUT
4100%.
THE CURRENT PLAN HAS EXTENDED
DEBT AN INCREASE TOLLS AT LEAST
TWELVE TIMES SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX TO PAY OFF THAT THEN
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR DEBT WHICH
IS NOW SIX POINT FOUR BILLION.
AND UNDER THE CURRENT DEBT
STRUCTURE IS ESTIMATED TO TOTAL
ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS T. C. A..
T. C. A. WOULD HAVE THAT EQUAL
TO THE STATES OF MONTANAUTAH
WYOMING IDAHO AND NORTH AND
SOUTH DAKOTA.
THE TOLL ROADS HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING TOLLS ON THESE
QUARTER SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE AND NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DOES DO SO
UNTIL TWENTY FIFTY AND TWENTY
FIFTY THREE WELL BEYOND THE
ORIGINAL ANTICIPATED DATE OF
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE THE SYSTEM
WAS CREATED DUE TO A LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION.
FUNDINGNOW ORANGE COUNTY
RESIDENTS PAY FOUR TIMES FOR
ROADS WE PAY OUR NORMAL TAXES WE
PAY MEASURE IN TWO WHICH IS A
HALF COW I HAVE SENT SALES TAX.
IMPOSED BY THE COUNTY WE HAVE SB
ONE GAS TAXTWELVE CENTS ON GAS
TWENTY CENTS ON DIESEL INCREASE
ROSA FOR REGISTRATION FEES.
AND WE HAVE TO PAY TO DRIVE ON
THE TOLL ROADS RATHER THAN BEING
A TOLL ROAD OPERATOR WHICH IS
THEIR CORE MISSION THE TCA HAS
BECOME A PLANNING AGENCY.
THAT IS OPERATING OUTSIDE OF
THEIR LANE SO TO SPEAK.
PCA'S PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
ORTIZ DUPLICATIVE AND REDUNDANT
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY SERVES AS THE COUNTY'S
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION UNDER
STATE LAW WHICH GIVES OC TAE THE
POWER PLANT DESIGN CONSTRUCTION
OPERATE HIGHWAYS.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE AND CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY THESE
THREE DOESN'T SEIZE AND
INCONSISTENCIES HARM REGIONAL
PLANNING TO STABILIZE REAL
ESTATE MARKETS.
IN DANGER SCHOOLS THREATEN OPEN
SPACE AND OTHER NATURAL
RESOURCES THE MAN SET ASIDE BY
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL AGENCIES AS
PUBLIC AMENITIES LAST YEAR AB
THREE EIGHTY TWO WAS HEARD IN
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
THE THEME THE CHAIR KEPT
REITERATING WAS THAT NEEDED TO
BE CLEAR DELINEATION WHO THE
PLANNING AUTHORITY IS IN ORANGE
COUNTY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
IS CLEAR THE PLANNING AUTHORITY
IS THE ORANGE COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
THE OTHER STORE OVER HALF CENT
SALES TAX MEASURE IN TWO THAT IS
DONE.
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF PROJECTS IN ORANGE COUNTY
AFFORDABILITY IS A MAJOR ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO LIVE HERE.
FEES PAID TO THE TOLL ROADS ARE
HIGH NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION
INCLUDES A DEVELOPER FEE FOR
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES FROM FOUR
THOUSAND ONE OR TWENTY SIX
DOLLARS 250-007-0090 SEVEN
DOLLARS.
THESE FEES STARTED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT AT THIRTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THERE'S A COMMUNITY CALLED
RANCHO MISSION VIEJO THAT'S
CONSTRUCTING FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMES OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
AND THEY'RE PAYING AN ESTIMATED
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE TCA AND THESE ARE
ULTIMATELY FEES ARE PASSED ON TO
THE NEW HOMEOWNERS.
BUSINESSES GET HIT EVEN HARDER
WITH FEES RANGING FROM TWO
DOLLARS TO EIGHT DOLLARS PER
SQUARE FOOT THESE P. THESE FEES
ARE ALL PAID BAR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES.
AND HAVE BEEN FOR YEARS FOR A
ROAD IN MY OPINION THAT WILL
NEVER BE BILL MY BILL TWELVE
SEVENTY THREE REMOVES THEIR
PLANNING AUTHORITY AND STOPS I'M
FROM ACCUMULATING ADDITIONAL
DEBT.
THE TOLL ROAD CAN STILL BE BUILT
IF IT'S APPROVED THROUGH THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WHICH IS OUR COUNTY
PLANNING AUTHORITY.
THE TOLL ROADS REBUILDING TENNEY
OPERATE ON THE BACKS OF OUR
HOMEOWNERS BUSINESSES AND TOLL
COLLECTION.
MY BILLS INTENT IS RETURN THE
TCA TO ITS CORE MISSION AS A
TOLL ROAD OPERATOR PAY OFF THE
BONDS AND THEN TURN THE ROADS
OVER THE PEOPLE AS FREE.
WHICH WAS THE ORIGINAL INTENT
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
THE MAYOR PRO TEM OF THE CITY OF
SAN CLEMENTE THE HONORABLE
DAMPING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE ASSEMBLYMAN
BRO SAID MY NAME IS DAN BAIN I
AM ALSO THE CITY SANTA MAYES
REPRESENTATIVE.
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN HILLS
TRANSPORTATION QUARTER AGENCY
BOARD WHICH IS ONE OF THE TWO
AGENCIES THAT MAKE UP THE TCA.
BUT TO BE CLEAR I'M APPEARING
TODAY NOT IN THAT CAPACITY THIS
ALWAYS MY CAPACITY IS THE MAYOR
PRO TEM SAN CLEMENTE.
SIMPLY PUT THE TCA IS AN AGENCY
THAT'S OUT OF ITS LAND AND
OPERATING FAR FIELD OF ITS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY.
ANOTHER TO SOME WOMEN BROKE
PASSED AROUND A LETTER THAT WAS
SENT BY A CONGRESSMAN LEVIN AND
ROWDY YESTERDAY.
AND IN THE SECOND PARAGRAPH A
HIGHLIGHT THAT UNFORTUNATELY THE
TCA IS ACTED BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
ITS INTENDED PURPOSE.
AND BEGUN PLANNING NEW ROUTES
THAT PASSED THROUGH SAN JUAN
CAPISTRANO IN SANTA MANY THAT
ARE INCONSISTENT.
WITH THE STATUTORY DEFINITION IN
MANDATE ABOUT SORT TO FORTY ONE
THAT WERE ESTABLISHED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
THE T. C. WAS INITIALLY FORMED
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX IT WAS A
NOVEL IDEA THAT WORK FOR A TIME.
THE P. C. WAS ABLE TO BILL FIFTY
ONE MILES OF ROADS WITH THAT
WORK BEING COMPLETED ACCORDING
TO THE T. C. IS ON WEBSITE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE SINCE THAT
SINCE THAT TIME THE TEASE THE
TCA HAS NOT BILL ONE INCH OF NEW
ROAD OR HIGHWAY.
HOWEVER THE TWENTY YEARS THE T.
C. HAS ACCOMPLISHED THE
FOLLOWING.
THEY'VE ENGAGED IN A TWENTY YEAR
FIGHT WITH ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
ATTEMPTING TO BUILD AN
UNNECESSARY TOLL ROAD TO THE
STATE PARK IN HABITAT RESERVE.
THEY'VE COLLECTED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
DEVELOPER IMPACT FEES THAT
INCREASE THE PRICE.
OF EVERY NEW HOME AND BUSINESS
BUILT IN SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY BY
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
IT'S INCREASE THE TO DAD BY OVER
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A TOTAL
DEBT OF MORE THAN SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
SPEND TENS OF MILLIONS ON
CONSULTANTS AND LOBBYISTS TRY TO
FORCE.
FOR FORCE BUILD -- TO BUILD A
TOLL ROAD THAT NO SINGLE STATE
TO DATE HAS SHOWN IS NECESSARY.
AND DEFERRED ONE POINT TWO
BILLION AND APPROVE ROAD
WHITING'S THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE COMPLETED BY. TWENTY TWENTY
TO PROVIDE INFRASTRUCTURE JOBS
AND PROJECTS PLANNED FOR DECADES
THIS LEGISLATURE'S BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO FIX THE TCA SINCE
THE LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES OF
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS EVERY FEW
YEARS.
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE KEEP
COMING BACK TO SAY SACRAMENTO
THE TCA ISN'T CAPABLE OF FIXING
ITSELF. ONE EXAMPLE THE T. C. IS
MISMANAGING WAS SEEN AT THE
RECENT IN THE RECENT LOS ANGELES
TIMES ARTICLE.
WEISS IN TRAFFIC THESE TOLLWAY
CONSULTANTS CHARGE THE PUBLIC A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR FOR READING THE NEWS.
WE CAN FRONT OF THIS INFORMATION
TO YOU SEE AT DC STAFF ATTENDED
THEIR OWN INTERNAL AUDIT.
WHICH HE SAID -- THESE CONSOLES
MORE MONEY FOR UNDER BILLING.
WHEN CONFRONTED BY THIS AT A
RECENT BOARD MEETING TO SEE
STAFF SAID THEY ALREADY HIRED AN
OUTSIDE CONSULTANT WITHOUT BOARD
APPROVAL?
BUT DO NOT ALLOW THEM TO DO A
FRIENDS GOT IT TO SEE IF THEY
REALLY SPENT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SEVEN THOUSAND FACEBOOK
FRIENDS -- IF CONSULTANTS REALLY
SPENT ELEVEN HOURS A DAY.
READING THE NEWS THE TCA AT
STAFF CONSOLE AND SO PERHAPS
ANOTHER BOARD MEMBERS WILL SAY
THIS SHOULD BE A MATTER OF LOCAL
CONTROL AT THE CITY'S ST
COMPANIES HERE.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO TOLL
ROAD THERE ARE OPEN SPACE.
THAT'S THE MINISTRY AS FAR AS IT
GOES.
THE T. C. HAS REFUSED AS THE
LOCAL CONTROL TO PROTECT OUR
MILES OF PROTECTED OPEN SPACE
FOR TOLL ROAD.
THE NOT AGAIN NOT ONCE THAT IS
SHOWN AS NECESSARY BUT SO LONG
AS THEY KEEP STUDYING AND
STUDYING.
A SOURCE HANGING OVER THE HEADS
OF OUR CITY.
IS TAKEN POLITICAL COURAGE FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROUGHT
INTRODUCED THIS BILL.
AND TO FIGHT FOR THE RESIDENTS
OF HIS DISTRICT IT IS TAKING
COURAGE FOR HIM TO RESIST THE
ORANGE COUNTY POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS AND LOBBYIST.
WITH PUSH HARD TO KEEP THE
STATUS QUO GOING SO LONG AS THEY
CONTINUE TO PROFIT.
LOOKING AT THE LIST OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT
APPEARS IN ALMOST EACH ALL OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS THAT I SEE.
ARE PAID CONSULTANTS OR VENN
DOORS FOR THE TCA -- RECEIVING
SOME SORT OF FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION ONE FORMER ANOTHER
FROM THE TCR ITS CONSULTANTS.
IT'S CLEAR BY SO MANY DON'T WANT
THINGS TO CHANGE IN A MATTER HOW
OUT OF CONTROL HAS BECOME.
AND I THINK AS AS CONGRESSMAN
LEVIN AND AND ROUTE AS LETTER
SHOWS THIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO THE SAME
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON OR MY
COMMITTEE WENT TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
HOWEVER OTHER OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION. ONE OF
THE HUMANA [inaudible]
MANAGER.
MADAM CHAIR -- RICHARD HARRIS OF
THE NORSEMAN FIRM ON BM BEHALF
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION QUARTER
AGENCIES ORANGE COUNTY.
WHICH ARE ACTUALLY THE MOST
INNOVATIVE AND SUCCESSFUL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES IN THE
STATE.
WITH A TRACK RECORD TO PROVE
THAT.
THE T. C. A.'S BILL FIFTY ONE
MILES OF STATE HIGHWAYS WITHOUT
TAXPAYER FINANCING.
IT'S ROUGHLY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
WAS FINANCED WITH TAX EXEMPT NON
RECOURSE TOLL REVENUE BONDS.
THERE'S OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND TRIPS A DAY
TAKEN ON THE TOLL ROADS.
AND THEY HAVE OVER ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ACCOUNT HOLDERS.
THIS IS NOT AN AGENCY OUT OF
CONTROL.
THIS IS AN AGENCY THAT WORKS HAS
A TRACK RECORD.
AND IS DOING A GREAT JOB.
LET'S SET THE RECORD STATE
STRAIGHT.
FROM WHAT WE'VE SEEN THE BEEN
PRESENTED WITH.
NAY AGENCIES I'M NEVER DEFAULTED
ON ANY DEBT OBLIGATION AND
THEY'VE NEVER MISSED ANY PAYMENT
OF PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST.
THE CREDIT INVESTMENT GRADE.
IS THE CREDIT RATING IS
INVESTMENT GRADE WITH AN A MINUS
RATING BY STANDARD AND POOR'S
THIS IS.
AN INVESTMENT GRADE RATING
DETERMINED BY THIS AGENCIES
MANAGEMENT.
YOU KNOW BASED ON HOW GOOD OF
MANAGEMENT THEY DO.
AND THE FACT THEY DON'T RECEIVE
ANY OTHER STATE [inaudible]
CONTRIBUTIONS.
FROM OTHER FROM STATE AGENCIES
SOMETHING LIKE THAT LIKE ALL THE
OTHER TOLL AGENCIES IN THE AND
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY AND YET
THEY HAVE RECEIVED THIS
INVESTMENT GRADE RATING.
AB.
TWELVE SEVENTY THREE WAS
INTRODUCED INTERFERE WITH THE
ONGOING SEQUEL -- REVIEW PROCESS
LED NOW BY CALTRANS.
THEY WANT TO INTERFERE BY
REMOVING CHEESY A WHICH IS THE
SPONSORING AGENCY WHICH IS DOING
THE PLANNING AND PROVIDING THE
FUNDING FOR WHATEVER
ALTERNATIVES.
OUTS PROJECTS ARE SELECTED TO
IMPROVE SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
TRAFFIC.
IT'S A CLEAR.
THE END AROUND OF SEQUEL.
CONTRARY TO THE AUTHOR'S
ASSERTIONS THE TCA STATUTORY
AUTHORITY ITS CORE MISSION.
UNDER THE J. P. A LAW AS CITED
IN THE ANALYSIS AND WE'VE SEEN
WE'VE GOT THE STATUS OF THE
STATURE NUMBERS.
THEIR STATUTORY AUTHORITY IS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PLANNING
FINANCING CONSTRUCTING
MAINTAINING MANAGING AN
OPERATING MAJOR THOROUGHFARES
AND BRIDGES IN ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT IS NOT AT ODDS WITH THE
ROLE OF THE OTHER TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY IN THE COUNTY AND IN FACT.
AND CONTRARY TO THEIR ASSERTIONS.
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND THE TCA HAVE
WORKED TOGETHER AND THEY WORK
TOGETHER ALL THE TIME HAND AND
LOVE.
THE LAST TWO DECADES ALONE TCA
BUILT.
AND FUNDED FINANCED AND BUILT
SEVENTEEN LOCAL TRAFFIC
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS IN
COORDINATION WITH THOSE HE TA.
AND CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW AS WE
SIT HERE.
THERE FUNDING TOLL REVENUES WITH
TOLL REVENUES AND DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEET CREDITS.
WHAT'S THE AUTHOR CLAIMS ARE
MISS MANAGE SOMEHOW THAT THAT
MONEY WHAT THE THAT IS FUNDING
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF PROJECTS RIGHT NOW.
INCLUDING THOSE SO BRIDGE AND
THE LOS PAJAMAS PARKWAY.
SO BESIDES OBVIOUS TRACK RECORD
OF SUCCESS ON TRANSPORTATION I
THINK YOU'RE COMMITTEE DID A
GREAT JOB OF POINTING OUT.
THE ANALYSIS -- IN THE ROLE OF
THIS COMMITTEE HAS THE LOOK AT
GOVERNMENT'S YOU ON THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES NEITHER CALTRANS IN
ORANGE COUNTY.
HAVE THE FINANCES AVAILABLE TO
COMPLETE ORANGE COUNTY'S STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
DON'T FORGET THESE ARE STATE
HIGHWAYS THEY WERE ALWAYS ON THE
ARTERIAL MAP THERE WAS NO
FINANCING FOR IT MISTER BROLL.
ALLUDED TO IT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS LEADERS CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET THE AUTHORITY
TO CONTROL THEIR OWN DESTINIES.
AND OUT OF THAT THE T. C. A.'S
JPA WAS CREATED. FOR JP AS TWO
SEPARATE ONES ONE MANAGEMENT AND
THEY ARE NOW MODELS OF LOCAL
DECISION MAKING.
THERE'S EIGHTEEN CITIES AND
THREE COUNTY SUPERVISORS THAT
ARE REPRESENTED ON THESE THESE
BOARDS THIS IS LOCAL DECISION
MAKING AT ITS BEST WHAT WE HAVE
THOUGH.
IS ONE CITY THAT HAS A PROBLEM
WITH THE ONGOING SEQUEL PLANNING
PROCESS.
AS DECIDED TO COME TO SACRAMENTO
OF FALSEHOODS DISTORTIONS A PAID
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN GOING AFTER
THE PEOPLE THAT SERVE ON THESE
BOARDS IN THESE OTHER CITIES.
AND TURN ALL OF THAT INTO A
SACRAMENTO PROBLEM.
FRANKLY IT'S NOT A SACRAMENTO
PROBLEM THERE THIS IS JUST A
LOCAL.
INTERFERENCE IN SEQUENCE.
THE TCL LOOKS FORWARD TO SITTING
DOWN WITH ASSEMBLYMAN BRO.
THE LOCAL LEADERS WILL CORRECT
THE RECORD WORK WITH PEOPLE TO
ENGAGE IN MEANINGFUL PLANNING
DISCUSSIONS UNDER SEE WHAT.
THAT HOPEFULLY FIND THE BEST
ALTERNATIVES TO ADDRESS LOCAL
TRAFFIC RELIEF THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
TRACY VERDA TOURISM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION.
CHAU MCREYNOLDS TOWNS AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS I REPRESENTING CITIES OF
PLACENTIA SANTA ANA FULLER TEN
IN MISSION VIEJO IN OPPOSITION.
WE WERE TOP ON BEHALF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DO THE THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I AM -- ONE IT ALLUDES TO ONE OF
THE LETTERS HERE THAT THE LACK
OF TRANSPARENCY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT?
IS THE COMMUNITY THINK THAT IT
HASN'T BEEN TRANSPARENT PROCESS
IT'S BEEN GOING ON WITH THE THE
T. C. A. N. [inaudible]
AND SO.
I MEAN I DO THIS IS A LOCAL
ISSUE. TO ME IT'S NO DOUBT ABOUT.
BUT NOT TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER FIGURE THE CELLS DRIVE
ME NUTS BUT STRIVE IN THE NOTES.
TO SO HELP ME WALK ME THROUGH
THIS A LITTLE BIT.
SO.
WHAT'S HAPPENED OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS IS.
THERE WAS A ROAD THAT WAS
PLANNED AND WE ALL SUPPORTED
CALLED THE GREAT ALIGNMENT IT
WAS TO FINISH THE TWO FORTY ONE
SOUTH OF SAN CLEMENTE.
NORTH THE CAMP PENDLETON WE ALSO
PORTED AT THE TCA ONE FROM THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL WATER QUALITY
BOARD.
COULDN'T GET IT APPROVED THEY
APPEAL TO THE COASTAL COMMISSION.
THEY GOT DENIED THE APPEAL TO
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION'S
DEPARTMENT COMMERCE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THEY GOT TONIGHT.
SO.
FORCED WITH NO APPROVALS THEY
ENTERED INTO THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITTEE TO TAKE THAT OFF THE
TABLE AND NOW IT'S OUT OF THE
SKAGGS FIFTY YEAR REGIONAL
REGIONAL PLAN.
SO NOW THE WHAT THEY'VE DONE IS
THEY TURN TO FIND AN ALTERNATIVE
ROUTE WHICH THEIR FAVORITE ROUTE
IS TO COME DOWN RIGHT INTO SAN
CLEMENTE HIGH SCHOOL ON PICO.
AND YOU KNOW.
THE OPPOSITION SAID THAT THIS IS
ONE DISGRUNTLED CITY IT'S NOT
IT'S FORMER CONGRESSMAN DARRELL
ISA ITS CURRENT CONGRESSMAN MIKE
LEVIN IT'S THE STATE SENATOR
IT'S THE STATE ASSEMBLYMAN. TO
DO NOT SUPPORT THIS AGENCY
BUILDING AROUND THE CONNECTS THE
FIVE SO IT'S NOT JUST ONE CITY
AND ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE FIFTY
FIFTY ON IT.
BOARD MEMBERS ARE FIFTY FIFTY ON
IT -- DOWN THERE SOMETHING.
THEY'RE OUT OF CONTROL SOMETHING
TO DO DOING A GOOD THING
[inaudible]
AND I ULTIMATELY THESE ARE STATE
ROADS.
SO WHAT HAPPENED WAS IN THE
EIGHTIES THERE WAS NO MONEY
AVAILABLE.
THE STATE ALLOWED THEM TO CREATE
THESE ROAD OPERATE AND PAY OFF
THE BONDS OF TURN OF THE PEOPLE
FOR FREE SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
IT IT IS A LOCAL ISSUE.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT THESE ARE
STATE ROADS AND THAT'S WHY THE
STATE'S INVOLVED.
IN THE OPPOSITION TALK ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PROJECTS.
A YEAR AGO THEY TURNED OUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR TO ADD
ADDITIONAL LANES BECAUSE THE
RIDERSHIP IS NOT THERE.
BUT THEY TALK ABOUT SPENDING ALL
THIS MONEY ON THE SO PARKWAY.
THEY AGAIN TRIED TO GET LOS
PETRONIUS EXTENDED THEY GOT
DENIED SO THE COUNTY OF ORANGE.
AND THE THE RANCHO MISSION VIEJO
COMPANY OR BUILDING THE ROAD
THAT YES THEY ARE PAYING FOR IT
BUT THEY CAN'T GET ANYTHING
APPROVED SO THAT'S PART OF THE
PLANNING THING BECAUSE THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS I CAN'T DO ANYTHING
APPROVED.
AND WITH THE TRACK RECORD LOS
ETA MANAGING MOTHER MEASURE AM
TO AND ACTUALLY BUILDING
PROJECTS.
WE FEEL THE PLANNING AUTHORITY
SHOULD BE IN -- C. T..
AND TCA SHOULD JUST GET BACK TO
THEIR CORE BUSINESS OF BEING A
TOLL ROAD OPERATORS.
ANYBODY ELSE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SO A MISTER ROWE THERE'S OPTIONS
HERE -- FOR ME I'D LIKE TO SEE
YOU GUYS GO BACK AND I KNOW THIS
THIS IS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT ISSUE --
YOU BRING IT TO THE SURFACE SO
THAT ALL OF US CAN SEE HERE
WHAT'S GOING ON AND I'D.
PROPOSED THAT YOU SHOULD SHOW UP
IN THE FALL AND WE RUN THIS IS A
TO YOUR BILL.
AND SEE WHERE YOU STAND AT THAT
POINT THAT'S THE PLANET AS OF AS
WE SPOKE ON THE PHONE.
LAST WEEK I HAD TWO WEEKS A
CONVERSATION WITH BOARD MEMBERS
AND THE REASON I DID TESTIMONY
ONLY AND THE REASON WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THIS A TO YOUR BILL IS
BECAUSE THE BOARD MEMBERS.
HAVE GIVEN ME THEIR COMMITMENT
TO WORK ON THIS AND IN THE PAST
SO FOR EXAMPLE THREE EIGHTY TWO
IS RAN LAST YEAR SENATOR BATES
AND I SAT DOWN WITH T. C. A. AND
CTA.
IN SEPTEMBER AFTER SESSIONS
TODAY GUYS WHAT'S GOING ON
NOTHING'S CHANGED SO THERE'S
BEEN PROMISES AND COMMITMENTS
MADE.
BUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
LEAVING YOU WITH A LETTER OF FOR
THINGS THAT WE HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH IS HERE.
SO IF THEY DON'T HAPPEN IN THE
AND THE PARTIES ARE DEALING IN
GOOD FACE WE CAN COME BACK.
AND CONSIDER WHETHER WE NEED
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION -- BUT I
THINK THIS IS THE LEAST YOU HAVE
A GOAL AND A PLAN AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING THE
OUTCOME AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THIS CLEANED UP AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND WE WON'T HAVE TO NEED.
A RED BILL.
IT'S A SHAME THAT A LITTLE TOO
THERE WERE HERE AT THIS RIGHT
ABSOLUTE AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAD
TREPIDATIONS ABOUT DOING THIS IN
THIS MANNER AND I THINK THIS
LIST BROUGHT.
IT TO THE SURFACE IN THE
CONVERSATIONS I HOPE WILL.
START OVER RIGHT IT'S CLEAR WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE PAST THIS WORK
ON THIS AGAIN.
AND I HOPE THAT THIS COMES TO A
A I OKAY A GREAT RESOLUTION AT
THE END SO DO I OKAY AND I WANT
TO PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR WORK AND
YOUR HELP ON THIS.
THIS PROCESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME THAT'S BEEN
JOB.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
I'LL BE QUICK.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO SEE A FOUR
POINT.
ALL RIGHT NEXT WILL BE -- ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
WELCOME.
THANK YOU -- MANAGER MEMBERS IN
THE INTEREST OF A LOT OF
BUSINESS FOR THE COMMITTEE I
WILL BE BRIEF.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE IS A
BILL DESIGNED TO HELP
DISADVANTAGED UNDER PRIVILEGE
COMMUNITIES.
BY ALLOWING THEM TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT.
FROM THE CHRISTIAN STATE
MANDATES AS IT RELATES TO DELAYS
IN ADOPTING A STATE -- PROCESS
SO FOR EXAMPLE THINGS LIKE
HAVING A HOUSING ELEMENT
COMPLIANCE THE HAS GO FOR STATE
REVIEW THEIR INSTANCES WHERE THE
STATE.
FAILS TO MEET ITS OWN A
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS CAUSING A
DELAY FOR CITIES CITIES ARE NOT
ALL ARE ON EQUAL FOOTING. FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY ABOUT WATER IN
MY DISTRICT HAS EIGHTY EMPLOYEES
THAT -- DEAL WITH -- THE CITY
BUDGET -- THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAS THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES YET BOTH
CITIES ARE REQUIRED TO UNDERGO
THE SAME -- REVIEW PROCESS -- BY
THE STATE SO THIS WOULD IN THE
CASE OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ALLOW THEM TO SEEK
REIMBURSEMENT WHERE THAT DELAY
CAUSES LOSS REVENUES FOR THOSE
SMALL.
DISADVANTAGED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR BOAT
WE HAVE A SEVERAL FOLKS HERE
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WELL.
THANK YOU AT YOUR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE DEALING GIVENS WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- COULDN'T SAY IT
MORE CLEARLY THE THE SIMILAR
MEMBER DEAD -- THIS TO BE
HELPFUL THERE THAT ARE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS RANGING IN SIZE -- AND
THE IMPACTS OF MANDATES --
IMPACT THEM DIFFERENTLY BASED ON
THAT THIS BILL WOULD -- HELP
THOSE SMALLER DISTRICTS IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TING HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
TYPICALLY WE DON'T THAT'S NOT
OUR PRACTICE TO COME IN ON A
LATE POSITION BUT WE FIGURED
THAT THE MEMBER WOULD BE OKAY
WITH US COMING IN LATE SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL -- WE KNOW WE WE
SIR WE CERTAINLY DO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT AND HIGHLIGHTS -- AN
ONGOING ISSUE FOR OUR RULE OUR
OUR OUR OUR RULES CITIES THAT
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
THE OPERATIONS AND SO -- WITH
THAT WE WERE POP PRACTICES THAT
SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
POSITION FOR GRAY.
THAT WAS AND THEN WAS.
DOWN THE HALL THIS MIGHT TAKE
AWHILE.
OKAY REALLY -- NEED IT ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- I NEEDED
ENTERTAINMENT.
MOVE BILL.
A MOTION AND A SECOND -- WHICH I
TO CLOSE MEMBERS THIS IS MY PUT
YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR MOUTH IS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M THANK
YOU MISTER GRAY FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS TO PROTECT CERTAIN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM THE
DELAYED ACTIONS OF STATE
AGENCIES.
MY DISTRICT HAS A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT COULD BENEFIT
FROM THE EXECUTION OF STATE
REQUIREMENTS ON A MORE TIMELY
BASIS.
WELL I HAVE QUESTIONS ON THE
BILL'S IMPLEMENTATION THE
OVERALL APPROACH BEING TAKEN I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY.
IT'S A WORTHY ENDEAVOR.
IF IT IS IF IT ACCOMPLISHES
NOTHING MORE THAN TO SEND A
SIGNAL TO OUR STATE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES THAT THEIR FAILURE
TO ACT.
CAN HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES FOR LOCAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION PROJECTS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
THIS MAY NOT ULTIMATELY BE THE
ANSWER BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
STARTED THE CONVERSATION I WILL
BE SUPPORTING TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BURNER HER OF
THAT.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS RAMOS
AYE THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
MEASURES UP FIVE ZERO THANK
MEASURE THANK YOU MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GET OUT
OF HERE BEFORE THE OPPOSITION A
GREAT CROWD GOT IN HERE -- WAKE
US OKAY NEXT UP IS -- LET'S SEE
I DO NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B. TWELVE
SIXTY NINE RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SIXTY NINE I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
PERSONAL INVOLVEMENT. TO MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER AND YOUR STAFF
HAS ALSO BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL
AND I REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE -- THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATION AB
TWELVE SIXTY NINE ALLOWS THE
CITY OF OUR MONEY TO ENHANCE
REPLACE AND PRESERVE SEVERAL
ACRES OF PUBLIC PARK SPACE KNOWN
AS THE PIONEER PARK. TO ALLOW
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF MADE THE
DYNAMIC TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT OR A TODD -- PROJECT
TO SERVE ITS RESIDENTS AND HELP
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE CITY IS CURRENTLY DEVELOPING
THE LARGEST TODD PROJECT IN THE
UNITED STATES ON CENTIMETER
AVENUE IN SANTA FE DRIVE JUST
ADJACENT TO THE ON MONEY TRANSIT
STATION.
THE MONEY GATEWAY IS ENVISIONED
AS A REGIONALLY SIGNIFICANT
MIXED USE COMMUNITY THAT
INTEGRATES PUBLIC TRANSIT
RESIDENTIAL RETAIL COMMERCIAL
RECREATIONAL AND ENTERTAINMENT --
ENTERTAINMENT - USED -- THE
CURRENT PARK SPACE KNOWN AS
PIONEER PARK HAS BEEN
TEMPORARILY CLOSED WHILE THE
CITY PREPARES A PLAN FOR SOIL
CLEAN UP.
THE MESS THE AMENDED VERSION OF
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ONLY NOT
ONLY PROVIDES FOR THE
ENHANCEMENT IN REPLACEMENT OF
THE EXISTING PARK SPACE BUT IT
ALSO ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO REVIEW.
ALL REPLACEMENT PROPERTY WITH ME
TODAY IS ALMA MARTINEZ THE
ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF ALL MONEY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEROKEE ARE
CURRY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TOM
MARTINEZ I'M THE ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF A MONTH
THAT.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO DISCUSS
ASSEMBLY BILL WELL SIXTY NINE
WELL A LOT THE CITY OF AMOUNTED
TO ENHANCE THE REPLACE PARK
SPACE TO A LOT FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A SIGNIFICANT TEO
DE PROJECT.
PORTIONS OF THE PART.
OF THE PARKS I WERE ORIGINALLY
USED BY THE CITY FOR LANDFILL
OPERATIONS AND AFTER THE CITY
LANDFILL CEASE OPERATIONS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE THE SITE WAS
DEVELOPED BY THE CITY WHAT ONCE
USED FOR RECREATIONAL USES.
LATER FUNDING FOR THE SUBSEQUENT
PARK IMPROVEMENT WAS OBTAINED
FROM THE STATE UNDER THE RUG
ROBERTI SEE BURKE HARRIS URBAN
OPEN SPACE AND RECREATION APART
PROGRAM ACT.
THE ACT REQUIRES REQUIRES
REPLACEMENT PARK SPACE BE
IDENTIFIED IN A CHOIR IN ORDER
TO SELL THE QUIRK FROM CONVERT.
EXISTING PARKS BASE WERE OTHER
PURPOSES.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THE NEWS IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
CITY WAS AWARDED TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA.
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO
DEVELOP THE GATEWAY PARK AN OPEN
SPACE PROJECT WITHIN THE TO YOUR
TO YOUR THE DEVELOPMENT. FOR THE
USE OF RESIDENTS AND VISITORS
THE CITY HAS ALREADY BEGUN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ENGAGEMENT
WITH TO PUBLIC WORKSHOPS ON THE
MASTER PLAN AND CITY COUNCIL.
WILL BE ADOPTING A PARK
RELOCATION ORDINANCE TO FURTHER
THE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IN
CONSULTATION PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING AND DEVELOPING
REPLACEMENT AND ENHANCEMENT
PARKS BASED IN THE CITY AND
DEMONSTRATING THAT THE
RELOCATION WILL RESULT RESULT
AND NOT NET LOSS.
BUT RATHER GAME.
OF PUBLIC PARK ACREAGES FOR THE
RESIDENTS WE HAVE ALSO I'M HAPPY
TO REPORT THAT WE'LL WE HAVE
ALSO BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LA COUNTY SUPERVISOR YOU LESS OR
LEAST. TO DEVELOP APPROXIMATELY
SIX ACRES OF NEW.
PUBLIC PARK LAND AT THE MCLAREN
PAUL SITE FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
DON'T KNOW WHAT MCLAREN HALL
SITE IS.
THE MCLAREN HALL SITE IS OWNED
BY THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
WAS FORMERLY USED AS A CHILD
PROTECTIVE SERVICES FACILITIES
OPERATED BY THE COUNTY THAT'S NO
LONGER THE CASE IS BEING VACANT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO REPURPOSE
THAT.
THE TO YOU AT THE PROJECT IN
PART PARK SPACE ENHANCEMENT A
REPLACEMENT PLAN WILL IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR A MONTH
THE RESIDENTS IN PROVIDE
BENEFITS TOWARDS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
TRANSIT USE AND ADDRESS THE LIKE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO SAID.
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
THIS ROOMS THE WORSE.
WAS REALLY.
BY.
HERSELF.
OKAY IS ALREADY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NO QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
I ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU -- AND TERRY AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE -- AND
HELPING US MAKE THIS BILL BETTER --
THE AS YOU WELL KNOW THAT CAN
THE CITY -- THE DISTRICT BILLS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
DISTRICTS AND THIS IS A HUGE
PROJECT AND THE CITY BY MONEY --
HAS COMMITTED TO IMPROVING THAT
SIDE AND I AGAIN I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE WORK THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS DONE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WE DID WORK
HARD TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
PUT LOTS OF PIECES HERE AND A
LOT OF THESE A DISTRICT -- A
BILLS THAT COME THROUGH SO -- AT
LEAST THIS ALLOW THE CITY OF EL
MONTE TO PROCEED WITH THIS TEO
DE DEVELOPMENT PROJECT WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- I WILL
BE VOTING FOR YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONTENTS.
US SECRETARY TO THROW.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
INCLUDING EMERGENCY
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BURNER HER VAST
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US FIVE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
IMAGES OF SIX ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A FEW UP FOR MR CHU.
AND THAT WILL BE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB ELEVEN WILL START WITH IS
THAT OKAY [inaudible]
GOTCHA.
YEP THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES AB
ELEVEN WOULD RECREATE
REDEVELOPMENT AS A TOOL TO FUND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WELL FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
DEFINITELY HAD CHALLENGES WITH
REGARDS TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
THE ELIMINATION OF REDEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE THE STATE TO STOP
INVESTING IN ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN FUNDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
WELL AS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THIS BILL WE DO NOT PROPOSE
BRINGING BACK THE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENTS FROM REDEVELOPMENT
ONE POINT -- WERE ONLY FOCUSED
ON HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE ON
A SMALLER SCALE THAN FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT.
OUR BILL WOULD ALLOW CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AGENCIES REQUIRED AT LEAST 30%
OF THE MONIES.
GENERATED IN PROJECT AREAS TO
FUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO
AVOID THE ABUSES FROM THE PASTOR
BILL HAS MANY SAFEGUARDS
REQUIREMENTS OF DETAILED RECORDS
AN INDEPENDENT AUDITS FINES FOR
VIOLATIONS NEW GOVERNANCE
PROVISIONS AND ROBUST
REPLACEMENT AND ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES.
OR BILL DOES NOT IMPACT COUNTY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS OR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE KEPT HOLE THROUGH
PASSED THROUGH PAYMENTS FROM
CITIES.
AND THE STATE WOULD BACK FILL
THE SCHOOL PORTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT KEEPING THEM WHOLE.
THIS BILL IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO RE ESTABLISHING
REDEVELOPMENT ON A LIMITED SCALE
FOCUS ON OUR STATE'S CURRENT
PRIORITIES AND WITH SIGNIFICANT
STATE OVERSIGHT I WANT TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT.
AND THANK THE TWELVE JOINT
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL INCLUDING
THE CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE --
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS IS
THE SECOND YEAR WE MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND HOPE THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE.
A POSITIVE CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A OF OTHERS
AND SUPPORT.
REBEKAH MARQUEZ REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA LEADING
AGE CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS OF SENIOR
CARE AND SERVICES.
INCLUDING AFFORDABLE SENIOR
HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND MANAGERS
COLLECTIVELY OUR MEMBERS SERVE
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES HAS MADE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO FINANCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AD THE TRIP
PARTICULARLY HOUSING THAT IS
AFFORDABLE TO THOSE WERE
EXTREMELY LOW.
AND VERY LOW INCOME THE STATE'S
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HIGHER COST OF LIVING HAS FORCED
MANY OLDER ADULTS TO LIVE ON
FIXED INCOMES.
INTO POVERTY AND HOMELESSNESS AS
HOUSING COSTS RISE RETIREMENT
INCOME SUCH AS SOCIAL SECURITY
AND SSI HAVE REMAINED STAGNANT
AND MANY LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS
FIND AN IMPOSSIBLE PAID THEIR
RENTS.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA -- OLDER ADULTS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RECENTLY
DISCOVERED THAT WHILE THEIR
OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION WENT
DOWN 4% IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
NUMBER OF HOMELESS PERSONS AGE
SIXTY TWO AND OVER.
INCREASED 22% IN THE SAME PERIOD
THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF
RESIDENTS LIVING IN LEADING H.
CALIFORNIA MEMBER AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE IS UNDER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH.
MOST OF THE BUILDINGS THAT SERVE
THESE EXTREMELY AND VERY LOW
INCOME OLDER ADULTS WERE BUILT
USING REDEVELOPMENT FUNDING.
DESPITE NOBLE EFFORTS BY THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOUSING ADVOCATES
TO CREATE NEW SOURCES OF FUNDING
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO FILL THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR HOLE LEFT.
IN THE ABSENCE OF REDEVELOPMENT
THE OLD REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
HAD ITS FLAWS BUT IT'S
UNDENIABLE THAT THE PROGRAM WAS
VERY SUCCESSFUL AT PRODUCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AB ELEVEN SIX TO REIMAGINE WHAT
WORKED FROM THE PRIOR
REDEVELOPMENT PROGRAM WILL
AIMING TO FIX WHAT DIDN'T WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIR
WHEN HIS CO AUTHORS FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AND ARCHER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- YEAH ANY YOUR ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
STEVE ALTHOUGH WE HAVE THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSIONER ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
BIGELOW DELUCA HERE WE HAVE THE
OAKLAND MAYOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARINO I OR THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM SUPPORTING
CONCEPT OF THE IDEA OF BRINGING
BACK ANOTHER REDEVELOPMENT LIKE
TOOL THANK YOU.
LOOK OUT FOR WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORTING
CONCEPT THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF US TECHNO MEREKA
STEINBERG WHO ALSO CHAIRS THE
BIG CITY MAYORS CUSHION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I KNOW OUR WITH THE WESTERN
CINEMA POVERTY WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT WITH BRING
YOU BACK REDEVELOPMENT TITLE AND
ARE HAPPY Là THE SUMMER TWO IS
CONTAINED THE CONVERSATION ON
THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING AFTER SEE COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
MAKING CELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF UP FOR OF ACTION IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN THANK YOU.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIA SPORT CONCEPT VERY
PLEASED THAT THE MEMBER
CONTINUES THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSED AB.
ELEVEN MEMBERS THAT WERE NOT
OPPOSED TO REDEVELOPMENT DONE
RESPONSIBLY AND ON A LIMITED
BASIS WE WE CERTAINLY DON'T
OPPOSE THE CONCEPT I THINK WHAT
WE OPPOSE IN REGARDS TO THIS
BILL AND ESPECIALLY IS ONE OF
THE LEADING PROPERTY RIGHTS
ASSOCIATIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA IS A I MEAN A FEW
THINGS NUMBER ONE EMINENT DOMAIN
AND THE TAKING OF PRIVATE
PROPERTY FOR PRIVATE USE -- BUT
ALSO JUST THE THE IMPLICATIONS
OF TAXING COMMAND AND LONG TERM
DEBT.
YOU KNOW ANY LONG TERM DEBT IS
GOING TO BE ON PROPERTY ROLES
FOR THIRTY TO FORTY YEARS --
THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND AT SO PAM
PAYMENT EVERY DEVELOPMENT BONDS
DON'T HAVE FIRST CALL ON GENERAL
FUND REVENUE AND I THINK FOR
THOSE REASONS IT'S ALL THE MORE
REASON THAT BURGER SHOULD HAVE A
SAY -- REGARDING THESE PROJECTS
THAT THEY APPROVE THAT ARE GONNA
LAST FAR LONGER THAN THE MEMBERS
THAT APPROVE THEM ON OFFICE ON
ON A GPA OR IN A CITY COUNCIL
FOR INSTANCE -- SO I MEAN WE ARE
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK
OF VOTER APPROVAL AND EMINENT
DOMAIN BROADLY AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FEELS THAT IN
COMPANY JUST TO ADD.
TO AS THE SECOND WITNESS -- WE'D
MAKE TWO POINTS ONE IS THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES WERE
NOTORIOUSLY INEFFICIENT AND
SPENDING THEIR HOUSING MONEY.
THEY HAD TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS AND SPENT UPON
DISSOLUTION.
AND THEY PROPERTY OFF THE ROLLS.
FOR AN AVERAGE OF TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THIRDS FOR FOR FIVE
YEARS AN AVERAGE OF ELEVEN POINT
TWO YEARS SO THEY ACQUIRE
PROPERTY BY EMINENT DOMAIN.
NONE DON'T DEVELOP.
A SECOND POINT MISTER WOLF MADE
ABOUT LONG TERM FINANCING BUT
THIS COMMITS THE STATE TO BACK
FILLING SCHOOL REVENUES. FOR UP
TO FORTY FIVE YEARS. FOR A
DEVELOPMENT THAT ONLY NEEDS TO
BE ONE THIRD FOR HOUSING -- AND
BY THE WAY IT COULD ALSO BE FOR
OTHER PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE TRANSIT PRIORITY
PROJECTS ARE NOT JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY CAN BE UP
250% COMMERCIAL.
PROPERTY.
SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THIS WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S CHOSEN A BETTER.
PATH IN HIS BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES.
SOMEONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST -- IN
ENCOURAGED BY THE DIALOGUE GOING
ON AND AN OPEN DISCUSSION AND
KEEPING THAT MOVING FORWARD AND
WE WILL SUPPORT TODAY AND
RESERVE THAT RIGHT ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
I REQUEST AND ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THERE MOTIONS SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE OR MAKE
COMMENTS.
TO THANK YOU MANAGER FIRST OF
ALL AGAIN APPRECIATE -- THE WORK
OF YOUR WORK AND YOUR SUPPORT
AND AND THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- I THINK I'LL JUST
MENTION A FEW THINGS -- THIS
BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING
WITH REGARDS TO EMINENT DOMAIN
OR DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING WITH
REGARDS TO VOTER APPROVAL
COMPARED TO REDEVELOPMENT ONE
POINT OUT.
WHAT WE ARE CHANGING IS -- THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT WAS
USED IN REDEVELOPMENT ONE POINT
OH FOUR TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR THAT IS NOT PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL THIS PROPOSALS ONLY
FOCUSED ON THE ABOUT 20% OF WHAT
OLD REDEVELOPMENT WAS FOCUSED ON
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECES.
BUT ALL THAT BEING SAID
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW LOOK -- FOR
TO KEEP YOU ABREAST AS THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUES.
OKAY HEY -- I JUST WANT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'M HONORED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS
TRYING TO NARROW IT DOWN AND WE
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND
LET'S CONTINUE A CONVERSATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL OBVIOUSLY
TODAY.
US SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER VAST RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT THE
REVERSE HI VOEPEL [inaudible]
HELL NO -- MEASURES AT THE BUS
BILLS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE SURE WE MOVE ON TO
SEE.
I'D LIKE TO ASK MR SANTIAGO
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT THE PUBLIC
BANKS MEASURE -- SO HE HOPEFULLY
WILL BE COMING SHORTLY BUT I'VE
GOT TWO OTHER MEASURES SO.
WHEN WE GO TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN OF THAT BE FAIR CERTAINLY?
OKAY LET'S DO IT.
PERSONALLY START BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED
BY THIS COMMITTEE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRPERSON AND
YOUR STAFFS -- WORK ON THIS AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A MOMENT
AS TO WHY -- THAT'S WHY MADE A
LT OF SENSE TO DO THAT.
SO COLLEAGUES THIS IS A BILL
THAT ADDRESSES THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE BAY AREA.
YOU KNOW THE BAY AREA AS AND AT
THE CENTER OF OUR STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THE RECORD
HOME PRICES RENTS HOMELESSNESS
LEVELS COUNTLESS RESIDENTS WHO
SPEND.
HOURS DRIVING EVERY DAY WERE ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY FROM THE FICTION
AND WE'RE CONTEMPLATING MOVING.
THE BAY AREA HAS FACE THIS
CRISIS BECAUSE AS A REGION WE
HAVE FAILED TO PRODUCE HOUSING
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS FAILED TO
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FAILED TO PROTECT RESIDENTS FROM
DISPLACEMENT.
AND AT A TIME WHEN RECORD
CREATION IN THE BAY AREA HAS
BEEN AT A RECORD HIGH.
A HOUSING IS A REGIONAL ISSUE
REQUIRING POLICY AND FUNDING
COORDINATION THERE HAS BEEN NO
REGIONAL APPROACH IN THE BAY.
INSTEAD WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
ONE COUNTIES A HUNDRED ONE
CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES WHO
BEEN LEFT TO THEIR OWN DEVICES
OFTEN LEADING TO INEFFICIENCIES
AND MIXED UP MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE CONCEPT FOR THIS BILL CAME
FROM A VERY DIVERSE AND LARGE
COALITION OF BAY AREA HOUSING
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WERE TYPICALLY
AT ODDS WITH EACH OTHER WHO
WORKED FOR THE BETTER PART OF
TWO YEARS. TO ASK THE STATE TO
EMPOWER OUR REGION TO HELP
OURSELVES.
BECAUSE NO PUBLIC ENTITY IN THE
BAY AREA HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
HOUSING THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH A REGIONAL HOUSING
ENTITY CALLED THE HOUSING
ALLIANCE FOR THE BAY AREA OR
HABA.
LIKE RECENT STATE ACTIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AREA THAT CREATED
THE BAY AREA TOLL AUTHORITY AS
WELL AS WORK TO FOCUS ON THE BAY
AREA THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
RESTORATION AUTHORITY.
THIS BILL WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE
THE THIRD ENTITY OF ITS TYPE
REGIONALLY IN THE BAY.
TRANSPORTATION BAY RESTORATION
AND A HOUSING A NEW ENTITY
FOCUSED ON OUR HOUSING NEEDS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE BAY AREA
NEEDS AN ADDITIONAL TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ANNUALLY TO ADDRESS OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS.
THIS ENTITY WOULD BE ABLE TO
PROPOSE REVENUE MEASURES ON THE
BALLOT IN THE NINE BERRY
COUNTIES.
IT IS A SELF HELP APPROACH TO
ENABLE OUR REGION TO RAISE
REVENUES FOR OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITHOUT FURTHER BURNING
THE STATE.
THESE REVENUES WOULD BE ADDITIVE
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
ALREADY AVAILABLE IN THE REGION.
AND HABA THIS ENTITY WOULD NOT
DIVERT ANY EXISTING REVENUES
REVENUE STREAM FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
WITH THESE REVENUES THE ENTITY
WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS PROVIDE STAFF
REPORT SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FUND TENANT SERVICES
LIKE EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
AND ACCESS TO COUNSEL.
RELIEVING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS OF
THESE RESPONSIBILITIES A SYMBOL
PARCELS AND ACQUIRE LAND AND
MONITORING FOR A REGIONAL SCALE.
ONE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT THIS
BILL THIS BILL THIS ENTITY WOULD
HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
WORN FORCE LOCAL LAND USE
DECISIONS FOR ACQUIRE PROPERTY
BY EMINENT DOMAIN.
HABA WOULD BE GOVERNED BY BOARD
COMPOSED OF LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS WITH AN ADVISORY BOARD
COMBINED AB COMPRISED OF
REGIONAL HOUSING EXPERTS.
WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
AMENDMENTS TO TAKE OUT SPECIFIC
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES IN THIS
BILL TO ALLOW THE REGION'S
LEADERS TO DETERMINE THEIR OWN
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
I UNDERSTAND THESE CONVERSATIONS
OF ALREADY STARTED AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUATION OF
THAT.
IN CONCLUSION.
THE BERIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
THREATENS NOT ONLY THE BAY BUT
ME IS BUT THREATENS MAJOR
ECONOMIC DRIVERS FOR OUR STATE.
THIS BILL WOULD EMPOWER THE BAY
AREA TO ADDRESS OUR REGIONAL
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THAT LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES
STARTING WITH D. TO ROUTE FROM
AN ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
SO I'M GIVE THE ROW AND I'M WITH
ENTERPRISE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
AND WE ARE DELIGHTED TO BE CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL.
OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES THROUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND LAST YEAR I CO
AUTHORED THIS REPORT IT'S CALLED
ELEPHANT IN THE REGION CHARTING
A PATH FOR BAY AREA METRO TO
LEAD A BOLD.
HOW ARE A BOLD REGIONAL HOUSING
AGENDA?
IN IN THIS REPORT WE LOOKED AT
HOW OTHER REGIONS IN THE COUNTRY
ARE DEALING WITH THEIR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THEIR DISPLACEMENT CRISIS.
AND ONE KEY FINDING FROM THIS
REPORT IS THAT THOSE REGIONS
HAVE A ROBUST HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT THEY HAVE
FUNDING.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE CAPACITY TO
DELIVER BOB.
ALL SEASON PROGRAMS AND DEPLOY
INNOVATIVE FINANCING.
WE ARE DEEPLY INVESTED IN THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT'S IT STARTS TO
LAY THE GROUND WORK FOR THAT
REGIONAL ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE NEED.
AND RIGHT NOW WE RELY ON LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO SOLVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
SO MANY LOCAL ARE JURISDICTIONS
IN THE HOUSING DEPARTMENT SEE
JUST BEEN GUIDED SINCE THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT AND
THEY'VE LOST.
RESOURCES STAFF AND EXPERTISE.
AND THIS BILL AS A WAY TO HELP
US THESE JURISDICTIONS IT'S ALL
CARROTS RATE IT'S FUNDING IT'S
TA ITS HELP WITH LAND ASSEMBLY
AND DATA TRACKING.
AND THERE ARE NO STICKS OF LAND
USE AUTHORITY OR EMINENT DOMAIN.
AND SO FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS
ENTERPRISE HAS BEEN ENGAGING
HOUSING DEPARTMENTS AND PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ON THE GROUND DEALING WITH THE
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WE'VE ASKED THEM HOW CAN THE
HOUSING ALLIANCE FOR THE BAY
AREA HOW ABOUT HELP THEM.
IN THESE ARE THESE ARE THE
EXAMPLES THAT THEY GAVE.
WHEN THE NEXT NATURAL DISASTER
HITS HABIT CAN DEPLOY ITS
EXPERTISE TO REBUILD HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES?
IT CAN PROVIDE THE CRITICAL GAP
FUNDING NEEDED AROUND TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND HELP
WITH LAND ASSEMBLY.
AND IT CAN HELP CREATE AN
EFFECTIVE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM NEEDED BY FAMILIES
THREATENED BY DISPLACEMENT.
AND LASTLY I JUST WANT TO AND
WITH THE POLL THAT CAME OUT
TODAY -- FOR IN IT THIS POLL IS
FOR BAY AREA -- RESIDENTS AND
THE POLLS SHOW THAT THREE
QUARTERS OF RESIDENTS AGREE THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NEEDS TO BE A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO ADDRESSING.
ARE THE HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
BAY AREA IT SHOULD NOT BE CITY
BY CITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AND WE
I'M VERGE YOU'RE ABLE.
THANK YOU. SEVEN OTHER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR GOOD
TO BE BACK.
MATT REGION WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR REGION THE
BAY AREA FROM A SATELLITE
PHOTOGRAPH YOU'LL SEE ONE MAJOR
METRO -- WHAT YOU WON'T SEE OR
THE HUNDRED AND ONE LINE TO DRAW
UP ALL OUR LITTLE CITIES IN?
THE NINE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
THERE -- IT'S ONE ECONOMY IT'S
ONE ECONOMIC -- ENTITY -- OVER
50% OF OUR WORKFORCE CROSS AT
LEAST ONE COUNTY LINE EVERY DAY
TO GET TO AND FROM WORK SO IT'S
A VERY FLUID AREA -- IT'S ONE
REGION BUT IT BY A QUIRK OF
HISTORY IS CARVED UP INTO A LOT
OF LITTLE PIECES -- THOSE LITTLE
PIECES ON THEIR OWN CAN'T SOLVE
OUR LARGE REGIONAL PROBLEMS WERE
REGIONAL ORGANIZATION WE TRY TO
CREATE REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE INDIVIDUAL AND
TO THE CITY'S CANNOT ON THEIR
OWN -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
MENTIONED A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO --
WE SPONSORED AND OFFERED A
MEASURE MEASURE A A TO RAISE
REVENUES PARTIAL TAX -- TO
CREATE -- INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG
OUR BAY SHORE TO PROTECT OUR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE OUR
AIRPORTS OUR WATER TREATMENT
PLANTS ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FROM FLOOD EVENTS ON
FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
INDIVIDUALLY NONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES COULD DO THAT BUT
COLLECTIVELY THEY CAN AND THE
SAME IS TRUE FOR THE HOUSING
CRISIS -- THE HOBBIT THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING AND AGAIN WE'RE
BUSINESS GROUP AND IN A
SUPPORTING NEW REVENUES IN NEW
TAXES IS A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
OUR MEMBER SOMETIMES.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT SOMETIMES
YOU KNOW THERE NEEDS TO BE A
PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT.
GOING TO SOLVE THEM -- BY
THEMSELVES SO WE'RE SUPPORTING
THIS WE SEE THIS IS AN ENTITY
THAT CAN REALLY BE A MAJOR
PLAYER A NEW TOOL IN OUR BOX WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE THE TOOL TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
THIS IS ONE THAT WILL HELP US
GET US THERE SO WE'RE URGING AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS A CO SPONSOR AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI FOR MANY OF WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY SILICON
VALLEY SPACE.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
NICK JUST SEPARATES MTC
COMMISSIONER HERE MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A SEVENTY AYE WITH WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA AND SILICON
VALLEY RISING REPRESENTING ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE UNIONS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LUIS MONTERO CALIFORNIA ME IN
SUPPORT.
NICCOLO DELAY OKAY HERE WE HAVE
TWO MAYORS OF MERELY BE SHAFT
BERKELEY NEAR JESSE AIR GAME
WE'RE SUPPORT OF AMENDED STAFF
HAS BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH WERE
GETTING REALLY CLOSE TO BEING
SUPPORT.
SO THAT'S OUR GOAL SO THANK YOU.
ALEX GIVES HIM WE HAVE THE CITY
OF LAFAYETTE NO FORMAL POSITION
BUT WHERE CURRENTLY WORKING ON
IT AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND HIS STAFF THE AGREEMENT.
TYRONE BUCKLEY HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MANSON MáS WANNA TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
MAYORS OF THE CITIES OF SOLANO
COUNTY -- WHILE OF THE S. TA
DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION NOW WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR --
GUARANTEE REPRESENTS
REPRESENTATION FRENCH COUNTY AS
WELL AS AS ALSO A HIGH RATE OF
RETURN -- FOR RETURNS SOURCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
I GUESS THIS IS A GOOD JUST
UNDER THERE OKAY.
US DO WALK ABOUT THE ON THE TWO
COUNTRIES DISH COMMISSION THEY
HAVE A AS OPPOSED TO SOME IN A
POSITION ON THE BILL -- THE
MAMMOTH THAT WAS TAKEN I THINK
THAT'S WHAT GOES A LONG WAYS
TOWARDS THAT RETURN THE
GOVERNMENTS OF THIS NEW ENTITY.
RESTORE COUPLE ORAL ISSUES
RELATED TO DISCUSS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE -- BUT THAT WE
THEY FEEL PRETTY STRONGLY ABOUT
TO TO TAKE IN OPPOSE US IN A
POSITION -- BUT I THINK OVERALL
THEY THEY DO AGREE WITH THE GOAL
AND THE NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM
BUT BUT THERE'S SOME ISSUES I'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THANKS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
OKAY -- ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST A
QUICK QUESTION ON ON IN THIS.
YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD.
IN OUT IN THE AREA SNOW COUNTY
PARTICULAR -- THERE'S TROUBLE
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND TRAVEL ISSUES THAT ARE THERE
ALSO IS THERE ANY POTENTIAL FOR
USING THIS MECHANISM -- TO
SUPPORT SOME HOUSING FOR THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY OUT THERE.
TO ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW THE IDEAS
WE AS I MENTIONED BEFORE WE'RE%
TWO AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR SHORT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THE BAY AREA REGION.
AND WE KNOW THAT AND WE'RE
ALWAYS FIGHTING AS A REGION FOR
OUR PORTION OF STATE FUNDS.
BUT AS YOU KNOW THAT'S
COMPETITIVE WITH THE STATE FUNDS
THAT COULD GO TO SAN BENITO
COUNTY OR MONTEREY COUNTY OR LA
OR ANY THE JURISDICTIONS
REPRESENTED BY ANY OF US AND SO
OUR IDEA.
IS TO CREATE A BODY. TO TO
ENGAGE IN SELF HELP TO RAISE
REVENUES SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THE ISSUES WITHIN OUR BOUNDARIES
AND CERTAINLY -- TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE THAT SO
VERY OPEN -- TO TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
EVERYONE INCLUDING OUR TRIBAL.
NEIGHBORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT COMMITMENT WITH THAT'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OF RE AND ENTERTAIN A MOTION SO
CENTER WE HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
AND SECOND.
OKAY WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST%
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO HAS
COME TOGETHER AROUND THIS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE -- THE CHAIRS
ANALYSIS AND YOUR SUPPORT -- AND
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATION SO THAT WE CAN
HOPEFULLY GET EVERYBODY ON THIS
AS WE MOVE IT.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING US FOR THE ANALYSIS
HIGHLIGHTED SEVERAL ISSUES THAT
NEED SOME WORK.
REFINE THE FINANCIAL TOOLS PIECE
IN THINKING THROUGH THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW GREATER BY AND
FROM AFFECTED CITIES AND
COUNTIES I'M RECOMMENDING THAT
YOU STRIP BUT WHAT YOU HAVE
AGREED TO STRIP OUT THE CURRENT
GOVERNANCE LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL.
AND COME BACK TO US WITH A
REVISED FOR FULL PROPOSAL ONCE
YOU'VE HAD THE NECESSARY
STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK.
AND FIND A PATH FORWARD.
I TALKED TO NUMEROUS OF MY MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE IN THE
THREE COUNTIES.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PIECE WAS%
JUST SOMETHING THEY WERE HAVING
A REALLY DIFFICULT TIME WITH.
BUT THERE ARE -- POSITIVE IN
HELPING MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
OKAY SO I THINK YOU CAN HELP
WORK THAT -- WHETHER THEY WANT
TO HAVE A WHOLE NEW GOVERNANCE
ENTITY OR HOW TO ENSURE THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE A SEAT
AT THE TABLE OR WHETHER TO ASK
THEM TO SEE OR A BAG. TO TAKE ON
THIS NEW ROLE.
THANKS FOR AGREEING TO TAKE THE
MEN ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH BOTH OF
THE GOVERNANCE OF FINANCING
ISSUES AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE PROGRESS YOU MAKE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I THANK
YOU FOR CALLING YOU TODAY.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BATH.
RAMOS RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT SIDE VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE THANK YOU -- SO DO
WANT TO MOVE. TO SEVENTEEN SIXTY
THREE I'M HAPPY TO ALTHOUGH I
KNOW THAT MR KARAS BEEN WAITING
VERY PATIENTLY SO IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO JUMP AND I STILL HAVE
TWO MORE BILLS OR I COULD DO
THIS BILL WE COULD WAIT FOR MR
SIGN [inaudible]
WHENEVER.
THIS SHOULD BE QUICK AND THEN.
WHEN YOU GO?
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO JUMP
AROUND HERE EVERYBODY WE JUST
WANT TO STIR UP THE AFTERNOON.
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. NINE FORTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
WELCOME THANK YOU THINK ABOUT
I'M SURE MEMBERS THANK YOU
CENTER VIRTUE -- FOR ALLOWING ME
TO JUMP AHEAD -- I'M REALLY
REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED SOME LEGAL
NINE FORTY EIGHT WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE COYOTE VALLEY
CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
AND BEFORE I GONNA WOULD LIKE IT
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
UP. TO EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT
FOR MANY OF THE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY THIS MIGHT BE THE FIRST
TIME YOU'RE HEARING ABOUT KILEY
VALLEY AND I'M PROUD TO BE ABLE
TO BRING THIS MEASURE FOR TODAY.
AND TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THESE
LANDS ARE THERE TRULY CLOSE TO
MY HEART.
GROWING UP IN SAN JOSE I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING PART OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY THERE'S ALWAYS
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
KILEY VALIANT SPEIDEL AND
PROVIDING A ROLE IN THE GREATER.
SOUTH BAY AREA REGION REGION.
HOW DO VALLEY IS NESTLED BETWEEN
THE FAST GROWING URBAN CORE OF
SAN JOSE AND MORGAN HILL AND IS
AN INVALUABLE NATURAL AN
AGRICULTURAL LANDSCAPE THE
PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL?
CORD OR FOR WILDLIFE WE BETWEEN
THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS IN THE
DIABLO RANGE.
HOW DO VALLEY'S NOT ALL YOU NEED
TREASURER AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
IT'S FLOOD PLAINS WETLANDS AN
AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE ALSO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
REGION'S?
RESILIENCE ENHANCING THE ABILITY
OF OUR NATURAL AND URBAN
COMMUNITIES RESPOND AND ADAPT TO
INCREASING DROUGHTS FIRES AND
FLOODS.
BROUGHT ON BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE LEGISLATION THAT I'VE BEEN
INTRODUCED AB NINE FORTY EIGHT
WILL CREATE THE KILEY VALLEY
CONSERVATION PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
OF COVERING MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES. FOR REALIZING
RESTORATION PRESERVATION AND
RECREATION PROJECTS AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD DOES NAY
KILEY VALLEY IS A RESOURCE OF
STATEWIDE SIGNIFICANCE.
CALIFORNIA'S CREATED PROGRAMS
DESIGNED TO PRESERVE AND RESTORE
CERTAIN RESOURCES OF THIS OF THE
STATE.
SUCH AS THE SANTA ANA RIVER AND
LOWER AMERICAN RIVER AND
RECOGNIZE THESE RESOURCES BEING
OF STATEWIDE SIGNIFICANCE.
THE NEED TO PROTECT KILEY VALUE
FROM DEVELOPMENT PRESSURES IS
GAINING MORE RECOGNITION BY THE
STATE.
BUT NO PROGRAM EXISTS OF FOLKS
AS LOCAL AND STATE EFFORTS TO
PRESERVE AND RESTORE A TIDY
VALUE.
I BOUGHT TO PROTECT THESE LANDS
WHILE AS ON THE SAN JOSE CITY
COUNCIL BOB HEIDI'S LIFE IT WAS
STILL.
VERY MUCH UNCERTAIN AND I'M HERE
TODAY ASKING MY COLLEAGUES TO
STAND WITH SO MANY OF US TO HELP
PRESERVE THIS LAST BASTION OF
OPEN SPACE WITHIN SAN JOSE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
BROAD SUPPORT CONSTITUENTS MY
DISTRICT IN ACROSS.
THE BAY AREA THAT ALSO ENJOYS
THE ENDORSEMENT OF VARIOUS
STATEWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION OF WILDLIFE
PROTECTION GROUPS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY EIGHT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BY THE
TESTIMONY BY MARK LANDGRAF WAS
HERE ABOUT HOW FAR BILL'S
SPONSOR.
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACE WITH ALREADY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK LANDGRAF WITH THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE
THORNY SPONSORS OF A. B..
NINE FORTY EIGHT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS POLICIES GOALS
AND PROGRAMS TO PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
TO PROTECT AND MANAGE NATURAL
WORKING LANDS TO MEET GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS
PROTECT WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
PROMOTE THE ROLE OF NATURAL
WORKING LANDS IN PROVIDING.
MANY OTHER CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND CLIMATE ADAPTATION BENEFITS
KILEY VALLEY CHECKS EVERY BOX OF
THESE POLICIES AND GOALS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY INVESTED IN PLANNING AND
PROTECTION OF PRIORITY HABITAT
IN AND AROUND KILEY VALLEY.
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL'S
SUSTAINABLE AG LANDS
CONSERVATION PROGRAM FUNDED AND
AG PRESERVATION PLAN THAT
INCLUDES THE PROPOSED KILEY
VALLEY PROGRAM AREA.
AND THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY IN
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
HAVE ALSO CONTRIBUTED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING TO
PROTECTION IN THE REGION.
NOW WE NEED ACTION TO PROTECT
THE LANDS AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF
DEVELOPMENT AND NEED THE STATE'S
ASSISTANCE AND FUNDING OF
PROJECTS WE BELIEVE AB NINE
FORTY EIGHT CAN HELP ACHIEVE
THAT AND THE AUTHORITY WORKS
WITH MANY LOCAL PARTNERS AND HAS
GOOD RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LAWMAKERS AND AGENCIES AT THE
STATE.
HAVING THIS PROGRAM AND THAT THE
AUTHORITY KEEPS THE IMPLEMENTOR
LOCAL BUT FURTHER INVOLVES THE
STATE AND PROTECTING THIS
RESOURCE.
LOCAL SERB SOURCES OF FINDING
SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT COULD
SERVE TO MATCH FUTURE STATE
FUNDING FOR LAND PROTECTION IN
KILEY VALLEY AND THE SERVE AS A
MODEL THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTICIPATION.
WITH STATE SUPPORT THE AUTHORITY
THANKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
HIS EFFORTS AND LEADERSHIP OVER
MANY YEARS AND SUPPORTING
EFFORTS TO PROTECT KILEY VALLEY
AND FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP OF AB.
NINE FORTY EIGHT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO.
LIKE A WHOLE ROOM WITH EVELYN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FRIENDSTER MAKER HERE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
WE STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BRENNAN DAWSON WE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
AND FEDERAL AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YES HELLO GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
WELL TELL ME ON A WITHOUT ON
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT --
MICHAEL RYDER GONNA BE UP THE
BOARD SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
OUR BRAND MEDINA AND WE HAVE A
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
YOU SAID THEN SOME RUCKUS MAYBE
EVEN COME TO THE DOOR I HOPE I
HOPE NOT AFTER I SAID THAT.
OKAY THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
COMMENTS -- ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
OUR MOTION AND A SECOND.
IT'S A TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU OF A MADAME CHEN I DO
SO I I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T MENTION IS A MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS -- THIS KILEY
VALLEY IS ACTUALLY IN HIS
DISTRICT ALTHOUGH IT IS IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND HE'S BEEN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
PROTECTION OF COYOTE VALLEY.
AND WILL BE JOINING US SOON AS A
CO AUTHOR ALONG WITH OTHER LOCAL
SENATORS AND AND I SAID ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES ON A THANK SUMMER
WITH US.
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
YOU YOUR SPOUSE WORK ON THIS
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
QUITE FRANKLY I DO NOR COYOTE
VALLEY.
AND IT IS A BEAUTIFUL SPOT AND I
REALLY WANT TO SEE PRESERVE
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH GROWTH
GOING ON IN YOUR AREA BUT IT HAS
BEEN -- A GREAT PLACE FOR AS
LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER WHEN THEY
PASSED THROUGH ON ONE US HIGHWAY
ONE OH ONE OR WHATEVER THAT.
IS AS KIDS BUT ANYWAY -- SO I'M
HAPPY THE YOU GET ENSURE THAT
THE COYOTE VALLEY RECEIVES THE
TENSION CONSERVATION EFFORTS TO
DESERVES ALL BE ACCEPTING YOUR
YOUR THANK YOU FOR THE EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
RAMOS RAMOS SIGN THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVERSIDE
VOEPEL [inaudible]
HI.
WE STILL NAY WERE MORE OF A
THANK YOU.
MAYBE THEY JUST WALKED IN THE
DOOR [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY I'LL TO THIS ONE AND THEN
WAIT FOR ME.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO WITH --
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND AGAIN APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
YOUR COMMITTEE WITH REGARDS
DEVELOPMENT.
AN EXISTING ZONING DENSITY IN
HEIGHT ARE OFTEN TOO LOW FOR
AFFORDABLE PROJECTS TO PENCIL
OUT.
SECONDLY FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS VERY SCARCE AND WE
NEED TO STRETCH EVERY DOLLAR.
THIRD FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS TO HAVE A SHOT AT
COMPETING WITH MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS MORE DENSITY CAN MAKE
A PROJECT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE.
AND GIVE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER THE SHOT THAT
COMPETING FOR SITE.
UNDER THIS BILL A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR AN 80%
DENSITY BONUS ABOVE EXISTING
ZONING DENSITY.
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES
AND CONCESSIONS GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND EQUITY
BENEFITS FOR LOCATING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOUR TRANSIT.
A 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS NEAR TRANSIT WOULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR AN UNLIMITED
DENSITY BONUS PLUS AN INCREASE
IN HEIGHT WAR FLOOR AREA RATIO
IS UP TO A LIMIT.
AT THIS POINT I'D LIKE TO TURN
OVER TOWARD BILL SPONSORED
MARINO WHITE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS RAN
AWAY WITH THIS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM I'M REALLY
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR FOR
THE CARRYING THIS BILL.
ON BEHALF OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS I REPRESENT --
I WON'T SPEAK VERY LONG BUT I'M
JUST WANTED TO ADD ON AS YOU
KNOW IT'S VERY COMPLICATED -- TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY MANY REASONS
AND WHILE THIS BILL DOES SORT OF
CREATED ENHANCE DENSITY BONUS
FOR FORMAL HOUSING PROJECTS
THERE MANY OTHER CONSTRAINTS
THAT THAT STILL WILL BE A
APPLYING ON THESE PROJECTS.
AND THIS JUST TAKES AWAY ONE OF
THAT SORT OF CRITERIA -- THAT
ALLOWS THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD UNDER ALL
THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS -- AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE MANY
COST IN DEVELOPMENT ARE FIXED
AND THE MORE INTENSELY WE CAN
UTILIZE LAND -- BUT STILL
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS -- THE
MORE EFFECTIVE WE CAN BE AND SO
ARE YOUR AYE VOTE THAT TODAY
THINK YOU.
THINK.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
THE REFORMS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE BILL ARE ACTUALLY A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING I'M ON
AROUND IN SAN DIEGO SO WHAT CAN
BE DONE -- BUT PART OF THE
REASON WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING IS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR SISTER CITIES ALSO STEP
UP AND DO THE RIGHT THING SO WE
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU.
I KNOW OUR WITH THE WESTERN TIME
ON POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
TERM BUCKLEY A HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPORT.
HI FOR ME I'M HAVE A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRIAN AUGUSTA -- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT WE HAVE
NOT YET SUBMITTED OUR LETTER BUT
WILL BE GETTING THAT IN SHORTLY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP HIM AWAKE --
INTO MOTION.
OKAY MISTER BLOOM MISTER.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE MADAM CHAIR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU -- I AGREE WITH
PROVIDING GREATER INCENTIVES TO
DEVELOPERS ON HOW 2% AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS WELL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I DO THINK THERE'S A
HAPPY MEDIUM HERE.
THAT YOU NEED TO REACH IN TERMS
OF HOW FAR TO INCENTIVIZE I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON THE ISSUE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
COMPROMISE.
THE YOU MIGHT COME UP WITH
APPRECIATE OF ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE ON THIS AND SHE BY
COMMITTEE WITH.
HAPPENED TO SO -- WITH THAT.
US SECRETARY ROLE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY MY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM I BURGER **** BATH RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I MEASURES UP -- FIVE
ZERO I THINK WE'LL GO AHEAD MR
BLOOM THING SHE WAS DO WONDER.
SOME MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
AHEAD
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THINK I MAY HAVE JUST
LOST ONE VOTE ON THE FLOOR --
FOR THE SPELL BUT REMEMBERING
LAND USE BARRIERS TO EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE DEVELOPMENT AND
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS OF THE STATE --
PLACES WITH GOOD SCHOOLS JOBS AT
AT AT CENTER IS AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND INCREASING CHOICE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
MANY OF THE PLACES WITH THE MOST
EXISTING RESOURCES AND AMENITIES
REMAIN AND ACCESSIBLE TO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
THE LACK OF DANCE MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING IS ONE OF THE MANY
BARRIERS THAT IMPEDE ACCESS HI
RESOURCE AREAS MAY OR MAY NOT BE
NEAR EXISTING HIGH QUALITY
TRANSIT BUT THEY CAN SUPPORT.
GREEN INFILL DEVELOPMENT WHICH
IS CRUCIAL TO SUPPORTING FUTURE
TRANSIT EXPANSION.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
NEEDS AND REDUCING AUTO
DEPENDENCE WE NEED TO INCREASE
DENSITY AND EXPAND INFILL
DEVELOPMENT.
IN MORE PARTS OF OUR STATE.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY NINE WOULD USE
DATA AND MAPPING TO IDENTIFY
HIGH RESOURCE AREAS WERE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS PREDOMINANTLY LOW
DENSITY AND SCREEN OUT PLACES
THAT ARE AT HIGH RISK FOR
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT.
THE REMAINING AREAS AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE STRONG INDICATORS OF
EXCLUSIONARY LAND USE PATTERNS
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO ZONING OVER
RIGHTS TO ENCOURAGE THE
PRODUCTION.
OF DANCE SMALL SCALE MARKET RATE
HOUSING AND LARGER SCALE MIXED
INCOME AND AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING.
WE NEED TO BUILD MORE HOUSING --
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY CITIES DOING THEIR
FAIR SHARE TO PROVIDE A RANGE OF
HOUSING TYPES.
AT A RANGE OF INCOME LEVELS EVEN
PLACES THAT TRADITIONALLY HAVE
FROWNED UPON DENSITY.
THANK YOU AND TO HAVE FUN ON A
LAWLER AND BRIGHT ACOSTA WITH
HERE TO TESTIFY.
WELCOME GOOD EVENING.
SORRY -- IDEAL WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
THERE ARE.
A LOT OF THE CONVERSATION A
COUPLE OF YOUR HUSBAND AROUND
INCREASING DENSITY OF
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT ROUND
TRANSIT WHICH IS CRITICAL BUT
THERE ARE MANY MANY COMMUNITIES
IN THE STATE THAT DON'T HAVE
TRANSIT.
AND HAVE HI -- NUMBERS OF LOW
WAGE WORKERS WHO HAVE NO
OPPORTUNITY LIVE IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD DENSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THOSE
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL WOULD FIX
THAT PROBLEM -- WE THINK IT'S
GOOD BILL AND WE WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT ACOSTA -- ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR THE BILL IN THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE
HAVING ON HOUSING THIS YEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE THIS BILL AS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT WHICH IS.
HOW DO WE CREATE MORE
OPPORTUNITY PARTICULARLY FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN AREAS OF HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AND HOW DO WE
PRODUCE MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES?
THIS BILL HELPS TO ACHIEVE THAT
AND WE WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYRONE BUCKLEY
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALSO ON SPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING ONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE NEED A MOTION THE BILL.
I'LL SECOND IT.
I GOT THE SECOND.
TO GET.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THIS BILL -- I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCEPT BUT HOPE YOU WORK TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
PEOPLE THAT ARE CONSERVANCY
SECOND URBAN COUNTIES HAS COME
TO MY OFFICE.
ON TIGHTER DEFINITIONS IN THE
BILL RE REFINED THE APPEALS
PROCESS WILL BE VOTING FOR THE
BILL TODAY.
AND HOPE TO SEE IT ON THE FLOOR
SOONER THAN LATER OFF CLEAN UP --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY I
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER OF THAT
RAMOS RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS FIVE
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WELL NO.
NEWS WILL NEVER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOME MEMBER
REAVIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO NEXT.
YEAH [inaudible]
NUMBER.
SIX HEY RUN ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- COLLEAGUES OUT
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
LEGISLATION THAT CREATES AN OPT
IN TOOL. TO HELP ADDRESS OUR
FARM WORKER HOUSING SHORTAGE HI
FIRST LIKE TO THANK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE ANALYSIS I AM HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE PROPOSED TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT THAT WAS IN THAT
ANALYSIS SO THANK YOU -- ALSO
SPECIAL THEY GET MY COLLEAGUES
ARE CO AUTHORING THIS
LEGISLATION ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
CHIU.
FROM GEM CISCO SENATORS ON A
COPY AT ALL MY THE ISLAND I
DORADO AND SCOTT WIENER.
I AND I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY
THAT WE ARE ALL WELL AWARE.
THAT CALIFORNIA IS FACING A
SEVERE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
AND THE SHORTAGE IS IT JUST AN
URBAN PROBLEM MANY AGRICULTURAL
AREAS IN THE STATE ALSO FACE A
HOUSING CRISIS.
IN RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY ONE IN
TEN STUDENTS.
AS HOMELESS.
IN FACT WE HAVE TWELVE SCHOOLS
WERE ONE IN FIVE STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS.
AND THEN THERE SURE WOULD
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN SALINAS.
WHERE 40% 40% OF THE STUDENTS AT
THAT SCHOOL HOMELESS?
WE HAVE FAMILIES LIVING FOURTEEN
PEOPLE TO AN APARTMENT.
AND OTHERS ARE SLEEPING IN CARS
OR UNDER FREEWAY OVERPASSES.
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE
HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY TOUGH ON
OUR FARMWORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY.
THEM WITH OUR FAMILY FARMERS.
THEY WORK TO BRING THE FRESHEST
PRODUCE TO MARKET.
AND CERTAINLY DO THEIR PART IN
HELPING FEED THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THEY WORK HARD EVERY SINGLE DAY.
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THE HOPE
THAT ONE DAY THEIR CHILDREN.
WILL BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO BUY A HOME.
HAVE DECENT HEALTH CARE.
AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
LIVE THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
YET THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE AND DECENT PLACES FOR
THEM TO LIVE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE ALL ALL OF
US IN THIS ROOM AND IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE GREAT
TO OPT IN STREAMLINED PROCESS TO
BUILD FORMER HOUSING ON
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
IT SETS QUALITY STANDARDS TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEW HOUSING IS
DIGNIFIED [inaudible]
FAMILY FRIENDLY.
AND PUT SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
LOOK THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET
AS WE'VE SEEN IN THIS HEARING
HERE TODAY. TO SOLVE THIS
HOUSING CRISIS.
BUT AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS
A SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD.
ESSENTIALLY THIS BILL CREATE A
TOOL KIT.
IT CREATES A TOOL FOR OUR
FARMERS TO USE IF THEY CHOOSE TO
USE IT.
IF THEY WOULD RATHER NOT UTILIZE
IT.
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO SEEK
PERMITTING THE BILL HOUSING JUST
AS THEY WOULD RIGHT NOW.
I'VE SPOKEN TO LOCAL FARMERS
LOCAL FARMERS WHO HAVE THANK ME
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY WOULD UTILIZE THIS
TOOL THIS OPTION.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE COME
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
BECAUSE IT IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY FARM BUREAU
HAS ALSO COME OUT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I AM NEW TO
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
AND IS ONE OF THE NEWS
COLLEAGUES I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO KNOW THAT I
CAN SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE.
I CAN SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF FARM WORKER HOUSING.
FROM FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE.
DID YOU SEE MY GRANDFATHER WAS A
FORMER GREAT ALMADEN VINEYARDS
AND PISCINE THIS CALIFORNIA.
HE WITH MY GRANDMOTHER MY MOM
WHO IS A SINGLE PARENT.
THEY RAISED MY BROTHER AND I I
GREW UP IN FORMER HOUSING.
I LIVED WITH TEN MEMBERS OF MY
FAMILY.
OUR HOUSING COMPLEXES LOCATED
RIGHT BESIDE THE VINEYARD WHEN
MY GRANDFATHER WORKED EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
OUR HOUSING WAS VERY VERY BASIC.
BUT IT WAS A DECENT.
IN OUR SMALL TWO ROOM HOME IT
GAVE OUR FAMILY THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR A BETTER LIFE.
A FARM WORKER HOUSING.
FARM WORKER HOUSING ALLOWED MY
FAMILY THE CHANCE TO GET OUT OF
THE FIELDS AND INTO THE
CLASSROOM.
BUT MANY FARMWORKERS THEN AND
NOW.
ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL
MAKE A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO WORK THE
FEELS LIKE MY GRANDFATHER DID.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
CURRENT GENERATION OF
FARMWORKERS.
THAT THEIR CHILDREN.
ALSO HAVE THE CHANCE AT A BETTER
LIFE AND A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MADAM
CHAIR I'M JOINED HERE TODAY BY A
BILL SPONSOR AND OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I'LL ASK
THEM TO DO THIS THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS A
BIT OF AN ON THIS AND I AM THE
CIVIC PARTICIPATION POLICY
COORDINATOR WITH THE UFW
FOUNDATION. TOO MANY CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS SUFFER HORRIBLE AND
INADEQUATE HOUSING.
I CONDITIONS BUILT ON FARM
WORKER HOUSING SYSTEM CREATED IN
THE BEGINNING OF THE LAST
CENTURY.
LABOR CAMPS DID NOT HAVE.
A TENDENCY PROTECTIONS LABOR
CAMPS DID NOT HAVE TITLE TWENTY
FOUR REGULATIONS.
THEY DO NOT HAVE RENT STABILITY.
LABOR CAMPS WERE COLD.
DAMP AND INDECENT.
AND THEY WERE CONTROLLED BY
EMPLOYERS.
TODAY.
FARMWORKERS LIVE.
IN GARAGES.
INDIRECT STYLE.
HOUSING TRAILERS WITH NO AIR
CONDITIONING THAT MAKE SUMMER
LIVING [inaudible]
BRUTAL.
IF I MAY SHARE WHAT A FARM
WORKER.
WHAT FARMWORKERS THEMSELVES ARE
SAYING?
APPELLEE NOT CRUISE A WINE GRAPE
WORKER IN THE SANTA ROSA REGION
SAYS QUOTE RENT FOR AN APARTMENT.
OR STUDIO IS TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THE PLACE.
FOR ME SAYS THAT'S TOO MUCH
MONEY.
EFRAIN GARCIA.
WHO IS NOW HOMELESS AFTER THIRTY
NINE YEARS WORKING IN THE FIELD
SAYS QUOTE? TO WARM UP MY FOOD.
I'M ALWAYS BOTHERING MY FRIENDS.
ASKING TO PLEASE ALLOW ME TO
MAKE MYSELF A TACKLE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS'S
FARM WORKER HOUSING ACT PROPOSES
TO SIMPLE SOLUTIONS.
AND POWER GOOD ACTORS TO BUILD
FARM WORKER HOUSING.
AND DO IT SO QUICKLY.
AND ALSO PREVENT STATE MONEY OR
BENEFITS FROM SUPPORTING A
FLAWED FEDERAL PROGRAM.
OR CONDITIONS THAT HINDER A
FARMWORKERS FREEDOM.
AND ABILITY TO LIVE FREE OF
CONTROL.
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME WHAT.
GOT YOU CHAIR -- MEMBERS --
CHRIS PUT YOUR THOMAS LAW GROUP
I'LL BE BRIEF AND SAY THAT THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY BILL AND WE'RE
HERE TO ANSWERING TACKLE
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LAURIE
JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SALINAS AND SUPPORT.
PRIOR TO GUEST WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ON THE OTHER WITH THE WESTERN
THURMOND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
LUIS MONTERO A CALIFORNIA BID
SUPPORT.
NICOLAS DOLLARS ON BEHALF UNITED
FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARK LANDGRAF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE OF FORTY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN OF FEDERAL
ON THOUGH PRESIDENT PARTY
STRATEGIES -- FIVE MAIN NORMALLY
SEEN HERE ON BEHALF OF
CONSERVATION ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS HERE TODAY ON MY OWN
ACCORD -- I'M ONE OF THOSE KIDS
THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO GET THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AS A RESULT OF
REALLY GOOD FORMER HOUSING A
GROUP OF FORMER HOUSING FOR MY
BIRTH UNTIL I TURNED EIGHTEEN
AND THEN WENT TO COLLEGE.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL
CAN'T BE OVERSTATED SO
DEFINITELY -- IN GREATER SUPPORT --
AND YEAH IF.
I I JUST WANT TO MENTION TO THAT
AND THAT ULTIMATELY THE ABILITY
TO HAVE THIS KIND OF HOUSING.
IS IS WHAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO COME
OUT OF POVERTY BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TO ADDRESS THESE
FAMILY ISSUES AT HOME -- AND
YOU'RE HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY WHERE YOU GET THE
NEXT MEAL BUT THE HAVING A ROOF
OVER YOUR OVER YOUR HEAD.
IT MAKES IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU YEAH IT JUST MAKES IT
REALLY IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO EVEN PAY ATTENTION.
SO.
I WAS LUCKY I GREW UP IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WHO WERE WHERE WE
HAD A REALLY GREAT PROGRAM.
THAT ALLOWED MY FAMILY.
TO GIVE ME THE UP [inaudible]
GOD.
RED DIRT FROM SANTA CRUZ
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I SUPPORT.
OKAY WE HAVE A WITNESS THE
OPPOSITION WILL GO.
YEAH ONE OF OPPOSITION QUEMADA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
MATTHEW ON REPRESENT RUSTING
GORGEOUS ASSOCIATION THIS
AFTERNOON -- WESTERN GROWS AS AN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL --
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED OPPORTUNITIES WE'VE
HAD TO DISCUSS FORMER HOUSING --
AND THE BILL WITH THE OTHER TO
STAFF WE STE WITH FIND OURSELVES
IN THE SAME COMMISSION THAT WAS
THE POSITION OF THE STARTED AND
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO ENGAGING
IN THESE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE A
LACK OF AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE
STATE HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS
HAS LONG BEEN A PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER THE MINISTERIAL
PERMITTING PROCESS AS DELINEATED
IN THIS BILL CURRENTLY WOULD NOT
BE AVAILABLE UNLESS THE FARMER
TURNS OPERATION OTHER HOUSING
OVER TO A THIRD PARTY.
OUT FEW FARMERS WOULD BE WILLING
TO DO THIS AS THEY WOULD REMAIN
ULTIMATELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HOUSING AND ANY LIABILITY CLAIMS
ASSOCIATED WITH ITS OPERATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
INSTEAD COMMITTED TO FINDING AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT DOES NOT
DISCOURAGE OUR FARMERS FROM
DEPLOYING THEIR CAPITAL AND
THEIR LAND TO MEET THIS URGENT
NEED.
WE ARE ALSO VERY CONCERNED AT
THE SAME TIME ABOUT LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
STATE FUNDING FOR THE PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND OPERATION OF
HOUSING.
THAT WOULD BE UTILIZED FOR H. TO
A EMPLOYEES.
THE REALITY IS THAT FARMERS HERE
AND ELSEWHERE IN UNITED STATES
ARE TURNING TO THE H. CHOI
PROGRAM IN DESPERATION DUE TO
THE ONGOING LABOR SHORTAGE THAT
WE HAVE AN AD.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH -- THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE LEGISLATURE
BUT AS FAR HOUSING IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
WE JUST BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT THIS FROM A
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TO LEVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM HERE WHERE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO THIS BILL I WE DO
APPLY THE AUTHORS INTEREST IN
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FORMER HOUSING WE
SHARE THAT GOAL -- UNFORTUNATELY
JUST AS MY COLLEAGUE HAD
MENTIONED WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
THAT THE EXEMPTION IS PROVIDED
AS IS SO LIMITED IN ADDITION TO
HAVING A QUALIFIED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATION OPERATES --
WITH NO LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
THERE'S ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CITING.
SO UNDER THE BILL YOU COULD NOT
CITE ANY OF THIS HOUSING ON
LINKEDIN ACT PLANS WHICH IS
SIXTEEN MILLION OF THE THIRTY
MILLION FARM AND RANCH LANDS IN
CALIFORNIA -- YOU ALSO CAN'T
CITED IN THE COASTAL ZONE.
ACOSTA PROGRAMS ARE PREDICATED
ON STATE AND LOCAL APPROVAL OF
HAVING FARM WORKER HOUSING AS A
MANDATORY PORTION OR VERY
IMPORTANT PORTION OF OUR COASTAL
AGRICULTURAL AREAS ESPECIALLY
WHERE.
HOUSING COSTS ARE TREMENDOUS
JUST AS THE COMMENTARY WAS A
NAPA.
I'M BEYOND THAT I THINK WE HAVE
SOME.
BROADER CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
TRYING TEN HOUSING RIGHTS TO
EMPLOYEE HOUSING RATES -- NOW
THIS WOULD BE INCONSISTENT WITH
HOW WE ACT FOR ANY OTHER
EMPLOYEE WHERE PROVIDED WE'RE
HOUSING AS A CONDITION OF THEIR
EMPLOYMENT.
I'M IT WOULD ONLY BE FOR THESE
AGRICULTURAL PLAYS REGARDLESS I
THINK WE ALL AGREE THAT WE WANT
OUR EMPLOYEES TO FEEL.
COMFORTABLE AND THE HOUSING
OPERATION THAT THEY FEEL IS
AFFORDABLE AND IS SAFE -- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
WELL IN THE END I THINK IT
PRACTICALLY WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
EXISTING EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS
COVER DISCRIMINATIONS
PROTECTIONS AND SOME OF THOSE
TEN OBLIGATIONS THAT ARE THERE
FOR AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEES ARE
READY SO WE DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH
THOSE CONDITIONS ARE NECESSARY
AND THEN I THINK.
PRACTICALLY TIME TEN HOUSING
RIGHT SIMPLY HOUSING RATES JUST
TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING TEN
HOUSING RATES LAW.
YOU HAVE A THIRTY DAYS NOTICE TO
EFFECT -- IF YOU ARE AN EMPLOYEE
AND YOU'RE FIRED FOR CAUSE IN AN
IN HOUSING SITUATION.
THAT EMPLOYEE WITH AND HAVE THE
RIGHT TO RESIDE WITHIN THAT
HOUSING FOR THIRTY DAYS -- SO
WHILE THEY'RE PROVIDED THAT
NOTICE TO MOVE OUT THAT MEANS
THAT.
IF YOU'VE BEEN FIRED FOR CAUSE
AND AT THAT COULD BE INCREDIBLY
DESTRUCTIVE.
I TO THE OPERATION AND IN
ADDITION YOU'RE TAKING AWAY A
POSITION THAT COULD BE FILLED
WITH THE REPLACEMENT EMPLOYEE
WHO'S EQUALLY LOOKING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES --
SO BASED ON THESE CONCERNS WE WE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE'RE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE THREE BEST MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
CUT FLOWER COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSING GARDEN
CENTERS AND AMERICAN PISTACHIO
GROWERS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED BUT
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
IN.
YOUR SCHOOLS AROUND TOO MANY --
SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND NEED A
SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE IT --
DRESSER THE QUESTIONS OR PRODUCT
AGAIN I YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND I REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT I REMAIN -- COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL SIDES AS I'VE --
I'VE DONE SO SINCE THE
BEGINNINGS AS WE INTRODUCE THIS
LEGISLATION -- YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN ABSOLUTELY TRANSPARENT AND
WE WILL -- MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
RESPECTFUL AN HONOR AND AND AND
AND HONEST MANNER -- THIS BILL
AB SEVENTEEN A THREE SIMPLY
CREATES AN OPT IN.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT'S
WHY THIS THIS BILL WOULD PROPOSE
TO CREATE A PROGRAM THAT IS
VOLUNTARY.
AND OPTED IF IT DOESN'T FIT THE
NEEDS OF AGRICULTURE OPERATION
OR FARM THEY DON'T HAVE TO DO IT --
YOU KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY TO TOOL
FOR OUR FARMERS UTILIZED IF.
IF THEY CAN'T -- BUT PLEASE KEEP
IN MIND THAT THIS BILL THIS
ISSUE IS NOT A DEMOCRATIC.
ISSUE IS NOT A REPUBLICAN ISSUE
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN ISSUE --
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO SOMETHING AND TO ACT.
THIS IS YOU KNOW BY NO MEANS AN
EXHAUSTIVE BILL OF WITH THERE'S
A LOT OF THESE IN AGRICULTURE
WORKFORCE HOUSING AND I INTEND
TO BUILD.
A YOU UPON THE FOUNDATION OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS TO SUPPORT
AGRICULTURE -- YOU KNOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT -- ARE FARMWORKERS
CERTAINLY NEED YOUR HELP -- AND
LET'S KEEP -- THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ALIVE FOR THEM AND
CERTAINLY FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
I RESPECT THAT'S WHEN I THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- IF
THERE'S EVER AND THE NEED TO
STREAMLINE.
NO BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T MAKE IT -- AN
OPT IN.
AND YOU MADE IT SO FARMERS COULD
CHOOSE TO USE IT OR NOT.
AND THAT'S A BIG STEP FOR MANY
PEOPLE I THINK WORK REALLY HARD
ON THIS BILL -- IT SHOWS A LOT
OF PROMISE -- I HAVE I KNOW YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION.
AND WITH THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY WITH
IT THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT --
I'D LIKE TO CALL CO AUTHOR AS
WELL.
I'M SORRY WHAT A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL THANK YOU YEAH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D LACKEY VOTING
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HORROR THAT.
RAMOS RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
HELL NO.
THE BILL HAS THREE VOTES FOR
HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE MISSING.
FOR ME DOING WE JUST IN ONE MORE
VOTE OF THAT.
I'M WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE.
BREAK WILL COME BACK ABOUT A
LITTLE. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
SOMETHING LIKE THAT
STARTED --
WE ARE NO.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
WELCOME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHOE IN SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES IN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS.
BILL LET ME FIRST START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE WORK I KNOW THE STAFF IS
DONE AND AND THE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD.
WE ARE IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AND THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT ALLOWING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
CONTROL THEIR OWN FINANCES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS THAT ARE INVESTED IN
WALL STREET BANKS AND THIS IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT IF THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
WANTS TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY FOR CHARTER TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR MONIES AND THEIR SAVINGS
ARE BUSTED AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WITH THEIR LOCAL CONSTITUENTS
THEY HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTION
TO CHARTER A LOCAL PUBLIC BANK
BUT IT DOES NOT ESTABLISH A
PUBLIC BANK IT ONLY CREATES THE
PROCESS TO DO IN IT WHICH IS A
MULTI YEAR PROCESS WITH MANY
HURDLES.
I KNOW WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE ABOUT CONCERNS OF
INSURING THAT PUBLIC BANK ASSETS
ARE SAFEGUARDED.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT MISTER
SANTIAGO AND I'D THAT IS A
CONCERN WE HOLD TO THE HIGHEST
LEVEL.
UNLIKE PRIVATE BANKS THIS BILL
REQUIRES A PUBLIC BANK TO ABIDE
BY A FIDUCIARY DUTY TO PROTECT
ITS ASSETS IT REQUIRES
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL REQUIREMENTS.
OF FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ON
BANKING LAW WITH ALL REPORTING
AND TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE RELATED.
NOW IN ADDITION TO THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENT THE PUBLIC BANKS
KEEP THE SAME COLLATERAL
REQUIREMENTS AS PRIVATE BANKS
THE MINUTES THAT WE'VE ACCEPTED
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE REQUIRED
PUBLIC BANK TO MAINTAIN FDIC
DEPOSIT INSURANCE.
IN ADDITION TO THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENT OF INITIAL BUSINESS
PLAN THIS COMMITTEE HAS ASKED US
TO ACCEPT AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE
HAPPY TO DO TO REQUIRE A LOCAL
AGENCY APPLYING FOR CHARTER TO
ANALYZE COSTS.
CAPITAL REQUIREMENTS FINANCIAL
PROJECTIONS LEGALITY ECCENTRIC.
I KNOW THERE BEEN SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THIS BANK INTERSECTS
WITH LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS LIKE CREDIT UNIONS
AND COMMUNITY BANKS AND LET ME
MAKE IT CLEAR.
COUNTRY TO WHAT HAS BEEN SAID
ABOUT THIS BILL THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES A PUBLIC
BANK WHEREVER POSSIBLE TO
PARTNER WITH LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. TO CONDUCT RETAIL
SERVICES THROUGH THOSE LOCAL
INSTITUTIONS IT'S MODELED AFTER
THE PUBLIC BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA
WHICH FOR A HUNDRED YEARS THIS
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HAS
SUCCESSFULLY PARTNERED WITH
LOCAL BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS
WITH PROFITABLE RETURNS TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE
RESPONSE TO THE MAIN ARGUMENT BY
THE OPPOSITION THAT SUPPORTERS
OF PUBLIC BANKS.
HAVEN'T SHOWN HOW THE CURRENT.
BIG BANKING INDUSTRY HAS NOT MET
THE NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC AND NOT
MET THE NEEDS OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I THINK OF YOUR
**** LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THEY WOULD HAVE AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE AFTERMATH OF CONSUMERS
WHO BEEN VICTIMIZED BY PREDATORY
LENDING.
WHO'VE HAD MILLIONS OF FAKE BANK
ACCOUNTS OPEN IN THEIR NAMES
WHO'VE LOST FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN INTEREST PAYMENTS
AFTER THE GREAT RECESSION.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE AFTERMATH OF HOMEOWNERS
VICTIMIZED BY MORTGAGE
FORECLOSURES STUDENTS VICTIMIZED
BY KRITI LENDERS.
SMALL BUSINESSES DENIED ACCESS
TO CAPITAL.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE HAVING
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF THEIR
DOLLARS INVEST AGAINST THEIR
COMMUNITY VALUES IN FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRIES.
GUN MANUFACTURERS PRIVATE
PRISONS COMPANIES WITH UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICES.
WITH THIS BILL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE CHANCE TO
KEEP TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN
CONTINUE TO SEND THIS TO CERTAIN
OF THE LARGEST WALL STREET BANKS
TO CREATE LOCAL JOBS BILL LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND STABILIZE LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO WITHOUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS A BILL THAT CAME
OUT OF A MOVEMENT THAT WAS BUILT
IN TWELVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SAN DIEGO.
ORANGE COUNTY AND LOS ANGELES
SANTA BARBARA SANTA CRUZ -- SAN
JOSE IN THE SOUTH BAY SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND EAST BAY SANTA
ROSA EUREKA THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE ASKING FOR
THIS.
AND SO WITHOUT I VERY MUCH HOPE
THAT WE CAN MOVE THIS BILLOUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
ASK MY JOINT AUTHOR WHO HAS BEEN
A TRUE PARTNER IN THIS ENDEAVOR --
MISTER SANTIAGO FOR HIS OPENING
STATEMENT -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WOULD ENGAGE ON THIS
CONVERSATION A WE KEEP COMING
BACK BUT WE REALLY WANTED TO DO
THE POINT THAT THIS IS A SERIOUS --
POLICY PROPOSAL AND IMAGINE A
PUBLIC BANK FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD --
AS OPPOSED TO SOME OF THE
CURRENT BIG BANK -- OUR
PRACTICES A SYSTEMS.
AND ILL LET LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PROCESS THAT HAVE BEEN LAID OUT --
THROUGH THE AMENDMENTS AND IT'S
A SERIOUS PROCESS AND YOU KNOW
FOLKS WILL ARE YOU WILL WHAT IF
A BANK.
WHAT IF THE CITY CAN'T DO IT OUR
TAXPAYERS AT RISK SIX CETERA?
THE SERIES PROPOSAL WITH SERIOUS
SAFEGUARDS NUMBER ONE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE FDIC INSURANCE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE WORN IT'S
NOT GOING TO PROVE SOMETHING
THAT IS AND FISCALLY SOLVENT
PERIOD WE KNOW THAT -- THERE'S A
BE A RIGOROUS STUDY IN ADVANCE.
THAT WILL HAVE PLAYED A
FINANCIAL PLAN GOVERNANCE A
PUBLIC BENEFIT -- PURPOSE WILL
BE PUBLIC MEETINGS IT COMPLETELY
TRANSPARENT -- IT'LL HAVE TO GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA PROVE SOMETHIN
IS A FISCALLY SOLVENT LET'S
LET'S PUT THAT ON THE TABLE.
I AND THEY'LL HAVE TO WILL HAVE
TO ABIDE BY FEDERAL LAWS IN ANY
OF THE REGULATIONS.
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANYTHING
DIFFERENT -- THAN ANY OTHER
RECORD BURBANK COMMUNITY -- BANK
OR CREDIT UNION WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE SET UP.
BUT A LOT BEEN SAID -- IT IN ALL
REPEAT SOME IS BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
SAID THAT TAXPAYERS DOLLARS
WOULD BE AT RISK HAVING LAID OUT
THAT RIGOROUS PROCESS -- THAT WE
JUST LAID OUT IF IF THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE THE CASE THEY WOULDN'T
GET A BANK LOCAL MISS KELLY SO
THE CONVERSATION IS MOOT OFF THE
TABLE.
ON IT YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN SAID
THAT -- DIED LOCAL BANKS WILL
STOP INVESTING OUR COMMUNITIES.
I ACTUALLY THINK THEY MIGHT
INVEST A LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE
NOW THERE'S COMPETITION THERE'S
A THERE'S A MOTIVE TO INVEST
MORE -- I THINK COMPETITION IS
ALWAYS HELPED US QUITE FRANKLY I
DON'T SEE IT SITUATION WHERE
HASN'T HELP THE CONSUMER HOUSE
AND HELP THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITY.
YOU CAN ARGUE DIFFERENT BUT I'VE
SEEN IT DIFFERENTLY -- THAT THAT
THERE'S GONNA BE A LOSS OF JOBS --
QUICKLY LOOK AT PUBLIC VANCE'S
JOB CREATORS -- THE ABILITY TO
TO INVEST IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY -- TO TO
USE THOSE DOLLARS AT A LOCAL
LEVEL ARE ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITY I WOULD
ARGUE AS OPPOSED TO TAKING THOSE
DOLLARS AND PUT THEM SOMEWHERE
ELSE IN ANOTHER AREA FOR
INVESTMENT.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S ITS BEEN SAID
TO THAT THE THE CORPORATE BANK
WOULD HAVE A OUR BEST INTERESTS
IN MIND.
SOME MIGHT -- BUT I MIGHT ARGUE
THAT THAT THEIR INTEREST OUR TO
SHAREHOLDERS -- IN AND AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT'S THE PROFIT
MOTIVE THAT WORKS AND THE BOTTOM
LINE THAT'S AT THE CORE OF
INTERESTS -- SO I'D ARGUE THAT
THE REPUBLIC BANK -- IS REALLY
IT IS A SERIOUS POLICY PROPOSAL
AND AND LET'S THINK WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY DOES NOT SAYING
THIS -- YOU'RE SETTING UP A
STATE BANK IT'S NOT SAYING IT'S
MANDATED.
IT'S SAYING THAT IF A LOCAL
MUNICIPALITY WANTS TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS.
IN A GET PASS MUSTER THROUGH ALL
THE THINGS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN SET.
I DON'T WANNA LIST AGAIN BUT
NONE THE LESS.
THEN AND ONLY THEN.
CAN ACTUALLY SET ONE UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ANYONE ELSE FOR THIS WE HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE TO IN ASSISTS SO
LIKE TO TURN.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS DAVID JEDI
IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING ALLIANCE REPRESENTING
TWELVE CITIES AND REGIONS IN THE
STATE FROM SAN DIEGO TO EUREKA
PLUS THE MORE THAN NINETY
COMMUNITY GROUPS WHICH ENDORSE
AND SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS.
I IN WHO SEE THE NEED FOR MORE
AND BETTER OPTIONS FOR PUBLIC
ENTITIES TO BANK THEIR FUNDS
LOCALLY.
AND TO SATISFY THE PUBLIC'S
DESIRE TO DIVEST FROM HARMFUL
AND EXTRACTIVE INDUSTRIES AND
THE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WHICH
ENABLE THEM.
A MONTH AGO THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
WAS FACED WITH A DILEMMA THEY
COULD EITHER WAIVE THEIR WAGE
THEFT PREVENTION POLICY AND
ACCEPT A BID FROM JP MORGAN
CHASE FOR THEIR BANKING SERVICES --
OR THEY COULD REJECT THAT BID
AND ACCEPT THE SECOND BEST BID
FROM WELLS FARGO WHICH HAS A SUB
SATISFACTORY SEE OUR A RATING --
DUE TO ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
RELATED TO DEFRAUDING THEIR OWN
CUSTOMERS A LOS ANGELES FACES
THE SAME DILEMMA HAVING
DISQUALIFIED WELLS FARGO FROM
SUBMITTING AN RFP FOR BANKING
SERVICES -- WHEN THEIR CONTRACT
EXPIRED BUT WAS FORCED TO EXTEND
THAT CONTRACT -- WHEN THERE WAS
A LACK OF AVAILABLE OPTIONS TO
BANK THE CITY'S MONEY THIS IS
WHY THE CITIES OF LOS ANGELES
SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND AND
BERKELEY HAVE ALL ENDORSED THIS
BILL?
AND WHY SAN JOSE EUREKA SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SANTA ROSA ARE ALL
CONSIDERING -- ENDORSEMENTS AS
WELL A LOCAL AND COMMUNITY BANKS
AND CREDIT UNIONS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM BUT MOST ARE TOO
SMALL TO HANDLE THE NEEDS OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND FALL.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE SAME
MULTINATIONAL BANKS WHICH
COLLAPSE ECONOMY IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HAVE SQUEEZED AND DEPLETED
THE LOCAL BANKING SECTOR WHICH
HAS SHRUNK TO A QUARTER OF ITS
FORMER SIZE -- SITTING COUNTY
TREASURER'S HAVE FIDUCIARY DUTY
TO MAKE PRINT INVESTMENTS AND
ABIDE BY STRICT -- EXTENSIVE
RULES ON HOW THEY DO THEIR JOB
IN THIS BILL CHANGES ABSOLUTELY
NONE OF THAT.
THE BILL SIMPLY OPENS THE DOOR
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ANALYZE THE BENEFITS OF A STATE
CHARTER PUBLIC BANK AND TO APPLY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT FOR THAT CHARTER.
IT REQUIRES FDIC INSURANCE FOR
ALL RELEVANT DEPOSITS COLLATERAL
CARMEN'S FOR PUBLIC DEPOSITS ARE
ALSO REMAIN THE SAME.
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN MAKES ALL
THE SAME REQUIREMENTS OF PUBLIC
BANKS THAT THEY MAKE ON PRIVATE
COMMERCIAL BANKS AND THEN SOME.
AND IN ADDITION TO THE NEW
LENDING AND SERVICE -- SERVICES
THE PUBLIC BANKING BANKS CAN
PROVIDE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
PUBLIC BANKS WILL PROVIDE NEW
PARTNER FOR COMMUNITY BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS A PARTNER WHO
DOESN'T WANT TO STEAL OUR
CUSTOMERS AND IN FACT IS LEGALLY
PROHIBITED FROM DOING SO.
THERE'S NO INTENT IN LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD PERMIT OR
ENABLE PUBLIC BANKS FROM -- TO
TO COMPETE WITH LOCAL BANKS AND
CREDIT UNIONS FOR EXISTING
CONSUMER OR COMMERCIAL DEMAND ON
THE CONTRARY IT REQUIRES THEM TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE LOCAL BANKING
PARTNERS TO EXTEND SERVICES.
AND CREATE NEW CORRESPONDENT AND
COOPERATIVE LENDING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT DID NOT EXIST
BEFORE OF THE BANK OF NORTH
DAKOTA IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF A
SMALL SCALE PUBLIC BANK SMALL
SCALE COURSE BECAUSE SMALL STATE --
WHICH SERVES AS A WHOLESALE
PARTNER TO LOCAL PRIVATE BANKS
TO MAGNIFY THE BENEFITS OF THEIR
INVESTMENT AND TARGET THEM TO
THE PUBLIC GOOD -- AND AS
ADVOCATES FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND BANKING
PUBLIC FUNDS WE'VE REALLY HAPPY
THAT THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
ACCEPTED -- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PUBLIC OVERSIGHT OF PUBLIC BANKS
IS WHAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO BE A
TRUSTWORTHY IT'S A SELF
SUSTAINING PART OF OUR PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A VITAL PIECE.
OF A HEALTHY BANKING SECTOR THAT
SORELY LACKING TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS CHRIS PADLOCK -- I'M
A CERTIFIED GOVERNMENT FINANCE
OFFICER -- AND I CURRENTLY SERVE
AS THE CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
FOR THE VALLEY THE MOON WATER
DISTRICT -- LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
SONOMA VALLEY.
I LIKE MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
SERVE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FEEL
PRESSURE TO MAXIMIZE PUBLIC
FUNDS. TO KEEP TAXES AND RATES
LOW WHILE AT THE SAME TIME TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES THE
COMMUNITY EXPECTS KEEP OUR ROADS
PAVED THE WATER FLOWING.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
FIRESTORM OUR DISTRICT WAS
HEAVILY AFFECTED BY THE FIRE SO
WE ALSO LEARN THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF INFRASTRUCTURE WORK TO DO TO
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT FIRE STORM --
AS MANY PARTS OF OUR COMMUNITY
HAVE SHOWN TO BE VERY VULNERABLE.
AS WELL WE ARE UNDER PRESSURE TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR INCREASED.
DENSITY FOR MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- THIS IS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE MEDIAN SIGNIFICANT WHEN
IT COMES TO IMPROVE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT THE UNDERLYING COST
SHOULD NOT BE LOST AND ANY OF US.
IT IS COMMON FOR THE COST OF
THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
BE DOUBLED BY THE FINANCING
COSTS WHETHER THROUGH BONTA
TRADITIONAL BANK LENDING.
SO WHEN WE LOOKED OF CASH FUND
WE LOOKED OF CASH FUNDS MANY OF
THESE PROJECTS AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN BUT THIS OF COURSE IT
EXPOSES US -- TO INFLATIONARY
PRESSURE BECAUSE IT PUSHED
PROJECTS FAR OFF INTO THE FUTURE.
ON THE SAME PROJECT COST USING
LENDING MODELS FOUND UNDER THE
BANK OF NORTH DAKOTA --
FINANCING MODELS SHOW SIGNAL
THESE COSTS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED THIS ALLOWS EITHER FOR
HIGHER QUALITY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS.
MORE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
GETTING DONE MORE MILES PIPE IN
THE GROUND AND LOWER RATES TO
OUR TAXPAYERS.
ON THE DEPOSITING A PUBLIC FUNDS
I SEE A PUBLIC BANK IS ONE MORE
SAFE PLACE TO PUT OUR PUBLIC
FUNDS LIKE MOST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE INVESTMENT
POLICIES HAD MANY RESTRICTIONS
ON WHERE AND HOW MUCH WE CAN
DEPOSIT ANYONE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION.
WITH A FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR SAFETY LIQUIDITY AND RATE OF
RETURN ON PUBLIC FUNDS SOME
ADDITIONAL RESTRICTIONS ARE
INSISTED UPON BY MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY THAT INCLUDE
EVALUATIONS OF BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND INVESTMENT
PRACTICES.
THAT PRECLUDE US FROM USING MANY
INSTITUTIONS AS QUALIFIED
INSTITUTIONS FOR THE POSITIVE
PUBLIC FUNDS.
MANY TIMES FINANCE LOOSE
INSTITUTIONS -- ARE EXCLUDED
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE CANNOT
REASONABLY ESTABLISH WHETHER OR
NOT THEY COMPLY WITH OUR
INVESTMENT POLICIES BECAUSE WE
LACK THE TIME AND RESOURCES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- TO MAKE THESE
COULD YOU DO THIS KIND OF
RESEARCH.
A BANK WITH THE CHARTER AND
INVESTMENT POLICY THAT IS.
THAT IS DESIGNED FOR THE PUBLIC
GOOD WOULD MAKE THIS TASK MUCH
SIMPLER AND POSSIBLY PROVIDE
HIGHER RATES OF RETURN ON
DEPOSITS THAT WE CURRENTLY GET A
COMMERCIAL BANKS AS DEMONSTRATED.
IN NORTH DAKOTA'S PUBLIC BANK.
I URGE AND EITHER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
TAYLOR JACK.
TELL JACKSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LYNETTE LAYER OF DAVIS IN
SUPPORT -- FOR YOUR LONG A
CLIMATE ACTION ALSO SUPPORT --
YELLOW MOVE ON AND YELLOW
INTERFAITH ALLIANCE FOR CLIMATE
JUSTICE GREAT IDEA.
IN THE CITY WEBER ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR
THIS FREE PARTY CALIFORNIA.
RUN HAVE TO WATCH OUT OR STILL
ARE ISSUES BUT ANYWAY.
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING THIS ISSUE
FOR NEARLY FIFTY YEARS AND SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL NOW.
KAREN SHOCK ON BEHALF OF OF
THREE FIFTY SOUTH BAY LA THREE
FIFTY RIVERSIDE. THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION AND THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO WHERE I LIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER OF WOODLAND
WITH ALSO FOR CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS MIKE MONACAN
BEHALF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS LEGISLATION IS GOING
PROVIDE LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES
AND LOTS OF BENEFITS FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ROGER SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING MARGIE LEWIS FROM
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITIES FOR A
BIT REPRESENTING COMMUNITIES FOR
A BETTER ENVIRONMENT IN STRONG
AND ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT.
LIVE WITH THE STATUS MY NUMBER
IS A BOTTLE AND A PRESENT THOUGH
UP ALL DAY AND GOOD AFTERNOON
HER NAME SOME BATTLES WHO'S HERE
REPRESENTING PULL THEIR GETTING
INTO THE RING AS HAVING THE SINK
ONE YES CONSISTENT WITH ANOTHER
COMPANY THAT.
YOUR RANGEL A NUMBER IN IT
DILLON AT THE MONEY THAT.
AN EXAMPLE YANG IS THE BEST A
LOCAL BUT I BUT I'M ALSO DONALD.
BONUS.
WHO -- FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS HAS BEEN SERVING THE
COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SHE'S HERE REPRESENTING ALL THE
MEMBERS ENERGY YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PUTTING YOUR THING -- ME SEE
HOST BEGINNING IT ALONE EVEN SEE
THAT YOU E. OKAY OKAY YEAH
SONORA YES IN SUPPORT THEN THEY
THERE'S SOMEONE CALL AT NO WELL
NO YOU ON THE LINE UP WITH ANY
THAT I DON'T EVEN SEE THAT YOU
MEET BECAUSE THAT PICKING UP AND
GET IT SET UP.
ALL THAT YOU'LL GET OKAY.
GLAZER ONE COUPLE THEY MOST THEN
THEY DON'T PISS THEM.
AND WITHOUT THIS PUBLIC BANK MY
KIDS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GO TO
UNIVERSITY AND MY DAUGHTER IS
YOUNG BUT WOULD LIKE TO BE A
LAWYER AND WE NEED THIS PUBLIC
BANK IN ORDER TO HELP THAT
[inaudible]
LAST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RAMOS
HELLO AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE HOUSING JUSTICE ACTION TEAM
IN DISTRICT ELEVEN OF IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND WHERE HUNDREDS OF MEMBERS
ARE URGING YOU TO PLEASE PASS
THIS BILL AND MOVE IT FORWARD.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
LIKE A JERK YOUR CURRENT MEMBER --
MEMBERS MUCH LIKE WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
SUSHIL JACOB WITH LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHARLIE SHAMA
SEPARATIST GO RISING AN ALLIANCE
OF NINE BASICALLY ORGANIZATIONS
IN SAN FRANCISCO IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UBER WILLIAMS I CHAIR SAN
FRANCISCO ACE -- WEREN'T SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND I'M I'M ONE OF
THE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS A LOSS OR HOMES TO
FORECLOSURE.
SINCE FORECLOSURE CRISIS A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT HI I ENCOURAGE
YOU TO MOVE THIS BILL FOR THANK
YOU.
I'M BRED GARRETT AND THE SANTA
CRUZ CLIMATE ACTION NETWORK
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
THANK.
I I'M JORDAN HAMMOND -- HI MATT
ORGANIZER FOR EAST BAY PUBLIC
BANK ALSO US YOU OWN CO FOUNDER
OF A TWENTY PERSON START UP AND
REALLY SEE A LOT OF POTENTIAL
FOR THIS.
TO ADDRESS THE POVERTY IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD -- IN THE EAST BAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI DOUG NORRLAND FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH US AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION ACTIVE
MEMBERS SUPPORTERS IN THE US
STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M SERIOUS ETHAN HERE BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THREE FIFTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI K. TANAKA FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA CLEAN ENERGY
APPLIANCE STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO EVERYONE I SHIRLEY
BROWNING WITH PRINCIPALLY
BANKING SANTA ROSA SPEAKING IN
STRONG INSULT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SUSAN HARMAN DOCTOR SUSAN HARMON --
SPEAKING FOR CODE PINK -- THE
WELLSTONE DEMOCRATIC CLUB IN.
OF THE EAST BAY AND THE EAST BAY
PUBLIC BANK THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA DESIGN --
FROM OAKLAND.
REGISTERING STRONG SUPPORT FROM
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK MORE SPECIFICALLY IT'S
ACTUALLY FOR MY SELF.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN PUBLIC
BANKING -- I AM A LAND WAR AND
I'M MORE SO WERE A DAY TRADER
I'VE SEEN THROUGH THE AND HOLD
BANKING SYSTEM.
COLLAPSE IN A WATCH BLOOM BURKE
EVERY MINUTE WHEN THAT HAPPENED.
EM BUT I'M NOT A SOUR GRAPE TO
HEAR TO SPEAK FOR THAT BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY DID VERY WELL IN COME
OUT OF IT.
VERY WELL BUT I JUST I'M HERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO HAVE A
PUBLIC BANKING TO COMPETE WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR SO THAT YOUR
ARM [inaudible]
RETIREMENT.
FUN WILL BE THERE FOR YOU WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO RETIRE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JASON LANE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WE'D.
VERY MUCH LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- AND THE
AUTHORS WILLINGNESS -- TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS I THINK.
YOU KNOW IT IT IT IS CERTAINLY
HELPFUL BUT IT'S UNFORTUNATELY
JUST NOT ENOUGH TO SAFEGUARD
TAXPAYER DOLLARS -- AND THE
REASON IS SIMPLE THE MEASURE
STILL ALLOWS -- STILL GIVES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LICENSE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE CREATION
OF A A PUBLIC BANK NOT
WITHSTANDING -- WHAT THE
FEASIBILITY STUDY SAYS A OR WHAT
ITS OUTCOME IS SO IT'S NOT
UNFORTUNATELY SUBJECT TO ANY
TYPE OF VOTE -- IT ONLY REQUIRES
A PRESENTATION OF THE
FEASIBILITY STUDY AND THIS IS
WHY THIS GIVES US CONCERN -- IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL -- CREATED THE AS
PART OF THE AD HOC COMMITTEE ON
JOBS IN THE ECONOMY WHICH WAS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE CITY COUNCIL.
CREATED A TASK FORCE -- TO LOOK
AT PUBLIC BANKING  THE RESULT
OF THAT STUDY -- AFTER A YEAR'S
WORTH OF HEARINGS WAS A HUNDRED
PAGE REPORT CREATED BY THE CITY
ANALYST OFFICE AND THAT REPORT
SHOWED.
THAT THE COST IN THE WRIST TO
TAXPAYER DOLLARS DO NOT WARRANT
THE CREATION OF A PUBLIC BANK
AND THE ENCOURAGE THE CITY
COUNCIL. TO TO LOOK AT
STRENGTHENING EXISTING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOLS RATHER THAN
GOING FORWARD WITH THE PUBLIC
BANK.
NOT WITHSTANDING THAT IN JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CITY COUNCIL
VOTED TO PUT MEASURE BE ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER WHICH ALTERS
THE CITY'S CHARTER TO ALLOW FOR
THE CREATION OF THE PUBLIC BANK.
THE CITY COUNCIL IGNORED THE
DATA AND THEY MOVED FORWARD.
IN SAN FRANCISCO THE CITY
TREASURER CREATED A MUNICIPAL
BANK TASK FORCE.
AND THAT TASK FORCE ALSO HAD
HEARINGS FOR A YEAR AND
CONCLUDED WITH YET ANOTHER
HUNDRED PAGE STUDY.
THIS STUDY HAD FOUR DIFFERENT
MODELS ALL FOUR MODELS RESULTED
IN A LOSS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AND COST TO THE CITY.
NOT WITHSTANDING THAT EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SAN FRANCISCO
UNANIMOUSLY ENDORSE THE VERY
PRODUCT THAT'S EMBODIED IN AB.
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN SO THE
FEASIBILITY STUDY IN AND OF
ITSELF IS IS NOT A SAFE COURT --
SANTA FE.
WASHINGTON STATE WASHINGTON
STATE ACTUALLY HAS A STUDY OF
THE STUDIES LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO MASSACHUSETTS ALL OF
THEIR FEASIBILITY STUDIES
CONCLUDED.
THAT THERE IS ENORMOUS COST IN
CAPITAL IN MAINTAINING THE
OPERATION OF A BANK AN ENORMOUS
RISK TO TAXPAYERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THE LOS
ANGELES REDEVELOPMENT BANK WENT
BANKRUPT IT TOOK GRANT MONEY AND
MADE SMALL BUSINESS LOANS.
AND 40% OF THOSE LOANS WERE
CHARGED OFF A CHARGE OFF AS A
LOSS IN IN IN IN WHEN A WHEN A
PUBLIC BANK HAS LOSSES IT HAS TO
ANSWER TO THE TAXPAYER.
WHEN A PRIVATE BANK HAS LOSSES
IT HAS TO ANSWER -- YOU KNOW HAS
TO ANSWER TO SHAREHOLDERS -- SO
YOU KNOW WE WE WE WE URGE YOU TO
TO OPPOSE THIS MEASURE TO VOTE
NO THERE'S A LOT IN THIS BILL
THAT'S LACKING -- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK IT IS
NOTABLE IS THAT.
WHEN THE PRIVATE SECTOR HAS TO
COMPETE WENT WHEN IT WHEN THE
PUBLIC ENTITY ENGAGES IN
COMMERCE IN COMPETITION WITH A
PRIVATE ENTITY IT OUGHT TO BE?
REQUIRED TO PAY TAXES THIS BILL
ACTUALLY ESTABLISHES A SEPARATE
CORPORATE STRUCTURE.
THAT CORPORATION SHOULD PAY
INCOME TAXES THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT IT WOULD
NOT PAY INCOME TAXES.
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE IN
CALIFORNIA IS EIGHT POINT 8% THE
BANK TAX RATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
TEN POINT 8% SO IT'S A HIGHER
NUMBER THAN THE CORPORATE TAX
RATE WHEN YOU'RE TAKING INCOME
PRODUCING.
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE TAXABLE AWAY
FROM PRIVATE INDUSTRY IN
TRANSFERRING TO THEM TO A PUBLIC
ANDY THAT'S NOT PAYING TAXES
THERE WILL BE A HIT TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
HERE TODAY THERE IS NOTHING IN
THE BILL THAT STIPULATES THAT HE
PUBLIC BANK HAS TO ADHERE TO ALL
FEDERAL BANKING LAWS.
NOR IS THERE ANYTHING IN THE
BILL THAT SAYS THE MEASURE THAT
OUR PUBLIC BANK HAS TO ADHERE TO
THE COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT ACT.
WAR OF THE RECENTLY ENACTED
SWEEPING PRIVACY LEGISLATION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
NEXT YEAR IT OUGHT TO HAVE THAT
IN THE BILL.
FINALLY IF THIS IS THE PEOPLE'S
MONEY IF IT'S ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL THEN WE SHOULD SHOULD
JACK THIS TO A VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE THE PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DECIDE AS THEY DID WITH
MEASURE V. IN LA WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO CREATE A PUBLIC
BANK.
NOT NOTE THEY VOTED NO THANK YOU.
58% 2402% FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
MARGARET GLAD SHE NUMBER HAVE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK OUR MEMBERS ARE SOLELY
SMALL COMMUNITY BANKS ARE BOARDS
AND OUR CUSTOMERS ARE BAKED
BASED IN THE COMMUNITIES AND WE
WERE VAST ARE FUNDS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
WHY DO APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
THAT THE AMENDMENTS TO AUTHOR
TOOK AND THE WORK THIS
COMMITTEES DONE -- AND THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT TALKS
ABOUT PARTNERING WITH COMMUNITY
BANKS AND MISTER SANTIAGO IN HIS
PRESENTATION TALKED ABOUT HOW
THESE BANKS WOULD COMPETE WITH
COMMUNITY BANKS.
GREEN BANKS ARE STRUGGLING IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY THE NUMBER
WE'VE LOST HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY
BANKS AS A MERGER AND TAKING
OVER BY LARGER INSTITUTIONS.
SOME OF OUR BANKS ARE DOING
AMAZING THINGS MY PARTNERING
WITH GOVERNMENT.
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS THE AYE BANK
TODAY THIS COMMITTEE WHEN IT
JOINED WITH THE SOMEONE BANKING
COMMITTEE AND A INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ABOUT PUBLIC MAKING.
HEARD BANKERS TALK ABOUT THE
AMAZING THINGS THAT THEY'RE
DOING IN THIS COMMUNITY RIGHT
NOW TO PARTNER AND GROW AND
REINVEST IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE.
LOCAL FUNDS LOCAL AGENCY DEPOSIT
THAT CURRENTLY COMMUNITY BANKS
ARE TAKING AND REINVESTING IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES BEING TAKEN
AWAY FROM US WITH COMPETITION
FROM THE STATE SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE.
EMILY ACT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN OPPOSITION.
FAILURE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
OPPOSED IT IS STILL ON OUR
JOCULARLY SAYS WE DO BELIEVE.
THAT THIS BILL WILL COST JOBS
LOCALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO WHO IS
RUNNING ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE.
ONE SO THIS WOULD TO THE BANKING
COMMITTEE SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THESE BANKING QUESTIONS THAT ARE
COMING UP.
WERE THEY ADDRESSED DURING THAT
THAT TESTIMONY ABSOLUTELY WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH BANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF -- BUT IF I
COULD JUST MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS ABOUT -- WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE BANKING LOBBYISTS AND
IT WAS INTERESTING THAT THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE SHIFTED BETWEEN
THE ARGUMENTS THAT WERE RAISED
ON MONDAY AND THE ARGUMENTS AND
REYES TODAY BUT IF I CAN SAY A
FEW THINGS?
FIRST OF ALL THERE IS A
SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW.
THE PROCESS INVOLVES A VERY
LENGTHY ANALYSIS ON A
FEASIBILITY STUDY.
AND THE BANKING LOBBY SUGGEST
THERE'S NOT A VOTE THAT IS NOT
TRUE IN FACT I WILL JUST SAY --
IT IS IN ACTUALLY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ANNOUNCES ITSELF ON
PAGE NINE SAYS THE STUDY THAT'S
REQUIRED MUST BE PRESENTED AN
APPROVED BY THE GOVERNING BODY
OF THE LOCAL AGENCY.
AT A PUBLIC MEETING PRIOR TO THE
LOCAL AGENCY SUBMITTING AN
APPLICATION WE HAVE NO INTEREST
IN A LOCAL JURISDICTION MOVING
FOR WITH THIS WITHOUT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS.
ANALYZING THE DATA AND FIGURED
OUT SO POINT NUMBER.
ONE UP.
NUMBER TWO THERE'S A SUGGESTION
THAT SOMEHOW -- THIS IS GOING TO
KILL COMMUNITY BANKS AND I COULD
NOT DISAGREE WITHOUT MORE
STRONGLY.
THE LAW OUR BILLS SPECIFICALLY
SAYS.
THAT ANY LOCAL PUBLIC BANK WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY BANKS IN FACT QUITE
THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED IN
RECENT YEARS THE WALL STREET
BANKS.
HAVE ACTUALLY KILLED 75% OF
CALIFORNIA LOCAL BANKS OVER THE
PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR THERE WERE
FIVE HUNDRED COMMUNITY BANKS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS YEAR THERE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BECAUSE OF THE ACTIVITIES
OF THE LARGEST WALL STREET BANKS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN NORTH
DAKOTA.
IS COMMUNITY BY THE COMMUNITY
BANKING SYSTEM HAS ACTUALLY BEEN
ENHANCED BY THE EXISTENCE OF A
PUBLIC BANK -- I WANT TO ADDRESS
THE THE JOB KILLER SUGGESTION BY
THE CHAMBER WITH ALL DUE RESPECT
THE WALL STREET BANKS WERE
TALKING ABOUT DESTROYED
COUNTLESS JOBS.
WITH THE LAST FINANCIAL CRISIS
COUNTLESS JOBS RELATED TO THE
MORTGAGE FORECLOSURES CRISIS
COUNTLESS JOBS THAT ARE IMPACTED
BECAUSE A PREDATORY LENDING OF
THE FACT THAT SMALL BUSINESSES
HAVE NOT BEEN LIED.
TO AND OUR VISION OF PUBLIC
BANKS IS THAT THEY ARE JOB
CREATORS THAT THEY ARE INVESTING
IN LOCAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THEY'RE INVESTING IN LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESSES. TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE CREATING JOBS -- THE LAST
POINT I WANT TO MENTION IS
AROUND -- THE POINT INVOLVING
TAXATION BECAUSE THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT -- THAT HAS BEEN
SUGGESTED.
I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THE
CREDIT UNION'S RIGHTFULLY ARE
TAX EXEMPT BECAUSE THEY EXISTS
TO SERVE THEIR MEMBERS NOT TO
MAKE A PROFIT FOR INVESTORS FOR
PROFIT INSTITUTIONS.
THAT HAVE INVESTORS IS OUR
BOTTOM LINE THEY ARE TAXED BUT
NONPROFIT.
ENTITIES GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES
ARE NOT TAX BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THE PUBLIC GOOD AS THEIR NUMBER
ONE FIGHT DO SHERRY -- OBJECTIVE
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES OUT
REQUIRES PUBLIC BANKS TO HAVE A
FIGHT JUDICIARY DUTY TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO THE PUBLIC ASSETS
AND THAT IS WHY WE TREAT THEM.
IN THIS BILL LIKE A CREDIT UNION
IF WALL STREET BANKS.
WERE NOT BASED ON THE PROFIT
MOTIVE THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY TAXES BUT THE FACT AMOUNT OF
DATA THEY DO.
THAT IS HOW WE STRUCTURE OUR TAX
SYSTEM OUR IN OUR OUR COUNTRY SO
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THOSE
POINTS.
I FIND IT INTERESTING THAT LOS
ANGELES.
TOOK IT THE TICKET TO THE PEOPLE
FOR VOTE -- WHAT HAPPENED WHAT
WHAT WAS THE?
WE LOOK AT THE OTHER WAY STREET
A SHOE STRING BUDGETS AND A
GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT -- WITH
ALMOST NEAR ZERO DOLLARS GETS --
CLOSE 2405%.
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD MOVE.
AND SO NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE SAME LET'S
HELP LET'S HELP WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS WANT.
HELLO IT LOOKS LIKE YES SOME
MEMORY THIS.
YOU KNOW I DO WANT TO JUST --
SAY THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS BILL -- HOPEFULLY
YOU KNOW MAKE SURE THAT -- IT
CONTINUES IN THIS PROCESS I LIKE
TO SEE IT EVOLVING I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE AMENDMENTS NO
I THINK THE THE THE ONE WHICH MR
CHIU SPOKE TO WAS THE ONE
RELATED -- TO THE PUBLIC STUDY I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP
ON YOU KNOW SORRY THAT WE DO
THAT ANALYSIS BUT I CERTAINLY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
TODAY.
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING IT
MOVED TO THE PROCESS AND SEE YOU
KNOW I MEAN I WAS IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE YOU KNOW IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING --
FROM FROM -- ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
TO BOTH -- AUTHORS FOR THE
ONGOING DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING OVER THIS TOPIC I THINK
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT MORE.
ABOUT BANKING -- IN ALL THESE
AREAS THAT ARE THERE.
CERTAINLY -- THE THE BANKING IN
THE MEMBERS THAT CAME THERE
STARTED TO ADDRESS -- SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED.
HOWEVER WE WE STILL AND WE HEAR
IN THE PRESENTATION THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CORPORATIONS VERSUS
TAXPAYERS MONEY.
WHEN TAXPAYERS MONEY IS AT RISK
I THINK WE ALL OF US MORE OF A
STRINGENT?
ON OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RISK TOLERANCE IS THERE FOR
ANY MUNICIPALITY -- THIS
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AND I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING HARD
ON IT.
BUT IT BECOMES THAT RISK
TOLERANCE THAT THE TAXPAYERS IN
THE COMMUNITIES -- ARE SUFFERING.
WHEREAS IN IN THE SHAREHOLDERS
THEY'RE PUTTING IN PRIVATE
DOLLARS THEY KNOW THE RISK
TOLERANCE BEFORE THEY EVEN GET
INTO IT SO IF A BANK.
OR SOMETHING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS STARS TO HIT THESE
DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS THEY START
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE MAKING
CHANGES TO PROTECT.
THAT ONGOING INVESTMENT THAT'S
THERE AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
WITHIN THE PRIVATE SECTOR NOW
THE GOVERNMENTAL SCHEME.
THE GOVERNMENTAL SCHEME I KNOW
I'VE ASK QUESTIONS AS FAR AS HOW
MUCH WOULD BE THE THE CAPITAL
OUTLAY FOR SOME OF THESE UP --
TO MANY CITIES ARE
MUNICIPALITIES IT WILL MOVE
FORWARD AND THEY FINANCIALLY
SOUND AND I KNOW -- IT IS THAT
WE DISCUSSED THAT AND SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF
BANKING -- STARTS TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE PLANS WILL BE
FORWARD ON A FIVE YEAR PRO FORMA --
SHEET ON IT PRO FORMAS ESTIMATE
ADJUSTMENTS AND ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT MOVE
FORWARD.
HOWEVER WE WE STILL LOOK AT THE
INITIAL OUTLAY VERSUS PRIVATE
DOLLARS AND INVESTORS COMING IN.
AND MELISSA PARODIES WITH THE
THE INFLUX OF TAXPAYERS MONEY
BEING.
IN THOSE AREAS IN THE SAFE CARS
THAT ARE THERE.
THERE STILL IS QUESTIONS THE
THAT I DO HAVE -- YOU KNOW AS
FAR AS THE STAR UP OF USING
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS TO FOR A START
UP BUSINESS WHEN WE KNOW THAT
IT'S IT'S A RISKY BUSINESS RIGHT
LOANING MONEY OUT AND DOING
THESE DIFFERENT THINGS.
OR ELSE THERE WOULDN'T BE -- A
RISK TOLERANCE AND SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE SEEN IN
HISTORY WITH -- SAVINGS AND
LOANS OR THE BANKING INDUSTRY
WHERE WE SEEN SOME BAIL OUT FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE TO
THE BANKING INDUSTRY HAS SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
SO IT'S NOT THAT IT'S NOT.
THERE'S NO RISK TO IT THERE IS
RISK TOLERANCE TO IT SO NOT
KNOWING WHAT THAT RISK TOLERANCE
IS ON WE CONTINUE.
TO BE OPEN TO DIALOGUE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S THERE AND AS WELL
AS MOVING FORWARD AND SEEN A LOT
OF THE SUPPORT IT'S THERE.
BUT YET THERE STILL IS SOME SOME
HARD QUESTIONS TO BE ASKED --
EVEN AT THIS POINT NIGHT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING ALL THESE
QUESTIONS AND AND TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME IS JUST A COMPLEX
ISSUE.
AND HOPEFULLY AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD WE'LL SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLARITY ON IT THAT WE WILL
KEEP AN OPEN MIND TO IT.
BUT TODAY I'M IN A RESERVE MY
VOTE -- TO NOT SUPPORT THIS WILL
BE.
FOR HEY OTHER COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- IN A TEMAS XIN
THE SECOND.
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M I'M
AT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
WILL BUT I DO WANT TO CLEAR UP --
WHEN I HAD TALKED ABOUT BANKS --
IN COMPETITION I WAS I DIDN'T
MENTION PLEASE DON'T REMEMBER
MENTIONING COMMUNITY -- BANKS OR
CREDIT UNIONS -- WHEN I WHEN I
START ABOUT THE BANKS I WAS
SEEING IN MY MIND THE BIG
CORPORATE BANKS -- AND SAID THAT
RATHER THAN THE SAY CORPORATE
NAMES BUT I CAN -- AND LOOK THIS
IS A SERIOUS POSSIBLE I ENJOYED
OUR CONVERSATIONS BACK AND FORTH.
BUT IT'S LIKE ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I MEAN HOW MANY OF
US OF SAT BEFORE COMMITTEE AND
SAID HEY I NEED TIME TO WORK ON
THAT AND THIS IS WHAT EXACTLY
WHAT THIS IS YOU NEED TIME TO
WORK ON IT.
AND A AND MOVE IT -- FOR A AND
IT'S IN BROKEN TEAM TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WAYS TO PROTECT -- THE
PUBLIC DOLLAR -- AND PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT AT SOME POINT
IN TIME A PUBLIC HEALTH HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IS MY CALLING IT
SAID IN THE LAST MEETING -- WITH
SOMETHING ABSURD THAT SHOULD
EXIST AND NOW WE HAVE A PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND I CAN GO
ON WITH DIFFERENT PUBLIC --
GOODS IN AGENCIES -- AND THIS IS
JUST A STEP FORWARD IN IN THAT
SAME FRAME OF THOUGHT THAT WOULD
THERE IS POSSIBILITY THAT TO
HAVE A PUBLIC BANK -- WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THROWING OUT
DOLLARS AND AND SPENDING BUT
THERE IS A SERIOUS PLANET YOU
GOTTA PUT IN PLACE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT OU HAVE TO
HAVE INSURANCE -- FDIC INSURANCE --
AND WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION TO ENSURE THE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE A ARE --
WELL KEPT -- AND WE CAN CONTINUE
TO PRESS OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM I BOUGHT
THIS IS -- I WOULD CONSIDER A
HISTORIC VOTE TO KEEP MOVING
THIS KIND OF CONVERSATION.
FOR AND I HOPE A MOST OF YOU --
WILL LAND ON THE ON THE US SIDE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
AND BASICALLY WANT TO THANK --
MISTER ROBERTS AND EACH OF YOU
WHO HAVE ENGAGE WITH US VERY
DEEPLY ON THIS AND AND I WANT TO
JUST MAKE THREE POINTS THE FIRST
IS AROUND RICK'S RISK TOLERANCE.
THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK ABOUT
QUITE A BIT BECAUSE AS AUTHORS
OF THIS WE DO NOT WANT TO SET UP
A SCENARIO FOR ANY THESE PUBLIC
BANKS TO FAIL.
AND THIS IS WHY THE REQUIREMENTS
IN THIS BILL ARE SO ONEROUS THAT
IT ACTUALLY WILL BE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANY LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO MEET ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
CHARTER A PUBLIC BANK.
AND THAT IS INTENTIONAL BECAUSE
AS YOU SAID WE DO NOT WANT TO
SET UP A SITUATION TO FAIL.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT I WOULD
NOT OF INTRODUCED THIS BILL.
IF. ELEVEN OF THE ELEVEN MEMBERS
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF MY JURISDICTION
HAD NOT PUT THEIR NAME TO SAME
WE MIGHT NEED TO DO THIS.
AFTER.
DEEP ANALYSIS THAT DID SHOW.
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
CAPITAL.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A NUMBER OF
YEARS TO GET THESE UP AND
RUNNING BUT EVEN WITH THAT RISK
PROFILE.
ALL OF MY LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE
ASKED ME AND ASKED US TO MOVE
FOR THE BILL TO GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO DO THIS.
THE SECOND THING I WANT TO SAY
IS I KNOW THE BANKING LOBBYIST
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT PUTTING
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AT RISK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN PUT IN RISK RIGHT NOW WITH
THE STATUS QUO. SEVEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS OF CALIFORNIA
PACKED TAXPAYER FUNDS ARE
INVESTED IN THESE BANKS.
AND THERE VESTED IN INSTITUTIONS
THAT ARE FAILING OUR CONSUMERS
THAT OUR FAMILY ARE HOMEOWNERS
THAT ARE FAILING OR SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE FAILING OUR
STUDENTS THERE PUT INSTANCE INTO
INSTITUTIONS.
THAT ARE OUR THAT ARE INVESTING
IN GUN MANUFACTURERS AND FOSSIL
FUEL INDUSTRIES AND COMPANIES
WITH UNFAIR PRACTICES.
AND I JUST THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
A DIFFERENT OPTION.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
I DO KNOW THIS IS A NEW CONCEPT
AND IT TAKES.
TIME FOR FOLKS TO WRAP THEIR
BRAINS AROUND IT AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THIS IS A HARD THING
TO THINK ABOUT IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
THERE WAS A TIME.
IN OUR COUNTRY WHEN WE DID NOT
HAVE.
A PUBLIC HOUSING SYSTEM BECAUSE
AND IT IT CAME ABOUT BECAUSE THE
PRIVATE HOUSING SYSTEM BROKE
DOWN.
THERE WAS A TIME WE DIDN'T NEED
A PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM BUT THE
PRIVATE HEALTH SYSTEM BROKE DOWN
THERE'S A TIME WE DIDN'T NEED
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
BUT THE PRIVATE TRANSIT SYSTEM
BROKE DOWN AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE IS OUR WALL STREET BANKING
SYSTEM UNFORTUNATELY HAS FAILED
US.
AND WE NEED TO EXPLORE OTHER
OPTIONS NOTHING IS GOING TO
CHANGE OVERNIGHT WE'RE SIMPLY
SAYING LET'S ESTABLISH THE RULES.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE ADDRESS THE
RISK AND MOVE IT FOR I VERY MUCH
RESPECT EVERYONE'S PERSPECTIVE
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS QUESTION.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN MOVE IT OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND I HOPE
THAT FOR FOLKS WHO ARE NOT
PERSUADED TODAY WE CAN PERSUADE
YOU OVER TIME.
THANK YOU.
THE LADY ON THE PHONE BOB
PROCESS YEAH -- SHE SAID IN THIS
POLICY -- TWO DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF FARMS FOR OUR THIS IS KATIE
MAY AND HOW MUCH OF THIS POLICY
ENERGY ASIANS AND THE STAFF
GOING.
FOR A LOOSE.
THIS IS WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
MADE SURE THAT THOSE THAT
[inaudible]
OR UNDERSTAND AGAIN A BUT YOU
ALSO CAN.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT -- FORWARD
PUTTING THAT MONEY INTO THE SIDE
OF A THANK YOU.
YOUR CLOTHES OKAY -- SO THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHORS AND THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS.
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS THE POOR THE
NINETIES ANOTHER LOCAL AGENCY
MORE AGENCIES MORE RECENTLY
QUESTIONABLE INVESTMENTS CAN
LEAD TO DIRE CONSEQUENCE
CONSEQUENCES.
WHEN LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE FILED
FOR BANKRUPTCY?
SERVICES ARE CUT.
JOBS ARE LOST EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
AND PENSIONS HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
TO COME UNDER ATTACK.
ENSURING THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
EMPLOYEES TAXPAYERS ARE
PROTECTED IS OF THE MONTH OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR THOSE OF
US IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ENSURING **** THROUGH FDIC AND
HAVING A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF
POTENTIAL FISCAL IMPACTS ON
LOCAL AGENCIES IT'S CRITICAL.
BEFORE DEDICATING SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES.
A PUBLIC TRANSPARENT STUDY IS A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION BEFORE
LOCAL OFFICIALS OFFICIALS MAKE A
DECISION TO APPLY FOR THE
CREATION OF A PUBLIC BANK.
THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO MAKE
FDIC INSURANCE AND THE PROBLEM
PRELIMINARY STUDY A REQUIREMENT.
A REQUIREMENTS.
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE SUPPORTERS
HAVE CONSISTENTLY HOW TO VALUE.
SAID A VALUE OF PUBLIC BANKS.
IS THAT LOCAL AGENCIES WILL
DIVEST FROM CERTAIN INDUSTRIES.
YET THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
LIMIT PUBLIC BANKS POTENTIAL
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO.
I MUST WONDER OUT LOUD IF THE
AUTHORS MAY WISH TO IDENTIFY
RESTRICTIONS ON PUBLIC BANKS.
JUST FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY -- AS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HI LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM HI.
BOERNER HORVATH RAMOS.
RAMOS NOT VOTING THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NOW. THREE FOUR IT'S WE
NEED ONE MORE VOTE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
FOR HEY.
YEAH WOULD LIKE TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
ONE LET'S SEE.
THERE'S A LOT OF OUR NEXT WILL
BE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA IS
BILL PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU A MADAM CHAIR WE'RE
HERE TO PRESENT AB -- TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA --
WHO WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS?
THANK YOU IN AB TWELVE FORTY A
WILL PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A
TOOL TO INCENTIVIZE THE
REDEVELOPMENT REHABILITATION
FACILITIES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
BY ATTRACTING INVESTMENT FROM
SMALL AND MID SIDE.
MANUFACTURES.
THIS BILL ULTIMATELY WILL ALLOW
THE CITY OR COUNTY TO OFFER A
PARTIAL PROPERTY TAX REBATE. FOR
QUALIFIED MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES LOCATED IN THEIR
JURISDICTION THEN INVEST IN
EXCESS OF FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OR MORE IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
MANUFACTURE ENTERING INTO A
COMMUNITY AGREEMENT.
THIS COMMUNITY AGREEMENT MUST
SPECIFY THE NUMBER OF TYPES OF
JOBS TO BE CREATED BY THE
QUALIFIED MANUFACTURING FACILITY.
THE COMPENSATION RANGES FOR EACH
JOB T<c.cyan> AND THE COURAGE TO BE</c>
PROVIDED BY AN EMPLOYER
SPONSORED HEALTH BENEFITS PLAN.
THIS WILL ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ANOTHER TOOL TO BETTER TARGET
THE SMALLER MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES.
THAT ARE BECOMING INCREASINGLY
MORE ATTRACTIVE IN ADDITION TO
THE LARGER MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES TARGETED UNDER THE
ALREADY AUTHORIZED CAPITAL
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE AUTHOR
UNDERSTANDS THE COMMITTEE'S
CONCERNS REGARDING THE NEED FOR
LANGUAGE REGARDING WHICH AREAS
OF A CITY OR COUNTY.
WOULD BE ALLOWED UNDER THIS BILL.
WE WILL LOOK AT POSSIBLE
CLARIFICATIONS AND DEFINITIONS
THAT MAY APPLY IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE BILL TRULY TARGETS
REVITALIZATION.
I ALSO HAVE JUROR OUT C<c.cyan> WE</c>
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND GIRL
BOX SO -- TO THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENTS.
INTEREST THEY WANT TO PRESENT ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS A MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA FOR CARING THIS BILL AND
SOME OF THEM RAMOS FOR STEPPING
IN TODAY.
MY NAME IS TRAIL COOK I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF AB -- TWELVE FORTY EIGHT AS A
MEMBER RAMOS MENTIONED BY THE
BILL IS MODELED ON THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT INCENTIVE PROGRAM A
BILL THAT.
PASSED I AM WAS RECENTLY
EXTENDED OUR LAST YEAR WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE.
I LIKE THAT PROGRAM.
THE THE TRIP FOR THE TARGET A
REVITALIZATION PRO INVESTMENT
PROGRAM A. B. TWELVE FORTY EIGHT
OPERATE ON A WIN WIN WIN MODEL --
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WINS
BECAUSE THEY GET NEW THEY GET TO
ATTRACT NEW INVESTMENT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE OTHERWISE
GARNERED WITHOUT THE PROGRAM --
THE MANUFACTURE WINS BECAUSE
THEY GET A CUT IN COSTS FOR
THEIR OPERATIONS AND THE
COMMUNITY WINS BECAUSE THEY GET
A DIRECT -- BENEFIT.
DUE -- TO THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
PAYMENT EITHER THE MANUFACTURER
MAKES IT FUNDS A PROGRAM IN
THEIR COMMUNITY [inaudible]
SO.
THE MODEL IN THE CITY IS GREAT
IN THE IN THE CAPITAL -- IN BEST
MINUTES AND PROGRAM IS GREAT
HOWEVER AT THE MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY HAS CHANGED SINCE THE
CIP WAS ENACTED IN IN THE
NINETIES -- SINCE THIS IT WAS
ENACTED MANUFACTURING HAS GOTTEN
LEANER IT'S GOTTEN SMALLER BUT
MORE PRODUCTIVE IT'S FASTER --
AND WE CAN PRODUCE A GREAT MANY
GOODS IN FACILITIESTHAT WE
COULD NOT HAVE OTHERWISE --
BEFORE -- SO NOW WE SEE
MANUFACTURING MOVING INTO URBAN
CENTERS INTO COMMERCIAL CENTERS --
DOWNTOWN TO DISTRICTS -- AT A
DOWNTOWN COMMERCIAL DISTRICTS IN
PLACES WE COULDN'T BEFORE AND
WHEN WE DO THAT WE ARE
REVITALIZING COMMUNITIES AND
DRAWING NEW INVESTMENT.
THE GROWTH IN MANUFACTURING IS
IN THE RANGE OF INVESTMENTS WHEN
FIVE AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THE MEGA INVESTMENT THAT
THE SET WAS INTENDED TO ATTRACT
OF A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE -- IS LESS THAN
4% OF A MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA.
BY COMPARISON INVESTMENTS WITH
THE FIVE AND FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT
40% OF INVESTMENT -- AND THE
NUMBER OF JOBS CREATED BY THAT
INVESTMENT IS MORE THAN FOUR
TIMES THE AMOUNT CREATED BY
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OR MORE.
SO THE TARGETED REVITALIZATION
IN.
CENTER PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO AB TWELVE FORTY
EIGHT IS REALLY GEARED TOWARD
PROVIDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL THAT WILL
ATTRACT MANUFACTURING INVESTMENT
WHERE IT IS TODAY.
AS AN EXAMPLE -- WE CAN POINT TO
A MANUFACTURING FACILITY THAT IS
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA IS DISTRICT IN RALEIGH --
THERE THERE WAS A FACILITY THAT
SHUT DOWN WAS RAN BY A NATIONAL
FOOD -- PROCESSING CHAIN --
AFTER IT LEFT WE SAW THE CITY
HAD A NEARLY 25% POVERTY RATES
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN A SMALLER
SCALED MANUFACTURER MAKING CRAFT
BEEF PRODUCTS TOOK OVER IN OLD
FACILITY -- AND AFTER INVESTING
IN MAKING INVESTMENTS OF FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THEY
CREATED SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE JOBS AS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AFTER THAT INVESTMENT WE'VE SEEN
FOLLOW UP INVESTMENT IN THE FEED
INDUSTRY IN THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY ALL OF THESE --
SUBSEQUENT INSULAR INDUSTRIES
THAT SUPPORT -- BEEF
MANUFACTURING AND SO GROWTH
COMES WITH MANUFACTURING COLUMNS
THE CHALLENGE AT THAT FACILITY
FACED WAS THAT THEY DID NOT HAD
THAT THEY NEEDED SUPPORT MENTAL
FINANCING INCENTIVES FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN SO THEY WORKED WITH THEIR
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD AS WELL AS OTHER --
COMMUNITY AND REGIONAL
INVESTMENT SERVICES BUT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAD TO DO A LOT
OF WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
FACILITY COULD BE SUPPORTED
BEFORE COULD BE UP AND RUNNING.
SO THE PROGRAM A. B. TWELVE
FORTY IS TO PROVIDE ANOTHER TOOL
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO THAT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE ASKING FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- I I'M EXCITED TO TO
BE HERE THIS EVENING BECAUSE I I
THINK THIS IS A FANTASTIC TOLD
MY NAME'S ROBERT BURRIS.
I'M NOT GO BACK TO THE HOTEL --
AND THEN I'D SORRY FOR THAT.
BUT I DO REMEMBER.
I DO REPRESENTS KHALLID -- AN
ORGANIZATION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PRACTITIONERS -- AS WELL AS THE
SOLANO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION -- MY DAY TO DAY JOB
IS COMPETING FOR THIS JOB FOR
THE STATE -- AND CREATING
HELPING TO CREATE JOBS AND
INVESTMENT -- THIS IS A
FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
ADD ANOTHER TOOL -- TO COMPETING
WITH OTHER STATES AND SOMETIMES
OTHER COUNTRIES FOR THOSE SAME
JOBS AND IT IS A HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT -- THIS --
TOOL WILL ALLOW US. TO TARGET
THE TYPES OF MANUFACTURES --
THAT THAT WE ARE SAYING IN TERMS
OF DEMAND IN THE STATE
ESPECIALLY -- OUR TARGET AREA --
AND CLUSTER INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
THE BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY AND WE
THINK THIS IS VERY SIMILAR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- IS IN
FOOD AND BEVERAGE LIFE SCIENCES
AND ADVANCED MATERIALS -- WE SEE
THOSE AS AS CRITICAL FACTORS IN
GROWTH AND THOSE THAT REQUIRE
THAT SIZE OF A MANUFACTURING
FACILITY AND WHAT WE SEE IS A
SWEET SPOT.
AS ANYWHERE BETWEEN FIFTY
THOUSAND AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
ROUGHLY FIFTY EMPLOYEES TO FIVE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES THAT'S THE
BULK OF OUR PROSPECTS PROSPECTS
ARE WHAT WE CALL COMPANIES.
AND INVESTORS THAT ARE WANTING
TO GET INVOLVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET PLACE AND WE
WORK WITH ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS.
WE THINK THAT -- THIS BELT
REALLY FIT STOCK MARKET VERY
WELL TARGETED VERY WELL AND
LOWERS THE THRESHOLD -- THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY THE STEP TO BE ABLE
TO ATTRACT THOSE COMPANIES.
AND IT'S A VERY FUNCTIONAL
PROGRAM AS FAR AS WE CAN SEE IT.
ONE OF THE THE REASONS THAT THAT
IT'S BECOME SO COMPETITIVE -- IN
THE IN THE MARKETPLACE ROUTE THE
COUNTRY.
AS THAT ARE SURROUNDING STATES
ROUGHING VERY LARGE INCENTIVES
TO THESE COMPANIES.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS ONE MAKE
SURE THAT WE CREATE?
A GOOD PLACE FOR COMPANIES THAT
ARE GROWING WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TO EXPAND INTO AND
FOR US TO RETAIN THOSE COMPANIES
HERE.
THE REASON THAT WE CHOOSE THOSE
INDUSTRY CLUSTERS OF THREE THAT
I MENTIONED WERE BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE WE WE LEAD THE NATION AND
INNOVATION.
AND MANY OF THOSE COMPANIES ARE
GROWING IN OUR MOST INNOVATIVE
LOCATIONS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WHEN THEY GET INTO THE
MANUFACTURING STAGE OR WHEN THEY
WANTED THEIR MANUFACTURING.
THERE'S A PLACE FOR THEM IN THE
STATE.
AND THAT'S ONE SECONDLY WE
REALLY WANT TO BE COMPETITIVE
WHEN COMPANIES ARE LOOKING
THROUGHOUT THE NATION EVEN
INTERNATIONALLY TO LOCATE THEIR
NEXT LOCATION.
OFTENTIMES THEY LOOK AT REASONS
LIKE SKILLED LABOR LOCATION
THEIR CUSTOMER BASE OR SUPPLIER
BASE OR WHERE THEIR HEADQUARTERS
RELOCATED. TO LAND THOSE TYPES
OF FACILITIES WE HAVE ADVANTAGE
IN MANY OF THOSE FACTORS BUT
OFTEN TIMES THEY CAN'T USE OTHER
LOCATIONS AND STILL OPERATE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COMPETITIVE AGAINST OTHER
STATES THEY'RE GOING AFTER THE
SAME COMPANIES -- AT ALL LEAVE
IT THERE -- AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE BUT
FOR THOSE REASONS -- WE'RE VERY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE --
ANY EMOTION.
WHO?
I HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU A MANAGER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- AND ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA MYSELF WE
ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA'S WORK TO DEVELOP
ALTERNATIVE APPROACHES OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN USE TO SUPPORT.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY WITH SMALLER MISSED
MIDSIZED MANUFACTURERS WITH THIS
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS ALL BE
SUPPORTING HIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PRESENTING FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I'D
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HI RAMOS.
RAMOS SILOS REAVIS.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I THANK YOU.
MEASURES THAT.
EIGHT ZERO AND THEN THE ROOM
RESERVATION.
EVERYTHING ELSE [inaudible]
JAMES.
RIGHT MEMBERS STAY STILL WE
GOTTA DO THE BILLS ARE ON CALL.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME AND MY OKAY --
IT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE BONTA VOTE IS
CURRENTLY FOR TO CALL THE
BOERNER HORVATH.
A FORTY NINE YEAH A FORTY NINE
HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
[inaudible]
THREE OF US SIGH.
MEASURES OUT.
SIX TO TWO ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN CHIU IN
SANTIAGO HER VOTE IS
[inaudible]
FOR TWO BOERNER HORVATH -- YES
SORRY I WAS NOT HERE DURING THE
HEARING -- I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE BILL AND
THE USE OF TAXPAYER MONEY -- BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT ALL OF OUR
BILLS ARE USUALLY WORKS IN
PROGRESS.
AND I DO WANT TO GET THE AUTHORS
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUE
WORKING.
ESPECIALLY WITH OUR COMMITTEE
BANKS AND CREDIT UNIONS I THINK
THE I KNOW MY DISTRICT THEY
OFFER OUR COMMITTEES SO MUCH
STRENGTH.
I DO HEAR THE NEED FOR PUBLIC
BANKS AND SOME OTHER PARTS WERE
STATE SO.
I HOPE THE OFFICE CONTINUE
WORKING AND SO I RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE DIFFERENTLY ON THE
FLOOR BUT I DO WANT YOU TO KEEP
MOVING ON THE SPELL.
SO I BOERNER HORVATH I NINETY
FIVE TO TWO ITEM NUMBER -- TEN
LET'S SEE AB NINE FORTY EIGHT
KALRA.
A CURRENT VOTE.
FOUR ZERO LACKEY AYE.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER ABOUT HI
WERNER HER ABOUT THAT.
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH.
OUT IMMENSELY.
EIGHT ZERO PHONE. SEVENTEEN A.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY NINE BLOOM AT
THE CURRENT VOTERS [inaudible]
FOR ONE LACKEY.
LACKEY DO BOERNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
NOT LOADING.
LOVE PHONING RUNNER HER A ****
BATH NOT VOTING THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH.
BOTH [inaudible]
FIVE TWO OUT.
THE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB.FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE GRAYSON
OUR CURRENT VOTERS.
FOUR ZERO LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
BURNER HERVE.
BOERNER HORVATH.
THREE OF US.
IS RIVERSIDE ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS I OUT -- EIGHT ZERO PHONE
NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WEEKS -- VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BOERNER HORVATH NOT
VOTING BOERNER HORVATH NOT
VOTING THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I SEVEN ZERO ITEM
FILE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY BECAUSE HIS ME.
SHE'S BEEN.
I'M TWENTY FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN FRIEDMAN. FOR ABOUT
THREE TO AGUIAR-CURRY I'M.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BOERNER HORVATH
I REMEMBER HER BATH I THREE OF
US NEWS RIVERSIDE.
BILLS AT SIX TO EITHER A PHONE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ROBERT REAVIS --
VOTES.
FOR ONE BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH.
BOTH THE US -- SIX ONE BILLS OUT.
AND NOW WE NEED TO DO ADAMS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HELLO DIANA AND STARTING WITH --
ITEM NUMBER WHEN A. B. ELEVEN
CHIU -- LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
BOERNER HORVATH YEAH HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I ITEM NUMBER.
TWO EXCUSE ME ITEM NUMBER -- TWO
AB ONE FOUR WENT COOPER BOERNER
HORVATH HI BOERNER HORVATH I
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FIVE OH
EIGHT CHIU.
BURNER HERVE HI UNDER HER BREATH
HI THREE OF US THREE OF US SIDE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SIX HUNDRED
CHIU.
BURGER HERVE HI BOERNER HORVATH.
THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US SIGH.
ITEM NUMBER -- SIX WE'VE GOT TO
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CLUES ITEM SIX AB EIGHT TO FIVE
AT ELEVEN NINE EIGHTY NINE NINE
FOUR ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB TEN
EIGHTY NINE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB TWELVE TWENTY AND ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BURNER HERVE.
I BOERNER HORVATH I THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIDE [inaudible]
HE HE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT
FIVE FOUR MAYES.
BURNER HERVE HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
BONTA.
BURNER HER VAST EARLY BRING HER
VERIFY THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US SIGH.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TWELVE
SIXTY NINE BLANCA RUBIO BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER BACK.
BOERNER HORVATH I ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY ONE
GRAY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE THREE OF US.
NEWS.
I VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
GRAYSON.
LACKEY HI LACKEY AYE BOERNER
HORVATH -- HER ABOUT THAT I
THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US SIDE [inaudible]
ON TWENTY MY LOOK IS COMING
APART.
I'VE GOT YEARS [inaudible]
NINE PROJECTS OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN SHOWS
LACKEY.
NO LACKEY NO BOERNER HORVATH.
NOT LOADING RUNNER HER VAST NOT
VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN FRIEDMAN.
THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US SIGH.
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY SIX AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE TO LACKEY.
HI LACKEY HI BOERNER HORVATH NOT
LOADING BOERNER HORVATH NOT
VOTING THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ADJOURNED